What's you're about to hear is part five
of a multipart series on the first world
war.
If you haven't caught the earlier
episodes and you want to know what's
going on,
it might be worth your time to go back
and listen to them.
If you've already heard them or you
don't care about stuff like that,
then please join us for part five of
blueprint for Armageddon,
be some bus seven,
19,
41 date which will live in infamy.
It's
perfect.
The events,
the figure out,
Lord,
from this time and place I take pride in
the words,
been the Alina tear down.
Welcome this kind of examination because
people have got to know whether or not
their president question,
well,
I'm not a crop.
If we dig deep in our district and our I
don't remember,
but we are not descended from fearful of
man.
It's hardcore history.
Earlier in this story,
we brought up the often quoted phrase
that one man's terrorist is another
man's freedom fighter,
and we brought it up in relation to the
man who actually launched the incident
that sparked the first world war,
the Serbian nationalist Gabriela
apprenticeship who killed the heir to
the Austro-hungarian,
thrown the archduke Franz Ferdinand,
thereby precipitating the crisis that
actually started the war.
The austro-hungarian saw apprenticeship
unequivocally as a terrorist is Serbian
nationalist brethren revered him.
In fact,
not that long ago,
a statue was unveiled in,
sorry,
Eva,
where the assassination happened,
honoring the assassin.
So your view of the motives of these
people really depends on,
you know,
who's doing the viewing at the time.
Print chip is far from the only figure
in this story who falls into a similar
category.
The United States is dealing with one
themselves.
In 1916,
for example,
in January of 1916,
just as the German military is putting
the finishing touches on what will
become the quintessentially horrible
battle of Verdun,
the quintessentially century style
battle,
the killing field created by mass
artillery.
The meat grinder that will be verdun the
United States is attention is taken off
European affairs by events going on in
northern Mexico.
Mexico has been convulsed by revolution
since 19.
10.
Northern Mexico often becomes one of
these hot beds of unrest and
instability,
and in January 19,
16,
gunman waylay a train in northern
Mexico.
Now this is at the tail end of the era
where train robberies are not uncommon,
but these gunman aren't there to rob the
train.
In fact,
as they go up and down the aisles,
they leave the Mexican nationals,
the locals alone,
but they pull off every American from
the train that they find.
They find 16 to 18 workers.
Employees have a US corporation
operating in northern Mexico.
They take these Americans off the train,
line them up in front of the tracks,
forced them to strip,
and then execute them.
We know this because one of the
Americans feigned death and got away and
told his story.
I believe he said that the bodies were
also mutilated.
This very well may have been an attempt
to provoke a response on the part of
theU ,
s government,
and if so,
the mutilation is just part of adding
fuel to the fire,
a little something to make the US
government even angrier at this event
and things had been escalating to this
point in northern Mexico for some time
groups affiliated with these same gunman
had been attacking isolated Americans at
murder.
Here,
a murder there,
a rape here or there,
but this was upping the ante
significantly.
Nonetheless,
the maneuver accomplished nothing
concrete of note,
so a couple of months later in March 19,
16,
this group of gunmen or outlaws or
revolutionaries,
if you're looking at it from another
point of view up the ante again and
cross the US Mexican border in strength
more than 100 go after American interest
on the US side of the border,
culminating in that in an attack on a US
city,
Columbus,
New Mexico.
In the middle of the night,
they roar through this town,
shooting,
looting,
killing,
and burning.
18 Americans will be killed.
The town will be burned down and the
bandits or terrorists or
revolutionaries,
depending on your point of view,
will escape back into Mexico.
Now,
as a side note,
then as now,
Americans are heavily armed people and
those bandits paid a high price for,
um,
what they did that town,
many more of them died than Americans
died.
Nonetheless,
the idea that you were safe and
protected within the confines of the US
borders was shattered in a way that
hadn't happened since the Apache wars in
that region had ended 30 years
previously,
the attackers have Columbus,
New Mexico.
We're affiliated with a Mexican
revolutionary leader known to history,
not his actual name as Poncho via now
via almost certainly wasn't in Columbus,
New Mexico.
He had been hurt not that long before,
but these gunman were part of his men.
And if you look at this superficially,
there's a lot of similarities between
Poncho via and Osama bin Ladin.
Now,
this is not said to insult Mexican folks
who still in some cases revere Poncho
via his memory,
but it's hard to avoid that,
at least from the American side of
things.
There are rough analogies that you can
point to,
for example,
like Bin Ladin via had once upon a time
been a friend,
did the United States,
someone we thought we could work with
and use and an arm and train and help.
In fact,
after that attack in Columbus,
New Mexico when it was obvious that some
response had to be put together,
President Woodrow Wilson,
the American leader,
launches and expedition,
a military expedition into northern
Mexico,
sends about 5,000
men across the border.
There was a a,
an official leader,
but he wasn't the guy who actually lead
things on the ground.
The guy who led things on the ground was
an American general named John pershing,
who was nicknamed by the way was Black
Jack and a year before to show you how
close the United States had been divya
at one time,
the year before,
pershing launches this expedition to go
capture this terrorist Poncho via.
He loses his whole family in a terrible
house,
fire.
Pershing's wife and his little girls,
they were little children,
died in the fire,
and as he was wallowing in almost soul
crushing grief amongst the condolence
letters he received was one from this
Poncho via person that he would be
chasing about a year later.
There are a lot of interesting things
that this expedition across the border
shows,
not just Mexicans,
not just Americans,
but European observers everywhere who
all throughout this war have wondered
what the United States is going to do
and what their capabilities are.
All of a sudden they have a US military
force in the field to have a look at and
measure up against the standards of
early 20th century.
And to be honest,
the American endeavor looks like a
disaster.
It doesn't look a whole lot different
than efforts 30 years ago to the year
that were launched to go after the last
Apache leader to,
you know,
break off theU ,
s reservation system with 40 warriors
and go into some of this same country
that via and his men were hiding in.
It looks like a very similar army.
Just add some motor cars,
which is what the US military was
employing to give them some mobility and
some airplanes that look like they were
invented by the Wright brothers
themselves.
In fact,
the pilots were trained in some cases by
Orville and Wilbur Wright.
That's how recent,
you know,
airplane development is and the US
planes are so rickety and so new that
none of them survived the first week or
two of operation down there.
One of the more interesting aspects to
the US operations in northern Mexico to
go get Poncho via is the US doesn't know
northern Mexico in their maps are all
wrong and so they have leading their
army as scouts Apaches,
and these Apache's include allegedly
some Apache scouts who were amongst the
Apache Scouts that hunted down Geronimo
30 years before.
In fact,
there's quite a connection to a lot of
these people involved in this conflict.
John General,
John Black.
Jack pershing was a junior officer
trailing Geronimo.
Thirty years before these events.
It's believed that Poncho via wanted to
get the US to attack northern Mexico and
bog them down in this insane country to
fight in insane terrain,
insane weather conditions,
and thereby raise his standing amongst
several revolutionary leaders vying for
control of the instability in Mexico
that had been going on since the 1910
revolution began,
but if Europeans already had a stereo,
typical view of the United States is a
nation of cowboys and an army myered in
an almost old west sort of approach.
The expedition into northern Mexico to
capture Poncho via did nothing to
disabuse them of that stereotype to many
European observers.
It wasn't just a frontier army that the
United States of America looked like
they possessed.
It was kind of a frontier mentality to
go along with it,
and one of the things that was really
hard for European planners is that on
both sides of the war,
by the way,
is that it began to look more and more
like the United States was going to play
this huge role in the war.
But what did that even mean?
The United States had never sent over
lots of men to go fight in some European
war.
It was alien,
the American experience,
so would they actually do that?
There were a lot of European observers
that thought that even if the US got
into the war,
they wouldn't send troops.
Americans don't do that,
and that's part of what makes that pre
first world war.
United States of America hard for modern
Americans to understand.
You know,
if you know your grandparents,
if you're lucky enough to have met your
grandparents,
you can explain them to other people.
You begin to get a real feel for what
they're about,
even if they're very different than you
are,
but they're real.
You can relate to them.
The United States of 1916 is like a
great,
great grandparents.
You can read all about it you want,
but those people are different from you
and you don't understand them and you
never knew them.
You never knew anyone like them.
The modern United States of America is
the most intervention is great power in
the world.
In 1916,
it was the opposite and it had a long
mythology connected to its very founding
that reinforced the idea that that's the
way American foreign policy should be
before the United States could involve
itself in the first world war.
It had to somehow deal with this lasting
legacy dating all the way back to,
you know,
pre-revolutionary days,
but why don't you just start with the
farewell speech of the first American
President,
George Washington,
a speech that was re-read allowed once a
year in patriotic fervor,
a speech that told Americans to stay out
of Europe's wars
in the middle of his goodbye speech to
the American people in his resigning
from public life.
He said,
quote,
the great rule of conduct for us in
regard to foreign nations is an
extending our commercial relations to
have with them as little political
connection as possible.
So far as we've already formed
engagements,
let them be fulfilled with perfect good
faith here.
Let us stop.
Europe has a set of primary interest,
which to us have none or very remote
relation.
Hence,
she must be engaged in frequent
controversies that causes of which are
essentially foreign to our concerns,
hence therefore it must be unwise in us
to implicate ourselves by artificial
ties in the ordinary vicissitudes of her
politics were the ordinary combinations
in collisions of her friendships or
enmities.
Our detached and distance situation
invites and enables us to pursue a
different course if we remain one people
under inefficient government.
The period is not far off when we may
defy material injury from external
annoyance,
when we may take such an attitude as
well,
cause the neutrality we may at any time
resolve upon to be scrupulously
respected when belligerent nations under
the impossibility of making acquisitions
upon us will lightly hazard the giving
us provocation which we may choose,
peace or war as our interest guided by
justice shall council.
Why forgo the advantages of so peculiar
situation?
Why quit our own to stand upon foreign
ground?
Why?
By interweaving our destiny,
would that have any part of Europe
entangle our peace and prosperity and
the toils of European ambition,
rival ship interest,
humor,
or caprice.
It is our true policy to steer clear of
permanent alliances with any portion of
the foreign world and quote,
when Americans revere those people like
Demi Gods and that speech has re-read to
American school children and re-read
publicly once a year.
On the anniversary.
You can see that if you were an American
who thought that the United States
should enter the first world war,
you have a lot of mythology to overcome
a lot of ingrained ideological training.
Unless you think that those are
revolutionary sentiments.
You know from the beginning of a nation.
A lot of times people are very emotional
and sentimental and lofty and
idealistic.
When a nation is founded and that cools
over time.
Forty five years after Washington gave
that speech,
the current president of the United
States,
a second generation guy like George w
dot Bush,
kind of John Quincy Adams gave another
one of these foreign policy speeches,
coining a famous phrase that Americans
would use ever since going abroad in
search of monsters to slay the very
antithesis of the idea that the United
States government is going to use as the
slogan to get the United States into the
first world war.
John Quincy Adams in the middle of one
of his speech is dealing with what the
country's foreign policy should be.
Forty five years after Washington gave
his speech said,
quote,
speaking about the United States here in
the Feminine Pronoun,
by the way,
quote,
wherever standard of freedom and pendens
has been or shall be,
unfurled there will her heart,
her benedictions and her prayers be but
she goes not abroad in search of
monsters to destroy.
She is the well wisher to the freedom
and independence of all.
She's the champion and vindicator only
of her own.
She will recommend the general cause by
the countenance of her voice and the
sympathy of her.
Example,
she well knows that by once enlisting
under other banners than her own were
they even the banners of foreign
independence.
She would involve herself beyond the
power of extrication in all the wars of
interest and intrigue of individual
avarice and Vienna ambition which
assumed the colors and you serve
standard of freedom.
The fundamental maxims of her policy
would insensibly changed from liberty to
force the front lead upon her brows
would no longer being with the ineffable
splendor of freedom and independence,
but in its stead would soon be
substituted and imperial diadem flashing
and false and tarnished luster.
The murky radiance of dominion and
power.
She might become the dictate trust of
the world.
She would be no longer the ruler of our
own spirit.
And to quote this kind of historical
legacy of idealism,
this mythology,
if you will,
that Americans had reinforced all the
time,
provided a natural counterweight for
patriots to choose a side that seemed to
be opposite of what patriotism normally
implied in Europe.
Patriotism was a key part of
nationalism.
It's the grabbing of the flag.
Sometimes I'm pushing your nation's
glory and and,
and,
and borders farther that was true in the
United States to everybody's human.
The same sorts of,
you know,
rallying cries,
often work on Americans that work on
other people,
but you also had this refuge for people
who were patriotic and who could take an
anti intervention is position and couch
it as much in the flag as those who were
suggesting that real patriots,
you know,
joined up and fought the Spanish in
Cuba.
For example,
as Theodore Roosevelt,
the former president of the United
States in and volunteer for that Spanish
American war know,
kept taking the opposite viewpoint that
the United States of America lived in a
different time than those founding
fathers and that real patriotism and
real men would be ready to join.
The first world war in the United States
is looking like a coward by not being
involved with theater.
Roosevelt is not the president in 1916,
but he's needling the guy who is a guy
from the other party,
a Democrat named Woodrow Wilson,
one of the most enigmatic and hard to
get your mind around figures in this
story.
And part of the reason that Wilson is so
hard to figure out is because the
historians don't agree,
the majority of historians have always
taken Wilson sort of at face value and
portray him as one of the most,
if not the most idealistic president in
American history.
A guy who is so peace loving,
he's virtually gone ds and a man who did
everything he could to keep the United
States out of war and to fight for this
wonderful just fair piece afterwards.
That's the sort of the the goodwills and
I divided them into the goodwill Wilson
and the Evil Woodrow Wilson in terms of
how some historians see them.
The other historical campus,
smaller but very vociferous,
very loud and growing.
And those are the people who for a lot
of domestic reasons,
it should be pointed out,
don't like Woodrow Wilson at all.
And often you know,
a scribe,
sinister or venal motives for him doing
what he was doing.
And see a man who wanted to get involved
with the allies who sought piece for his
own vainglorious reasons,
who was a schemer and a person who hid
behind a mask that promised you know,
idealism and peace,
and there were German,
for example,
who were never falling for that story,
that Wilson was some Bambi,
deer in the headlights on the world
stage and always thought that that was
just a really good mask that his
machiavellian scheming hid behind making
him even more dangerous.
Right?
His disguise was better.
Nonetheless.
I'm not going to wait as a fan of
history into which Wilson I believe was
the real Wilson,
but look at how it adds to the
uncertainty of the whole thing.
What is this guy all about now?
I personally think that the air of
mystery that surrounds Woodrow Wilson
makes him a more interesting character.
I mean,
he's a giant enigma that's quickly
becoming perhaps the most important
single individual in the story by the
end of 1916.
But you know,
I didn't have to live with them to the
people in this tale.
He's not a character.
He's a world leader.
And what the United States does in this
war might decide the conflict.
So the stakes couldn't be higher.
Winston Churchill writing after the
first world war,
he got a very interesting view on
Wilson.
It's hard to describe.
You can see he's.
He's.
He's walking on eggshells sometimes,
but he says this guy,
we didn't know anything about him.
I mean,
he comes out of academia basically,
and he says,
only in the American system do you get
these people that can come from totally
outside politics as complete unknowns.
He goes,
in Britain,
such a prime minister would have spent
years in the,
in the House of Commons or what have
you,
you know,
working their way up.
They would be in the public eye the
whole time.
They would be a known quantity by the
time they got the top job.
He marvels at the fact that Woodrow
Wilson is an unknown,
you know,
the most powerful man in the United
States and quickly becoming the most
important single figure in the war.
Churchill writes about Wilson in all his
strength and his weakness in his
nobility,
in his foibles.
He was in spite of his long academic
record and brief governorship and
unknown and unmeasured quantity to the
mighty people who made him their ruler.
In 1912,
still more was he a mystery to the world
at large writing with every sense of
respect,
it seems no exaggeration to pronounce
that the action of the United States
with its repercussions on the history of
the world depended during the awful
period of armageddon upon the workings
of this man's mind and spirit to the
exclusion of almost every other factor
and that he played a part in the fate of
nations in comparatively more direct and
personal than any other man and quote.
That's why we're talking about the
United States so much in this episode,
and one of the other parts of the Wilson
story that are interesting is when you
get human beings in positions of great
power and authority,
oftentimes their little quirks or
idiosyncrasies or characteristics can
make or break history.
I mean,
we all have little things about us that
might be quirky or idiosyncratic,
but because we're not in positions of
and authority,
they don't really make much of a
difference.
If if adults,
Hitler leaves the military after the
first world war is a decorated corporal
and goes and opens up a sausage shop in
Munich,
his quirks and idiosyncrasies and
characteristics don't make a big
difference on the world stage.
You probably never hear about them.
They only affect,
you know the people he has contact with,
but you take that same figure and you
make them the iron fisted dictator of
one of the Great Twentieth Century
nations on the planet and all of a
sudden that man's quirks and
idiosyncrasies and characteristics can
create a deadly holocaust.
Now,
Wilson didn't have those kinds of
characteristics.
At least I haven't heard that even from
the evil Wilson camp,
but he did have characteristics that
impacted this whole situation.
One was he was almost always convinced
that he was right.
No paraphrasing here,
but he said something to the effect of
once that he felt pity for people who
had different opinions than him because
he knew they were wrong.
You can watch the way he operates in
government and he's a supremely gifted
politician,
but a lot of times those people are
unwilling to let other men carry out
their policies and their programs
because they know they could do it
better and you can see that from Wilson
to after the war,
the man is going to become the British
prime minister.
A guy named David Lloyd.
George will have to sit by the French
military leader on one side and the
president of the United States on the
other and he said it was like sitting
between Napoleon on one side and that
was the French leader and Jesus on the
other.
That was woodrow Wilson and Jesus was
probably more the way Wilson saw himself
is what George was trying to convey than
the way others saw him.
Negotiating with a savior can require a
deft touch and Wilson's demeanor and
sort of professorial air of superiority
and that I'm always right.
Kind of save your air about him.
Sometimes rubbed some people the wrong
way and certainly influenced the way
that Wilson handled things.
And there were several big challenges to
American neutrality that Wilson had to
deal with and all we're especially acute
in 1916.
One involved American lives,
the other involved American money and
the last involved in American election
start with perhaps the number one most
obvious things,
sucking the United States into the
whirlpool,
the vortex of the first world war.
And it was something that was so
obviously doing that you can feel the
momentum even now reading the history
books about this sort of slide into a
war because the German's use of this
thoroughly modern science fiction almost
weapon.
The submarine and the submarine was
creating conditions where a couple of
Americans here and there,
every now and then we're dying on ships.
Every now and then.
It was worse than when the Lusitania
went down,
which was a titanic like liner to a
submarine torpedo.
More than 100 Americans went down with
that ship.
How long would any nation put up with
that?
And the problem is is that the US would
complain.
It works something out with the Germans.
Tensions would drop.
And then a month later,
month and a half later,
boom,
it happens again.
It's like a sore that kept getting poked
with a needle before it was able to heal
and yet we'll send,
kept making the conditions more and more
impossible to fulfill.
So those anti wilsonian historians who
say,
no,
you misunderstand.
Wilson was trying to create the
conditions that the Germans couldn't
help but violate and then get the United
States into the war and then claim it
was foist upon the Americans.
For example,
Wilson at one point in his
administration with high minded rhetoric
and speeches,
was defending the right of an American
passenger.
And remember Americans could travel on
American ships or neutral ships and and,
and,
and at certain times the German's had
had sworn they wouldn't go after those,
but Wilson was defending the right of an
American to travel on a British ship or
a French ship,
right?
A belligerent ship and defending their
right to travel on a belligerent ship,
even if it was carrying munitions and
defending their right to travel on a
belligerent ship carrying munitions that
also was carrying defensive guns on it.
That could hurt a submarine.
That's when the Germans would throw up
their hands and say that to them.
Wilson didn't look like an honest
broker.
That's the kind of guy you're going to
trust with peace.
I mean,
look,
he did and their attitude was he doesn't
hold the British to any of these same
rules.
He's trying to hold us to.
The British had a blockade going.
They didn't use submarines.
They use minds and they would mind the
North Sea and they create these zones
where they would stop every line that
they could get their hands on,
make it go to a British port,
search it,
you know,
decided was contraband and Wilson and
his administration were pretty darn
quiet about that.
The occasional protest and nothing more
to the Germans.
This looked like rank hypocrisy and to
anti wilsonian historians.
To them,
it looks like a perfect example to show
that really these ideals that Wilson
professed were very conveniently ignored
when they ran against what he wanted.
There were other complications that
affected what he wanted to.
One had to do with perhaps the,
the most ancient of motivations of all
economic ones.
The United States was making a killing
on the first world war by 1916,
pardon the pun,
and it began to affect its entire
outlook toward the conflict.
It's one of the longest term impacts,
by the way,
are the first world war that the results
of which we live with everyday in our
modern world,
but it's sort of sinks beneath the
radar.
It's a lot easier to understand the
submarine warfare question than it is
the economic transfer of wealth from
Europe to the United States.
This war was so total in its stakes that
these,
the,
the sides fighting it found no good
reason not to spend every bit of
capital.
They had to win it.
When Britain started this war in 1914,
she was the richest country in the
world.
It was not long after the era where the
phrase the sun never sets on the British
empire was in vogue.
The British empire controlled directly
or indirectly about a third of the
planet.
She was wealthy and she'd been sucking
up a lot of the wealth of Europe for 100
years.
During Europe's most dominant time
period on the world stage.
The era of colonies and Post Napoleonic
splendor,
right?
The Victorian Age,
and yet when 19,
14 started,
the British didn't just have their own
bills to pay in this most expensive of
all human conflicts.
They underwrote their dominions.
The Canada's the Australia is the New
Zealand's.
They underwrote countries like Italy and
paid for almost all their costs during
the war.
The Russians to it.
A lot of other small powers.
The amounts of money that we're changing
hands.
I've seen so many different attempts to
come up with it.
All you have to know though is it's
ungodly.
At one point it was like $75,
million dollars a week in 1916.
Money.
I mean it's,
it's incredible.
The wealth transfer and when Britain
started buying stuff from places like
the United States,
when the war started,
they used cash and gold.
By 1916.
We're talking about credit and debt and
if you wanted to think of New York as
being like a giant vacuum cleaner with
the sucking hose and in London just
sucking out a hundred years of
civilizational wealth acquirement it's
not a bad image in four years.
The center of world banking as we sit in
an earlier episode is transferred from
London to New York,
same thing for the center of World
Trade,
and all of a sudden by 1916,
Wilson is acquiring a huge amount of
power because the United States is the
banker and these people are beginning to
owe it money.
The British realized that at the same
time,
historian justice don't key rights,
um,
about Wilson's new ability because he
controls the purse strings of the allied
side in this war to dictate any sort of
outcome he might want.
He writes,
quote,
if Wilson desire to force the allies to
the peace table,
the opportunity had come and he knew it.
On October third,
1916,
a British interdepartmental conference
noted the nation's utter dependence upon
American munitions,
steel,
foodstuffs,
oil,
wheat,
cotton,
and lubricants.
We're the United States to engage in
economic reprisals.
Britain's war effort would practically
of the 5 million pounds sterling needed
to prosecute the war reported a
government economist John Maynard
Keynes.
Later that week,
2 million must come from North America,
quote in a few months time claimed the
treasury official,
the American public will be in a
position to dictate to this country on
matters that affect us more nearly than
them.
And quote,
the author continues,
quote Reginald Mckenna,
Chancellor of the Exchequer concurred
with canes telling the cabinet.
In late October quote,
by next June or earlier,
the president of the American republic
will be in a position if he wishes to
dictate his own terms to us and quote.
The author says,
at the end of December,
Mckenna told an American journalist that
Wilson could quote,
force the allies to their knees anytime
in a moment.
And quote the United States in late 1916
is like a bank in Europe and especially
Great Britain who was the financial
underwriter of the whole allied war
effort.
Basically owes is the bank money that
gives the bank a lot of power,
but there's an old line in banking that
if you owe the bank a little bit of
money,
it's the bank who has the power.
But if you owe a bank a lot of money,
that power goes back to the person that
owes the money because the bank now has
a vested interest in seeing that that
person survives so that they can pay
them back.
The United States is beginning to worry
about what happens if we can't sell this
war material anymore,
or if we can't get paid for the credit,
we're loaning out.
The US has had a very uncomfortable sort
of prosperity descend on it in the past
two years.
In 1914 when the first world war breaks
out,
the American economy is not doing well
at all.
By 1916,
halfway through the year,
the American economy is humming along
nicely.
Thank you.
Some historians have actually called the
United States a nation of war
profiteers.
At this point,
if if Wilson was successful in,
in creating a negotiated peace at the
end of 1916 somehow,
and you wanted it at that point,
declare the winner in the first world
war.
Do you know which two powers I'd
nominate it nominate Japan and the
United States and the Japanese hardly
fought in the war at all.
And by the end of 1916,
the United States hadn't fought in the
war at all.
Those are the victors.
The Japanese get involved in 1914 for
purely opportunistic reasons.
They can take over all the German
holdings in their neck of the woods and
the Germans can't do anything.
So you get all this territory for
basically nothing.
The United States is selling stuff,
amazing amounts of stuff.
The both sides need everything in.
The Americans will sell to anybody,
but they can't get their stuff to
Germany.
They still made loans and tried to get
stuff to them.
But by and large,
the British blockade had shut that down,
but you could still trade with the
British.
And we did.
And the idea that that trade might
somehow go away,
began to filter into the halls of
government the prosperity that this war
brought.
The United States created another vested
interest.
And there are economic historians and
historians who look more at,
um,
economic motivations for why countries
do things that pointed this as the most
important undercurrent of why the war
was really going the way it was.
Now,
there's another reason too,
and this is a very pedestrian,
but woodrow Wilson in 1916 was an
American president that faced an
election campaign,
and this is where the,
the real uniqueness of the American
situation has demonstrated what does the
president do,
who's running for reelection,
and the big elephant in the living room
situation is this war in Europe when
he's facing an electorate made up of
immigrants,
of people on both sides of that
conflict.
In the old world,
historian David Stevenson does a great
job breaking down,
you know,
the ethnic makeup of the United States
and showing you all these weird problems
that the United States would have if it
got into this conflict that other
nations wouldn't.
For example,
he points out that large chunks of the
United States is made up of immigrants
from some of these countries.
The two main groups that are,
that are problematic for anyone who
wants to talk about siding with the
allies in this first world war,
our German Americans and Irish
Americans.
Here's what Stevenson writes,
quote,
support for American neutrality was
strongest in the interior and especially
the middle West where the German
Americans were concentrated,
of whom only an insignificant minority
favored intervention on the side of the
central powers of a US population.
In 1910 of $92 million,
he writes,
two and a half million had been born in
Germany and five point seven,
$8 million had one or two German born
parents in 1917,
522 German language.
Newspapers and journals were published
in the United States.
And German Americans were the largest
ethnic group in Baltimore,
Pittsburgh,
Chicago,
Detroit,
Los Angeles,
and San Francisco.
And quote,
he then goes on to talk about Irish
Americans who,
and we didn't even get into this as,
as a person of partly Irish American
descent.
I would have just gone off on,
on the whole,
uh,
Irish uprising,
the Easter uprising that happened,
uh,
during this conflict of which the
Germans may have had a role.
Uh,
the British considered this an
especially nasty stab in the bank back
since it happened.
During wartime reacted by killing a lot
of Irish or it depends on if you're
British or not,
killing Irish leaders in the uprising,
infuriating a Americans of Irish
descent,
of which there were a ton,
and so if you're a politician like
Woodrow Wilson,
you have to deal with the fact that you
have a ton of voters who were the only
people that can keep you in power,
who are really interested in not joining
the side of the allies maybe or anyone.
The slogan for the Nineteen 16 campaign
that's most remembered on the Woodrow
Wilson side is the one that said,
quote,
he kept us out of war and quote.
That was a slogan that appealed to most
Americans.
Wilson's peace oriented Secretary of
State,
William Jennings.
Bryan had said at one point that New
York and the major newspapers want war.
The rest of the country wants peace,
and if you're an American planner,
it's interesting how many times you can
open up the history books and see
references to the uncertainty of what
these large immigrant descendant
populations would do if the US joined
the allied side in the war.
If you have two point $5,
million Americans born in Germany,
what are they going to do when war
breaks out or these potential
terrorists,
and so it became quite an interesting
issue before the conflict involved the
United States as to whether or not the
United States was unified and the idea
that it would go fight on any side in
this conflict.
Now what do you do if you're one of
these American figures,
perhaps one of the top politicians who
wants the United States to get into the
first world war?
What's your strategy for dealing with
these Americans who don't want to go?
Who Want to stay neutral?
It may be a huge majority of the country
during this time period.
If you're a politician and you're used
to sort of putting your finger in the
wind and going in the direction that
people want to go,
but they don't want to go in the
direction you want to go.
You know?
What's your strategy for dealing with
that?
The strategy of several of the top
political figures in this period was to
play the Super Patriot card and to
accuse Americans who disagreed with the
idea of getting into the war as being
disloyal mean.
Take for example,
the former president Theodore Roosevelt
in 1916.
Roosevelt is not running for president,
but he's campaigning and helping the guy
who is from his own party,
the Republican that's challenging.
Woodrow Wilson in the November 1916
elections.
Now,
Roosevelt is in an interesting position
here.
He desperately wants to get into the
first world war.
He thinks it's cowardly that the US is
staying out.
He has publicly slamming Woodrow Wilson
from pillar to post for not wanting to
get involved in the conflict.
He compares him on the campaign trail to
punch US pilot.
In fact,
he says Wilson's neutrality is worse
than ponchos pilot.
Remember Pontius pilot?
He's the Roman official who in the Bible
Sentences Jesus to be crucified.
That's a pretty good political slam at
the president,
isn't it?
But then Roosevelt makes a point to go
after what at the time were referred to
as hyphenated Americans.
You know,
people who had a hyphen between their
description of their nationality,
German hyphen Americans,
Irish Hyphen Americans,
Jewish Hyphen Americans,
and there was a feeling amongst a lot of
Americans that these people weren't real
Americans,
that they had conflicted loyalties and
there was also this idea that you had to
have 100 percent loyalty to the United
States and any consideration with what
the ancestral home might want was
equivalent in Roosevelt's own words to
being a moral trader.
And so how do you deal with the fact
that you want the United States to do
something that most Americans don't want
it to?
Do?
You Slam as traitorous those who oppose
it.
Now Wilson was in a bit of a different
position because not only many
historians think,
did he not want to get in the war?
Maybe,
but he certainly had a public persona of
not wanting to get into the war,
but Wilson didn't like anyone who
disagreed with them.
And you can see Wilson's attitude about
those who would oppose his policies even
in peace time,
in his response to a telegram he
received from an Irish American.
There's that hyphenation,
right?
Irish hyphened,
American leader.
In September 19,
16,
a guy named Jeremiah O'leary and o'leary
was telling Wilson something that's,
that's perfectly logical.
He's explaining to him that all of these
moves that seem to lean toward the
allied side of the war are going to be
issues in the campaign,
right?
There's nothing controversial about
that.
O'Leary's cable said,
quote,
your foreign policy is your failure to
secure compliance with all American
rights.
You're leaning and see with the British
Empire your approval of war loans.
The ammunition traffic are issues in
this campaign and quote,
most American political figures would
understand that.
That's just someone from the opposition
explaining that that's how the American
political system works.
There's nothing wrong with that,
especially not in peace time.
Wilson wrote back to Jeremiah O'leary,
quote,
your telegram received.
I would feel deeply mortified to have
you or anybody like you vote for me
since you have access to many disloyal
Americans and I have not.
I will ask you to convey this message to
them and quote.
In other words,
to simply oppose Woodrow Wilson's
policies in peace time doesn't make you
part of the loyal opposition.
It makes you disloyal.
What is a president who feels that peace
time opposition to peacetime policies is
disloyal?
What's a guy like that going to do when
it's no longer peace time?
Well,
here's a little preview to think about.
We still have laws on the books that
were currently enforcing and using in
the war on terror that our president
Wilson's response to critics who
addressed him negatively in war time.
Unless you think that this is an
overreaction though or maybe misplaced
priorities,
it's worth noticing that in late 1916,
there are several belligerence in this
who are most threatened not by foreign
armies defeating their armies on the
battlefield,
but by their own populations collapsing
from within morally or in terms of their
unity and support for the government.
In an era where more and more of the
armies of these modern 20th century
states could take a punch and stay on
the battlefield fighting year after
year,
the Chink in the national armor for some
of these states was proving to be the
home front and nowhere by the way,
do you see a better example of the
sweeping away of the 19th century
mentality than in how the Home Front is
viewed?
The Home Front of course as a shorthand
word for the people back living their
civilian lives and you know,
supporting the war economy and helping
to make munitions and all the stuff that
helps support those troops at the front.
In the 19th century in Europe's more
genteel sort of era,
there were all sorts of peace
conventions and laws of war meetings to
do,
to help spare civilians and keep them as
far away from the suffering of war as
possible.
That was considered to be a civilization
will advance.
It's interesting and and telling I think
to watch that sort of genteel peace time
mentality crash into the rocks of
reality that are the 20th century where
all of those rules look like rainbows
and Unicorns.
I mean from another time we're gassing
each other with know insecticide,
human humic decide can we say that you
design something you use to spray on
human beings like their aunts,
you know,
there go the 19th century genteel
conventions right there and the same
applied to civilians.
We have the Germans,
you know,
using zipline raids to drop bombs on,
on British cities.
I mean there goes those 19th century
conventions right there and the German
bombers who do it,
you know,
site this idea that everyone's a
combatant.
Now if the home front is a legitimate
target in total war,
then so are the civilians going about
their daily lives in places like Germany
and Austria,
Hungary.
When the British cut off trade to those
places,
they begin to do the equivalent of put
an entire nation or an entire alliance
under siege.
And one British official actually said,
you know,
what's the difference between,
putting the city under siege,
which has been done throughout history
in the civilian population in that,
besides that he always suffers and
putting a nation under siege.
The British clamped down this blockade
at the beginning of the war by the
middle and latter parts of Nineteen
Sixteen at Longterm Anaconda like
strategy really begins to bite.
And part of the reason why is these
societies are already straining to the
maximum to just keep their militaries in
the field.
And I think it's easy to forget exactly
what the strain on these societies,
you know,
was because you look at,
we know we've often compared the size of
these modern armies to what Alexander
the great conquered the known world with
back in,
you know,
the three thirties bce.
Alexander the Great is a core in one of
these modern armies.
Listen to what a German army corps of
which they had dozens in the army
requires to sustain itself.
Imagine an ancient economy trying to
provide this.
This is from a holder,
her vague and his book on the First
World War quote,
the army consumed copious amounts of
food and fodder,
a single core of 35,000
soldiers monthly devoured 1 million
pounds of meat,
600,000
loaves of bread,
189,000
pounds of fat,
or he says 242,000
pounds of canned meat and 121,000
pounds of Marmalade.
And he says 73,000
pounds of coffee.
It's horses.
Her Irving says needed 7 million pounds
of oats and more than 4 million pounds
of Hay.
The 18th army corps,
he says,
for example,
estimated that it needed 1000 wagons
extending for nine miles to haul.
It's monthly allotment of bread.
It's butchers slaughter at 1,320
cows.
1,100
hogs and 4,158
sheep every month.
Taken as a whole.
He says,
the German army weekly demolished $60,
million pounds of bread,
131 million pounds of potatoes and 17
million pounds of meat.
No one in the government or the general
staff he writes,
had given serious considerations to such
mammoth needs for a period of four years
and quote no,
no one saw that coming.
Someone from the ancient world,
I mean this could never have been
sustained before the modern era,
but sustaining it took all of those
necessary foodstuffs out of the civilian
populations mouths and they were
beginning to starve because of it.
The winter of 1916,
1917 will be remembered by Germans
forever as the turnip winter,
and that's the winter where the hunger
blockade really bit historian Eric Dorn.
Burroughs writes,
quote as 1916,
turn to 1917 caloric intake,
which had already begun to fall in late
1914.
Sled,
do about a third of prewar consumption
levels,
money connections,
and the black market help the lucky
ones,
but even the upper crossed suffered.
Now,
quoting a noble woman,
we are all gaunt and bony.
Now.
We have dark shadows around our eyes and
our thoughts are chiefly taken up with
wondering where our next meal will be.
Bros continues,
quote poor had almost disappeared from
dinner tables in restaurants where crow
was now served,
milk was reserved almost exclusively for
young children,
butter and sugar could be purchased only
in very small quantities.
Eggs were rationed to two per person per
month and turnips and Rutabagas had
begun to replace potatoes and quote,
Bros goes into a couple of reminisces
from Germans about what those tasted
like and then says,
quote,
inevitably,
as nutrition levels fell,
bodies to come to a variety of ailments
like rickets,
scurvy,
dysentery,
tuberculosis,
and influenza.
Estimates place the number of blockade
related deaths by war's end at 730,000,
which makes popular outrage,
understandable and quote.
Now,
as with everything in the first world
war,
there are historical dissenters who will
challenge every aspect of what's known
as the hunger blockade affecting the
central powers.
But nonetheless,
the important thing to understand is
that it.
It creates a dynamic in this conflict
that forces the German side to do
something.
They're the ones continually getting
less food.
Their adversaries,
the British and the French do not have a
food insecurity problem.
That dynamic forces the Germans to do
something to change their situation or
they'll just strangled to death.
I mean,
if you're already living through what
Germans are calling the turnip winter in
1916 and 1917,
what are they gonna call the next winter
of 1917 and 1918.
You don't have to be a genius to see
that you now have to do something to
change the state of affairs.
German public opinion begins to demand
it.
Now I should point out that that just
pretty much makes them the equal of all
the other populations of all the other
belligerent seemingly doesn't seem like
anyone's particularly happy with the way
their government is prosecuting the war,
regardless of which country you're
talking about,
at least amongst the major states.
In Britain at the end of 1916,
there government falls and the new prime
minister who arises is the very
embodiment of what voters would vote for
if they wanted to shake things up and
get somebody different in there.
His name is David Lloyd.
George usually just called Lloyd George,
Georgia.
Feisty Welshman have a much more working
class background than you normally see
in these sorts of positions.
Might be exactly what you know,
the average dissatisfied with the way
the war is going British citizen wanted.
Now it is a little interesting that only
a couple of weeks before Lloyd George
gets the job,
he's recorded as having said about the
allies in Britain.
We've lost this war and now he's in
charge of Britain's war effort.
It's also interesting to note that you
could tell how up in the air,
the outcome of the first world war is in
1916,
where you can find leading figures on
both sides who think their side has lost
the war.
Nonetheless,
the French also get into the game.
Nineteen 16 has been a terrible year for
them to just as it has been for the
British,
and they finally find the courage to get
rid of their longtime military leader,
the legend Joseph Jaffra.
He's been living off the fumes of his
reputation from the battle of the Marne.
A long time,
I think it's safe to say been
underperforming and the French finally,
they can't fire him.
He's too much of a legend,
but they finally sort of kick him
upstairs and promote them to a ceremony
of poster and replace him with the first
new French leader since the war started,
a guy named and he's Al the Russian
population and public opinion,
which isn't really supposed to have much
of a sway,
supposedly because they live in a,
in a strange sort of autocracy with a
part time legislature,
um,
but they're making their feelings known
to more on that in a minute.
And in Germany,
the population just wants a way out of
this trap.
Some people would like to see efforts
made towards figuring out a way out of
the war,
which they have people who say this in
all the belligerent countries,
but you have to be careful.
A little while ago we talked about
Woodrow Wilson,
suggesting that people who might oppose
his policies were disloyal.
He could get you thrown in the jails in
a lot of these belligerent countries if
you appear to be disloyal.
So too much peace talk could get you in
a lot of trouble.
Nonetheless,
there was a body of German public
opinion that was pushing for another
outcome.
They wanted their government to take the
gloves off,
stop playing nice with the adversary.
They wanted their government to unleash
the submarines and to heck with what the
Americans would do to some Germans.
The American policy looked to be a very
conniving way to simply deny Germany the
use of the submarines.
If you make the rules too restrictive,
and in the Americans case,
the rule basically was that an American
traveling on some ship gives it some
magical protection simply by stepping on
board.
You can't sink that ship.
Now there's an American on it that
pretty much nullifies the submarine for
Germany at all,
but if that's the only way you see a
chance to end the war with the German
victory over the British,
what does that mean?
Can you let the Americans hamstring you
like that?
Added that.
The fact that a lot of Germans don't
really see the Americans is all that
neutral already and think that maybe
Britain could be defeated in four or six
months before the Americans have a
chance to do much of anything.
Add to that.
The fact that when public opinion veers
in that direction,
there are Germans in the military high
command,
a majority of them that were already
thinking that themselves now they have
public opinion on their side unleashed
the submarines,
but what if the Americans come in the
war?
There were German leaders though that
didn't like this choice,
wanted to find another option rather
than use the subs,
get the United States into the war.
Chief among them was the chancellor of
Germany,
the top political guy.
His name was Beth manhole.
Vague,
and we've discussed him before.
This is all,
by the
way,
very controversial,
very complicated,
very convoluted.
You're getting the Dan Carlin a
condensed,
potentially unreliable version of this,
but it's a fascinating time in the
conflict because the politicians led by
whole vig think they find a way to throw
a monkey wrench into that terrible
choice that the allies of sort of
foisted the Germans on with the hunger
blockade and everything else.
They've got to make a move so they make
a very unexpected one.
On December twelfth,
1916,
Beth manhole,
vague and the Germans announced that
they are prepared to enter into
negotiations to end the war.
Now it should be pointed out that such
calls for peace and discussions about
peace had gone on since the war started.
Woodrow Wilson had stepped up pretty
much right at the beginning and said,
I'll mediate anytime you want.
There were attempts by both sides in the
war to try to make a separate peace with
somebody else and maybe get,
you know,
one of the allies of,
of your enemy to drop out of the war,
but those are peace terms just to get an
edge in the conflict.
They're not peace terms to end the war.
The Germans were making the first
apparently serious,
certainly public offer to sit down and
start talking about the issues that kept
the conflict going.
This was a huge shock,
not exactly to the Wilson
Administration.
They'd been getting some information fed
through some back channels that the
Germans might be ready to do this,
but the Americans thought that they were
going to unleash this big piece
proposal.
When the Germans do it,
they preempt woodrow Wilson's version
and he has to rush this out.
You know,
about a week later,
a little bit miffed that the Germans
stole his thunder a little bit,
but all of a sudden in December 19,
16 after this horrible year,
there were a piece proposals on the
table and it puts everybody into a
really uncomfortable position.
Now the Germans had taken a real chance,
by the way,
by trying this peace proposal route.
If this is a high stakes card game and I
often think of the war and in terms like
that,
the Germans,
because of the hunger blockade and
everything else are forced to play a
card and everyone thinks they're going
to play that really high risk,
high reward,
dangerous card.
They have the unrestricted submarine
warfare card.
Instead they play a potentially equally
perilous card,
but one that no one's expecting.
They play the race card,
but the peace card can blow up in your
face if you don't play it.
Definitely case in point,
what are your enemy's gonna?
Think?
When you become the first power to come
forward and start talking about stopping
the war,
they're gonna.
Think you need to.
What's more?
There's a danger.
Your own people might think that too,
and you spend a lot of effort in this
war to stiffen their backbone and keep
their resolve in place.
How much are you going to undercut it if
you become the first power to seek
peace?
So this whole thing has to be worded
very carefully and it is,
but almost in such a way to give your
gift to give you as you're moving
your neck between the humanitarian side
of the German chancellors proposals and
the side,
this filled with overwhelming hubris.
The Germans talk about what this was
doing to civilization and how they'd be
willing to get into conversations about
ending it,
but that they're still invincible than
they're gonna win the war and they don't
need to do this and what would the terms
be on the other side?
Maybe you could say that allies,
historians have argued about the motives
behind this ever since,
but the truth of the matter is,
if you look at this like a card game,
there were some good reasons for the
Germans to play that piece card.
Whether or not it was realistic and
whether or not the other side accepted
it,
and some historians say this was what it
was intended to do the whole time.
Provide some diplomatic cover for the
start of the unleashing of the
submarines to go and say,
hey,
we'll talk about peace.
Then when it's rejected.
Being able to turn around to your own
people and say,
you know,
you better give up those hopes.
Have an easy piece.
We just tried.
They won't do it.
This is a fight to the end,
stiff in yourself and also to show the
world including the neutrals and
including the people on the other side
of the wars population that we're not
the ones keeping this carnage going.
It could have been over,
but your side wants to keep fighting it.
Most especially is an attempt to maybe
influence public opinion in the neutral
countries,
especially the most important neutral
country.
The United States which has so many
German Americans in it that there are
more than 520 German language newspapers
as we said.
What do you think the editorials are
going to be in those newspapers after
Germany makes a peace proposal and the
allies swatted down?
That's going to put some pressure on the
US government to stay out of the war to
and that's going to influence American
public opinion over who the bad guys and
who the good guys are.
That may have been the overriding
intention of this German piece effort,
but nobody knows.
It may have been a serious attempt to at
least start negotiations going and to
take a position that didn't make you
seem to vulnerable at the outset.
The Germans picked the right time to do
it.
It was right after the capital of
Romania fell to the central power,
so were they're negotiating from a
position of strength here and the allies
swatted down.
They have to.
The problem with asking these powers to
state publicly what their war aims are
in order to create a piece is to show
that the war aims of these powers have
gotten so out of hand that they bear no
resemblance to anything that could be
negotiated as historian Gwynne Dyer road
in as we may have quoted already on this
program,
quote,
what the governments of Europe who found
themselves trapped in the first total
war discovered to their dismay,
was that if the means used to fight the
war,
our total then so must be the ends.
It was almost impossible to stop short
of total victory for one side and
unconditional surrender for the other
and to quote the old territorial
exchanges and the paying of reparations
and the,
you know,
giving up or acquiring of colonies was a
19th century sort of war aim.
It's sounded out of place in the 20th
century.
If the British or the French or the
Germans or anyone had said that their
was involved,
a little change,
a territory and a little reparations
money or what have you,
it would have seemed so out of
proportion to the cost that there would
be a real danger that the public would
think that what the country was fighting
for wasn't worth what the public was
paying for it.
In addition to that,
of course there were some craven
territorial ambitions involved and no
one wanted to state those.
In fact,
both sides had promised other people's
territories to allies of theirs.
For example,
the Italians were promised territory
from the Austrian Hungarian Empire.
Once the war was over,
the British couldn't very well say that
was a war aim and still not look like
cynical gamesman in this war.
When everyone,
by the way on all these sides is a
cynical games win,
but you can't show that to the public.
What's more?
The idea of war aims that stopped short
of defeating the enemy unconditionally
clashed with your propaganda.
This is a war that's using such 20th
century ideas as a war to end all wars
and a war to make the world safe for
democracy.
It's not a war to acquire a few colonies
on the Mediterranean and some oil in the
Middle East and the breakup of the
Austrian Hungarian Empire.
It's a war for these high minded ideals.
The problem is as if your propaganda
portrays the Germans as the second
coming of the Hmong goals will actually,
the huns is the word the propaganda used
and they're baby killers and nurse
executioners and none rapers and all the
things that propaganda makes them out to
be.
How can you possibly sit down and sign a
piece of paper to compromise with them
and have peace again,
when the Vatican was a at this time
trying to help create the conditions
where peace could happen.
The Vatican kept telling the powers to
live up to those prewar agreements to
make war less horrible,
and they were saying that they were
favoring this not because they were
idealists,
but because if these powers kept doing
everything in there,
you know might to destroy one another.
They were going to hate each other so
much that there was going to be no space
and mutual respect left to carve out a
piece later,
the Germans were no happier by the way
to state their war aims publicly for the
exact same reasons.
Now,
there was an implied threat included
when the Germans came forward with this
attempt to get negotiations started and
the implied threat was if negotiations
didn't happen in weren't fruitful,
they would play the unrestricted
submarine warfare card.
The peace negotiations are over by the
end of January,
in the middle of January.
Actually,
we're on January 20th.
Wilson makes a famous speech,
a speech where he calls for peace
without victory
in his so called Peace Without victory
speech on the 22nd of January when
essentially he already knew that it
wasn't going to happen.
Wilson lays down the kind of peace that
Europe will have to broker to end the
first world war.
If it's to be a lasting peace.
It can't be one of those pieces.
You know where the knife is turned in.
One side is left hating the other.
When you think about how the first world
war ended and how it's sowed the seeds
for the Second World War,
Wilson sounds like nostradamus was some
of the things he says in this part of
the speech where he talks about,
you know,
having to have this kind of peace.
He says,
quote,
I am seeking only to face realities and
to face them without soft concealments
victory would mean peace forced upon the
loser of Victor's terms imposed upon the
vanquished.
It would be accepted in humiliation,
under duress,
at an intolerable sacrifice and would
leave a sting,
a resentment,
a bitter memory upon which terms of
peace would rest,
not permanently,
but only as upon quicksand.
Only a piece between equals can last
only a piece.
The very principle of which is equality
and a common participation in a common
benefit.
The right state of mind,
the right feeling between nations,
it is necessary for a lasting peace,
as is a just settlement,
a vexed questions of territory or of
racial and national allegiance
end quote,
so he's not only calling for a piece
where nobody can claim a victory.
We just stopped fighting and begin
negotiating for a postwar world in which
Wilson and envisions a new international
global structure to enforce global peace
and harmony so that we never have a
first world war.
Again.
As I said,
for those historians who suggests that
Wilson is out to make Wilson the biggest
historical figure he can,
that would be a heck of a legacy if he
could pull that off,
but instead,
within a couple of months,
the United States will be in the war and
from the allied perspective,
not a moment too soon.
The end of 1916,
early 1917,
and we've been spending quite a bit of
time setting this period in the war up,
but this period in the war is probably
the most important six months in the
last hundred years.
People talk about the first world war is
this transformative moment and the
aftereffects that were living with,
you know,
even now all around us,
but the most transformative moment in
that conflict is what's about to happen
now and you know,
I can't help but find some sort of
analogy approach to looking at it,
but I mean it's like we have this tree
and they've been shopping at it for two
years and at the end of 1916 and finally
the tree falls over.
Winston Churchill says three ingredients
acting together,
create what he calls the second climax
of the war.
In this period we've dealt with two of
those ingredients,
the Americans and the submarine
question.
The third ingredient involves Russia.
Up till now,
I think it's pretty obvious in this
episode we've been dealing with what you
could safely call the first rate powers
the countries that were at the top of
everything when the war started.
The rich,
powerful,
cohesive,
unified,
you know,
top of the Line States,
the Francis,
the Britains,
the Germany's.
But if they're worn down by this many
years of this war to this point,
to where they are now,
where the Germans are undernourished,
for lack of a more provocative term,
what must be the situation that the
countries that weren't first rate powers
in the war started?
The ones that had challenges and we're
struggling in various areas.
How are two years of war treating them?
Well,
the Italians have opened disagreements
about peace in their government.
Um,
in,
in the trenches,
there are pamphlets distributed by
socialists that say next winter,
not another man in the trenches.
The generals are not very pleased with
that,
but it's hard to blame the Italians.
They were on like their 10th or 11th
battle of the [inaudible] river fighting
over this torture risk,
mountainous terrain,
which creates an environment.
You know,
it's,
it's a little teeny horrible war in and
of itself with all these unique things.
I mean,
just to give you one example,
in the mountain war that the Italians
are fighting with the Austro-hungarian,
when shells hit,
they're all carved into rock.
I mean,
instead of trenches,
a lot of times they have blown out like
chasms for cover,
but when the shells hit the rocks,
the rocks just splinter,
creating like a secondary amount of
shrapnel.
That's just horrifying.
And then when you get wounded your way
up at six,
7,000
feet and you got to be brought down
through mountaineers,
Alpine conditions to the nearest
waystation,
they,
they still find frozen things up there.
Even today,
it's a horrible conflict and by 1960 and
the Italians are on like their 10th or
11th version of it and all they have to
show for it is more and more dead
people.
They wouldn't be human if they weren't
starting to get a little fed up with
this.
In fact,
that just puts them on par with how it
seems the populations of all the
belligerent countries are doing now.
How's Austria Hungary doing?
Remember,
they're the ones that you know,
kind of where we're at.
Ground Zero.
When this whole war got started,
they're the ones who had the archduke
that got himself assassinated.
They're the ones that sent that
uncompromising letter to the Serbians.
They're the ones that sparked this war.
How are they doing?
Well,
I bet they wish they hadn't.
They're in terrible shape.
The venerable emperor that had ruled
there for so long,
the benign face of stability had finally
died to be,
um,
you know,
succeeded by the next emperor who's a
much younger man and who looks at his
country and says to the Germans,
this war has to end in 1917 when
Austria,
Hungary is worse than done
this new emperor.
During this coming year,
we'll go behind the Germans,
back to the allies reportedly and try to
sort of sell them out and the Germans
find out about it and then they're never
going to take their eyes off Austria
hungry again.
All of a sudden,
you know,
these brothers in arms don't trust each
other anymore.
And it was a very interesting move that
a lot of people have talked about.
It's almost like world war one's version
of Rudolf Hess flying to Great Britain,
you know,
to make a separate piece for Nazi
Germany and the Second World War.
It's just this weird little endeavor.
And all it does is earn Austria,
Hungary.
Germany's Ms Dot Trust,
and then you have the Russians.
Now,
the Russians from the very start of this
war,
even before this war for a very long
time,
have been this contradiction in power.
In one sense,
they are massively powerful in a
military sense.
Theoretically they are terrifying
and yet they are at the same time,
so fatally flawed in the underpinnings
that anything Russia's doing in this,
we're always seems to be like writing
some rail or or walking a tight rope and
and disaster loomed at any moment.
It just,
it was an unsteady sort of situation.
There's a story that sort of shows this,
this contradiction in terms the military
leader of the Russian military leader,
bruce seal off.
He'll have an offensive named after him
in 1916.
We talked about it nowhere near as much
as it deserves in the last program.
This once again,
push the Russians out there in a good
light,
shows you what they can do when they get
their act together and they are
devastating.
Seven hundred and 50,000
casualties on the Austria.
Hungarian army,
I mean essentially mortally wounded than
it is frightening what the Russians can
do,
you know when things go the right way.
But Priscilla of tells a story that
shows you just how fatally compromised
everything is.
You know,
how rotten the insides are.
He says,
at the height of this offensive,
when everything's going so well,
he's receiving unsigned letters from his
own soldiers telling him that if the
fighting doesn't stop soon,
they're going to kill him.
Russia has been having internal problems
for decades.
Now.
The current Tsar,
Nicholas the second,
uh,
the czar desire is not even his right
name.
He's the emperor of Russia.
The czar is the old name that goes back
hundreds of years,
but they still call them that because
that's essentially what the office still
is in his name,
his official long title that says he's
the autocrat.
And,
uh,
even if the Russian doom has been given
one percent and the czar still has 99
percent of the power,
he's a,
an example of the old world at its most
royal.
And yet he knows how frightfully fragile
the underpinnings are.
When he was emir adolescent,
he saw his grandfather carried into the
royal palace with his legs torn to
shreds,
his groin gone,
his stomach ripped out,
and his face mangled,
and he is bleeding out on the royal
carpet and the royal family,
including Nicholas.
The second,
the man who will be Nicholas the second
watch their grandfather die.
It takes about 15 minutes
he'd been killed in an assassination.
Another one of these stories where you
know the czar is out in his bulletproof
sled and I am a bomber.
Throws a bomb.
It sounds a little like the whole Sarah
Gevo thing that kicked off the first
world war.
A bomber throws a bomb,
the bomb goes off,
kills people who are not the target.
The target comes out.
In this case,
the czar comes out to look around and
there's another bomber in the crowd.
Supposedly desire at the time had said
something about,
you know,
thank God that nothing happened.
And the other assassins as he's throwing
the bomb and him saying it's a little
too early to thank God,
boom.
And he bleeds out in the royal palace
floor while the czar who will be
commanding Russia as the autocrat in the
first world war as a 13 or 14 year old
boy watches.
He knows how dangerous the job is,
and he knows that there's a violent
current of rottenness that opposes his
system and he's dealing with it all the
time.
One of the things that makes this story
so interesting though is when you're
dealing with one person with almost
total power,
as we said earlier,
their little idiosyncrasies make a big
impact on history.
In the case of Nicholas,
the second,
the autocrat of all the Russians,
right?
His idiosyncrasies involve some things
that I think most people out there who
have children can at least relate to a
little bit of.
It's interesting that there's a part to
this story that just has a personal
tragedy wrapped up in it.
I mean,
this is an example why you can't reduce
history to some sort of mathematical
equation or some sort of predictable set
of rules are.
I mean there are human beings involved
here.
In the case of the Tsar.
It's a fascinating story.
The man,
just so you know,
I mean this is how Europe was.
This is the old Europe that's being
destroyed.
He's the first or second cousin with
everybody.
He's the first cousin with the King of
England.
He's the second cousin with the emperor
of Germany.
I mean he's related to everybody and his
wife is the first cousin of the King of
England.
I mean a little incestuous maybe,
but that explains why the czar and his
wife more than her in a second,
who only have one son give birth to a
son who's a hemophiliac.
It runs in the family Queen Victoria,
who sort of the,
the,
the descended that all these people can
trace their heritage back.
You said that this did not run in her
family,
but it seemed to.
Victoria of course was German and her
roots,
so it was the czar's wife has Arina
Alexandra.
Both of them loved each other,
and I say this because you know,
you would think today we'll.
Of course they did,
but listen,
this is an era where,
especially amongst nobility,
you often had very political marriages.
You also had these very old fashioned
things that were very common back then
where the husband and wife really didn't
love each other and the husband was out,
you know,
with all the girls all at it wasn't like
that with Nicholas and Alexandra.
This is what this was a love story and
it really was,
and not just between the two of them but
with their children too.
They loved their children the way we
think of every modern person loving
their children or the way they should
and that is not to say that people in
the past didn't.
Although you find a lot of examples in
the royal families throughout history
where the father hardly sees the son
eight.
It's not like that with these guys.
They take an active day to day role in
their parenting and they wrote letters
to each other constantly and they wrote
in English,
which they both spoke.
Well,
this is our arena was German,
but.
But she spoke Russian.
She spoke English,
does our spoke everything and they
communicated in more than a thousand
letters with each other where you get a
real feel for these people.
And one of the things that they are
absolutely terrified about is their son
who's got hemophilia,
he's their only son,
he's the czar and he is almost certainly
going to die young from this disease
now,
just so you know,
hemophilia is a disease where your blood
doesn't clot.
Not to get too technical because I
couldn't explain it any way,
but um,
but basically any little cut or bruise
has the potential to spiral out of
control.
The normal in a rough and tumble of a,
of a young child's life will kill you.
And in this era,
especially,
parents just assumed almost a death
sentence.
And these two parents,
as any parents we would think of today
probably could hardly handle that
thought.
And they were looking around for curious
and trying to find them.
And eventually they found someone who
seemed to be able to fix their son.
And because of the little idiosyncrasy
connected to who this person tended to
be,
world history is completely altered.
And,
and the funny part about it is an
unknown.
It's a tragic story.
It's a,
it's an interesting story.
It's a very human story.
But there are elements to it that would
make a good sitcom or a good movie
premise,
and I,
as I walked in to talk about this today,
I remembered the movie that was kind of
based on the premise that it had nick
naulty entity was called down and out in
Beverly Hills and the story is about a
vagrant kinda homeless kind of guy who
by hook or by crook ends up,
you know,
in living with a rich family in beverly
hills,
a really fabulously rich family.
And of course because of the dichotomy
in their lifestyles and the way they
view the world,
hilarity ensues,
right?
But that's Kinda what happened with the
tsar and his wife and they're
hemophiliac son when they found somebody
who seemed to be able to heal him,
that somebody was basically the
equivalent of the vagrant in down and
out in Beverly Hills.
They were bringing a peasant in to have
a look at their sick son.
Peasants name is Gregory Rasputin.
And history has always been.
I mean,
he's a hardcore history personality.
If you've ever found one.
And the fact that this government was
run 99 percent by one guy and his wife
opens up the door to a greg gory
Rasputin being able to have the effect
on history.
He had historian Peter Hart does a good
job of of framing all the various things
that seem to be going on at once,
including what I just talked about,
the the way Russia is sort of a giant,
but hamstrung by this,
this ancient system of theirs so that a
guy like Rasputin could make a
difference in the idiosyncrasies of a
single individual or two could come to
the fore.
He writes,
quote,
the Russian homefront was gradually
collapsing under the intolerable strain
of war.
The czarist government did not have the
flexibility necessary to cope with the
plague of economic,
political,
and social problems that infected the
land.
The tsar himself perceived any form of
democracy is a threat to his regime,
and rather than introducing an increased
measure of liberalism was more attracted
to the idea of a total disillusion of
even the tokenistic Duma appointments.
Depositions of considerable authority.
We're routinely assigned by the czar on
the grounds of either naked favoritism
or the authoritarian credentials of the
candidate.
Spy scares raged through society with
particular suspicion falling on any
Russian general,
unfortunate enough to have a Germanic
name.
Meanwhile,
incompetence and corruption blossomed
unfettered while at the center.
The tsar was publicly embarrassed by the
adherence of the Zarina Alexandra to the
ludicrous cult of Rasputin and unhinged
religious mystic with a pension for
irreligious pursuits.
The whole despotic system of government
was resting on just a few weak
individuals.
Russia was being hollowed out from
within,
and the vacuum at the center was
creating dangerous instability and the
quote now,
everything that Peter Hart says right
there could have applied to several
other countries in this story.
Everything except one thing.
The part dealing with recipe
Gregori.
Rasputin is a great wildcard in the
story and a quintessentially Russian
figure.
I mean,
he's.
It's hard to imagine him anywhere else
and he is outrageous and larger than
life.
And I think Peter Hart has great
historian as he is.
He sounds a little bit like he can't
understand,
you know,
the Zarina,
the wife of the czar kind of falling for
this guy and his shtick.
He calls it the ludicrous Rasputin cult.
I mean,
if you'd have had her here to ask her,
she'd probably say to you,
but I saw him do it multiple times.
Do what?
Saved my son's life.
If you saw somebody save your kid's life
multiple times,
don't you think it would be hard to have
your logic override what you think you
saw?
I've seen cold hearted total realists
turn into people seeking quack remedies
when they were dying of cancer.
They were looking for hope.
If your kid is dying,
you're looking for hope.
What if somebody actually comes through?
I mean,
what if that quack treatment for your
relatives,
terminal cancer cured the cancer.
That's the weirdness in this story that
the royal family,
the emperor and his wife,
run into this Guy Gregory Rasputin first
in 19.
Oh,
five
about 10 years before the time period.
We are in the story and there's an entry
by the czar in his diary.
We met a man of God today and so
starched this relationship between this
person who was born,
a poor peasant in Siberia,
you know,
uneducated,
everything and his relationship with two
of the most royal figures in the world.
I mean,
when you think of the king and queen of
England,
that's the level we're talking about,
what the czar and Sarina imagine today's
queen of England who has no power at
all,
picking up some person off the street
who's almost homeless and not even a
London homeless person.
Someone from the sticks up in the north
of England somewhere,
some small town,
bringing them in the palace and having
them live with you for awhile and sort
of questioning them on the state of
things and what are the people saying
and and Oh yeah,
letting the minister medicinally to your
child.
It's a crazy story and the only reason
Rasputin becomes important.
You can hardly imagine him important in
most of the other systems of government,
but because Russia is so autocratic,
if you capture the czar,
you capture the country.
Rasputin made the royal family emotional
hostages.
Now,
whether that was intentional or
otherwise is debatable.
Historians disagree.
There are some historians,
you think this is a person who thought
he was a blessed man of God with these
special powers to do,
you know,
religious oriented things and others say
he's a charlatan and he knew he had the
royal couple sort of emotionally
blackmail,
but there was nothing anyone could do
about it.
There's a great quote from the czar,
you know,
in the middle of the story with Rasputin
where one of his advisors says something
to the effect of you to get rid of this
guy and the czar,
his answer is,
there's nothing I can do about it.
And a lot of historians have always
interpreted that to mean that the czar
is basically saying he can't stand up to
his wife.
You know,
that she wants him.
And there's nothing that the czar can
do.
He won't stand up to his wife.
But you know,
some historians have come out recently
and said,
you know,
it could easily mean there's nothing he
can do about it because there's only one
person who can save their son's life.
The heir to the throne,
by the way,
if you really believed that this
Rasputin guys got you in a weird
position between 19 Oh,
five.
When the czar and Rasputin first meet
and where we are in this story right
now,
late 1916,
Rasputin has been warming his way into
the czars family pretty consistently.
Not as circle of friends,
his family,
the czar.
We'll have these get togethers sometimes
it was him and his wife and his kids and
Rasputin.
Now there our back steps.
Sometimes the relationship goes sour for
awhile usually because Rasputin,
who was a surreal misbehavior does
something particularly outrageous,
either embarrassing the czar,
so much that that,
that he does what his underlings are
continually telling them to do and sends
Rasputin a way or legitimately upsetting
him.
Nonetheless.
Every time he manages to break the
relationship breakup,
I guess you could say with Rasputin
inevitably,
Alexi,
his son,
the heir to the throne will get sick
again,
necessitating a return of Rasputin.
He's like a cigarette habit.
You can't kick
now.
This rescued and characters fascinating
on so many levels.
You know,
you have to think you were dealt some
interesting cards by fate to be able to
parlay your gifts from his upbringing as
a,
as an uneducated peasant with no money
in the middle of nowhere to where you
are in the royal family.
And when you see a picture of him,
you see a little bit of it.
I mean,
he was five foot nine inches tall,
pretty normal.
Um,
he had dark black,
oily hair parted in the middle,
unkempt mustache,
unkempt beard,
interesting way of dressing.
I mean,
if you,
if you had photo shopped his picture
onto the back of any number of 19
seventies heavy metal albums,
I don't think I would be able to look at
the bands photo on the back and,
and know that you did it.
He would have fit in perfectly as the
basis of any number of bands from back
then.
Heck,
if he were a lead singer and you named
the band after him,
it would fit in on any lineup.
You could think of it as a heavy metal
festival winded.
I mean,
you know,
this weekend only black Sabbath,
iron maiden,
motorhead and Rasputin,
he had the most amazing eyes and you can
tell because normally you can't tell
from photos 100 years ago,
you know,
certain qualities of individuals.
It just gets lost through the layers of,
of,
of fuzziness and black and white and all
that.
But if you catch the right photo of
respite and he had to be hand to be
caught just the right time,
you can see what the eyes were like
because they jump of the black and white
photo from 100 years ago at you.
Even now the whites of his eyes were
said by witnesses to be extra white and
again,
it kind of looks that way and some of
the photos is eichler dazzle people to
the point where we have multiple
descriptions that all contradict each
other.
Some people say blue,
some people say Brown.
Some people say gray.
Some people say multicolored.
When you read about his sort of tick
like way of walking,
moving his nervous habits,
the way he wouldn't talk for a while and
then all of a sudden you get this,
this stream of sometimes unrelated
conversation spiced with sexual
innuendos.
I mean there's a part of you that
thinks,
I mean I just read a book on the late
writer,
a hunter,
Thompson,
they sound like in a room together.
They would look like they were
impersonating each other.
Rasputin is a combination of a person
who looks to be a very devout religious
figure from Russia's Christianity and
Orthodox Christian,
um,
and a drunk and hell raiser.
And apparently that's not that unusual
in a,
in the Russian tradition,
especially in the Siberian tradition
where Rasputin's from,
there are some offshoots and sex and
cults who had these interesting beliefs
and I don't understand them and
wouldn't,
wouldn't try to explain them,
but apparently it involves needing to
sin sometimes in order to get the right
kind of repentance working for you.
And,
and there are rumors of orgies that take
place as part of the rights for these
religions.
And some historians,
not most,
but some have tied Rasputin to some of
those,
um,
strange sex and strange beliefs and it
would make sense in one in one sense
though,
because there's,
there are conversations that have been
recorded with his wife and yes,
he was married,
you know,
when she would walk past him in,
in,
in the middle of a town with other women
and they would all see him having sex in
the open with some towns,
woman,
she would say something to the effect
of,
well,
that's just his cross to bear.
He's got to do that.
You know what I mean?
Like he didn't want to just,
he has to do that.
That's,
that's he's helping those people.
I'm sure if I was rescued and I would
want to sell it that way,
let's put it that way.
The to gossip column type offenses that
he's,
he's always tarred with our,
our extreme drunkenness and sexual
outrageousness.
And usually in combination with each
other,
there are rape charges that are brought
to the czar in Zarina's attention were
the household staff is accusing him of
going after them.
He's absolutely brazen.
He will sit down next to have a figure
from the royal family and put his arm
around her at a party with all the
aristocrats there and start moving in on
her.
There are stories that you have to know
that the Zaras arena knew he was this
way because at these family gatherings I
mentioned earlier where they're all
sitting there and it's just him and the
family.
He'll sit next to the princesses who are
all adolescent girls during this time
period and they will jump up like
they've been prompted with a hot needle
because he's goosing them and feeling
them in front of the czar and Zarina.
And yet at the same time,
um,
some
of this stuff is passed off as just part
of his rustic peasant charm.
Isn't it cute that he doesn't know how
inappropriate that is?
Like I said,
some of these people in Russia's
aristocracy hated him,
but those who didn't kind of had a
reaction like he was some sort of exotic
thing that the zoo brought in and you
have to make allowances for what he
doesn't understand.
He might not know.
You can't just walk up and touch them.
Noble Woman's breast at dinner and how,
how funny and interesting it is at isn't
outrageous,
you know,
that kind of an attitude.
Uh,
but he was fun and historian Joseph
Fermin,
who's written two books on Rasputin,
pointed that out,
quote Rasputin was fun.
It was a pleasure to be in his company.
He gave people nicknames and they were
often cutting and quite appropriate.
He might double a woman hot stuff,
boss lady,
sexy girl,
or good looking while a man would be
called fancy pants,
big breaches,
long hair or fellow people accepted this
as a charming characteristic.
The humor of a peasant who meant no
disrespect and quote.
So the people that didn't hate Rasputin
would often,
you know,
overlook his outrageousness and consider
that part of,
you know,
his charm is rustic peasant charm.
Nonetheless,
sometimes it was a little too much.
Even for the czar,
there's famous incidents and they all
end up in the local media.
Believe it or not,
Russia had a tabloid media during this
time period.
And Rasputin was one of their staple,
you know,
figures.
But I mean,
back in my day,
every one of them had to have it
Elizabeth Taylor story or a Michael
Jackson story or something like that.
Kim Kardashians,
probably today,
back then in Russia,
if you didn't have a respite in the
story,
you know,
every so often,
I mean you were worried about
circulation dropping and just when you
think there'd be no new news,
he gets roaring drunk in a,
in a Highfalutin restaurant in the
capital city.
Starts yelling about how he knows the
czar and then pulls his pants down and
whips his genitals out to the restaurant
word like that,
gets around in the tabloids,
eat it up.
At one point,
does our had to tell the tabloids that
they couldn't mention his name anymore.
So they just started referring to him as
the guy who lives on so and so street,
whatever street he lived on.
And everyone in the public just knew who
they meant.
There were cartoons that made the rounds
showing Rasputin,
um,
with his hand on the naked breast of the
Zarina,
implying what a lot of people wondered
about this relationship.
Although it's almost certainly not true
if Rasputin's going around town,
sleeping with everything that moves from
peasants to royal women as well.
What's he doing with the Zarina?
There are even whisperings and one
public charge made that the
heir to the throne.
The Tsar's son is really Rasputin son.
Almost certainly not true,
but the more gossip circulated with that
kind of talk,
the more it undermined,
you know,
people's trust in the [inaudible] arena.
Remember this arena's already German at
a time when the Russian people are
hounding Russian generals who just have
German last names.
What happens if you are German and the
[inaudible] not around and this strange
Russian peasant who seems like a spin
golly is.
I mean there were protests in 1915 where
the people were saying down with respite
and down with Alexandra,
he's not an unknown quantity.
Everyone realizes he's almost a public
figure.
They debate him in the legislature and
the powers that be want him gone.
There's a story during this time period
about one of the ways they tried to get
him out.
It's a famous story one day Rasputin.
Here's a knock at his door.
He goes to the door and there's a man
standing there with a package and he
gives risks in the package and Rasputin
opens the package and it's full of
photos and Rasputin looks at the photos
and they are photos of him unconscious,
insensible due to drink,
and there are naked women all around
him.
Night photos.
The man at the door who gave him the
package says either you leave town and
go back to where you came from and stop
talking and influencing the czar or
we're going to give these pictures to
him.
It was an extortion attempt and I'm one
of the nights apparently that respite
and had passed out from drink.
His enemies had hired prostitutes and
position them around him naked and
started taking photos to blackmail him.
In typical,
unexpected fashion.
Rasputin took the photos straight to the
czar and sort of,
you know,
threw himself on the mercy of the court.
Now a lot of the time Rasputin's able to
skate away with no real repercussions.
Sometimes he's not,
as we said,
occasional riffs would develop between
the czar and Rasputin.
One of them,
for example,
that went on in 1912,
is a perfect example of how hard it was
for the czar to stay away from Rasputin
in 1912.
They have one of these disagreements on
the [inaudible] sends Rasputin back to
Siberia.
The royal family goes on a vacation in
September,
1912 to their country palace.
They're playing around in the young heir
to the throne.
Lexi jumps in a boat.
He's about seven or eight years old.
Not Unusual,
not unusual for seven or eight year old
to land wrong and hurt themselves,
but most of these seven or eight year
olds,
of course,
not hemophiliac,
so it instantly becomes a problem.
There's a giant Hematoma in his lower
abdomen.
They take them back to the palace and
they have a terrible scare.
He gets very ill,
very bad.
Uh,
it takes about a month for him to start
to recover.
And as he's just starting to turn the
corner,
and I've never understood this,
his mother,
there's our arena,
thinks it'd be great to take them on a
little carriage ride and it's a bumpy
road and they hit some bumps and he
cries out and pain and something's
happened inside him.
They take him back to the palace and now
they have one of the most horrific
periods of their life starting because
this kid starts to die and it takes a
while and it's very painful and the
parents are watching it.
I mean the kids fever skyrockets.
The pain becomes so terrible.
He's delirious and slipping in and out
of consciousness.
I read somewhere that a opium is used in
the past sometimes for people in the
heir to the throne,
his condition,
but they didn't use it for him.
And the screams are so terrible that
we're told the palace staff has to stuff
cotton in their ears to walk around to
deal with it.
The parents,
like I said,
loving real hands on.
Parents take their turn at his bedside
and he's begging for help.
He's,
he's saying,
Lord,
have mercy on me.
Was one of the things recorded over and
over and over again and my mom helped me
the pain and we're told that when the
parents shifted,
the bedside was over,
they would walk out of the room and just
burst into tears.
The czar said that the Zarina handled
the ordeal better than he did at a
certain point that doctors run out of
things to do.
They tell the parents there's nothing
more they can do.
It becomes apparent to the parents and
to the patient that he's dying and he
starts talking about those things that
destroy parents.
I mean that you never want to hear your
little kid saying he's.
He's saying,
when I die,
will the pain be gone to his mother?
He asked that after he dies,
they build this little shrine in the
woods for amount of stones and then the
reality of the situation sets in and
they start putting together a public
statement to tell the Russian people
that the heir to the throne has died.
The last rites are performed and while
at a meeting,
the czar gets a hand scrawled note from
his wife saying,
come quickly.
I think it's time the boy's about to die
at the last minute,
the Zarina pens and note to rest butte
and often Siberia essentially saying
help and she gets a cable the next
morning.
It's a famous cable and it lets a little
air out of the tires that it's not as
good.
According to a historian,
Josef Herman,
as we always thought it was,
the cable was always thought to say God
has seen your tears and heard your
prayers.
Do not grieve.
The little one will not die.
Do not allow the doctors to bother him
too much.
And quote Russians during the Alexandra
Spring,
uh,
apparently says there was,
there were two notes,
but the one that was misquoted really
said,
quote,
fear nothing.
The illness is not as dangerous as
they're saying.
See that the doctors do not bother him.
And by that afternoon the boy is out of
pain and is able to sleep and the fever
starts dropping.
The doctors are stunned and it should be
pointed out.
They hate Rasputin,
but they were forced.
I mean,
there's several of them quoted in the
infirmary [inaudible] latest book.
He's written two books on Rasputin and
they're just,
they don't know what to even make of it
and it wasn't just this time they would
be trying to stop the boy from bleeding
and past incidents and Rasputin would
come up and they would watch him stop it
and historians have been trying to find
explanations for this ever since.
I mean,
I've heard everything from hypnosis to
the power of suggestion to drugs to one
theory is that that they were giving the
young czar aspirin,
which was like the new wonder drug back
then and that of course would have been
the worst thing to give them and when
respite and says don't let the doctors
bothered him too much.
They stopped giving him the Asprin.
Some people have suggested that there
were some potion Rasputin had the sort
of kept the boy,
you know,
in a bad state.
Anytime he wanted to,
you know,
put a little emotional pressure on the
royal family.
There's all kinds of theories,
but if you're the Zarina and you've
already seen respite and save your son's
life several times and he just pulled
him back from the brink of death by
telegram,
don't you think you'd stop caring about
the wherefores and the what ifs and just
not want this guy to leave your side.
If the czar of Russia was in the process
of kicking his respite and habit,
he fell off the wagon after that 1912,
you know,
pull your son back from the brink of
death moment.
Now,
here's the thing,
Rasputin wasn't a problem because he
kept healing the heir to the throne.
If he had stuck to that,
probably we don't even talk about him
very much.
Of course,
the reason we do talk about and the
reason he's a famous figure,
the reason half of Russia wants him dead
is because he's not sticking to fixing
the air.
He's meddling in policy in a funny way
to.
I can see how that happened.
I'm not so appalled.
I mean,
if you,
if you look at this from the czar as our
arenas vantage point and you think this
guy has something,
does arena thinks he's a man of God and
that God favors him and all the in the
prophetic and if you'd seen what she'd
seen,
wouldn't you think?
So maybe to win if you thought that,
wouldn't you want to use this guy like a
magic eight ball,
especially with the stakes as high as
they are for the czar at this time.
I mean,
when the first world war breaks out,
when the Romanov Dynasty is threatened,
when millions of lives hinge on the
decision the Zar makes,
how tempting would it be?
You know,
to just sort of ask Rasputin what he
thought about disappointment or that
idea.
Should I go to the front end to command
from the front line sources?
Say Yes.
And that's the event.
By the way,
the czar going to command at the front
lines,
which opens up the door to turbo
charging Rasputin's influence and really
ushering Russia into the terminal phase
of the end of the Romanov Dynasty.
Because what happens is,
you know the terrible losses against the
central powers that the Russians had
suffered.
The czar thought that people might need
a scapegoat and he altruistically
offered himself up as a sacrificial
lamb.
He thinks he's going to go to the front.
His advisors think this is a terrible
idea,
would lots of downsides,
but Rasputin likes the idea.
Therefore,
by the way,
those aren't.
Rena likes the idea.
At one point the Zaras wavering and
things maybe he shouldn't do it in
Rasputin bolsters his confidence that
it's a good idea and so the czar leaves
the capital and goes to Kinda close to
the front lines and all of a sudden
there's our arenas left in charge of day
to day activities
and she's using rest Putin like a magic
eight ball,
like you wouldn't believe.
You can read it in the letters back and
forth between the tsar and his wife
because she'll inform them what's going
on.
She calls Rasputin our friend.
That's your little code name for him.
And she'll say to the,
are our friend thinks we should do this.
Our friend doesn't like that legislator.
Our friend thinks that appointment job
should go to this person and they'll
debate it back and forth and Rasputin is
making huge decisions for Russia's
future in war time when things are
deteriorating badly and bread riots are
happening and and and dissatisfaction is
palpably on.
The rise and demonstrations are
occurring and he's drinking 12 bottles
of wine a day at wake up.
I don't think the belligerent powers of
the other countries aren't aware of it
either.
The British secret service is monitoring
according to historians like Joseph
Herman,
Monitoring Rasputin.
They have a nickname for him,
a code name.
They call them dark forces and many
things about Rasputin troubled and
they're not sure.
He's not a German agent.
They think he's unstable.
Certainly they think he is in favor of
some sort of peace deal to get rushed
out of the war.
There's a lot of reasons they don't
Kinda like him,
but this problem is becoming acute and
some nobleman apparently take it upon
themselves to read Russia of this
cancer,
which is the way they see risks.
Putin that decided to kill him,
and when we reached this point,
we're actually caught up with the story
timeline again.
It's December 19,
16 where we left off before our little
Russian digression,
you know,
that time with the submarines and the
peace deals on the table and the
questions about the US getting into the
war or not.
In December,
19,
16,
rumors are flying and the capital that
Rasputin is going to be killed and
they're so pervasive.
Rasputin hears them,
allegedly has children,
hear them do,
and they hide his clothes so he can't go
out.
Nonetheless,
even with those rumors flying,
he can't resist.
And this is the traditional story.
This is a Kennedy assassination type
thing.
And Good Luck finding the truth.
I'm just giving you the,
the most common story here.
Apparently a nobleman offers his wife to
rest Butin,
you know,
a nice little clandestine arrangement,
uh,
after a party or something like that.
Rasputin takes the guy up on the offer.
He's a nobleman.
Felix,
you saw Paul is his name and I think
he's so rich.
He has more money than the ruling
dynasty and he's working with a bunch of
other men.
It's a true conspiracy.
Nobody knows how deeply there are some
who think the British secret service was
even in on it.
The majority don't you stop off,
meets Rasputin kind of at his door,
brings him down into the basement.
A Yankee doodle to tie this story
together wonderfully is playing on the
phonograph upstairs that they can hear.
So you get this little American playing
in this story
as,
as a Russia reaches the terminal phase
here in the Romanov Dynasty.
Um,
there's food on the table,
there's wine.
Uh,
the rendezvous is a little pushed back.
You saw Bob says.
So they sit there and they eat the food
and they drink the wine and after a
while you stop off,
begins to freak out because he's laced
all these things with cyanide.
And this guy's not dying.
He says he's a,
his throat's bothering him a little in
his stomach's bothering him a little,
but he's,
he's sitting there drinking more,
eating more than asking you so pumped to
sing for him.
I liked your singing voice,
you so bob,
he excuses himself,
goes upstairs to where the other
conspirators are and freaks out.
What are we going to do?
Finally,
one of them decides,
um,
they should shoot him.
And [inaudible] got a pistol so you soap
up,
goes down there,
tells 'em Rasputin to look at something
on the wall over there.
And then,
uh,
when Rasputin turns around,
the pistols pointed at him,
you saw Paul says,
he said,
you know,
say your prayers or something like that,
shot him in the chest.
He screams and he falls down on the rug,
frothing at the mouth,
convulsions dies.
The assassins all come downstairs,
have a look at the body,
the blood,
everything.
Go upstairs to commiserate about it for
awhile.
And then we're told that the assassin
yourself off,
wants to have another look at the body.
And so he goes downstairs and,
uh,
just affirming the historian quoting
some original sources in his quote,
talks about what happened when you soap
off.
Went down there to just make sure that
nothing wasn't.
Miss Thurman writes,
quote,
he found Rasputin lying in the same
position on the floor.
Overcome with a terrible inner rage,
you soap up,
grabbed Rasputin by the shoulders,
and shook him as he stared into
Rasputin's face.
First one I and then the others suddenly
opened and then the source he's quoting,
says greenish and snake I'd they fixed
the prince with an expression of satanic
hatred.
Rasputin stumbled to his feet,
foaming at the mouth,
roaring and anger,
and wildly clawing at the air.
As he rushed towards you soph off blood
dripping from his mouth,
he grabbed the prince by the shoulder,
ripping an epithet from his uniform.
Rasputin was reportedly groundling,
his tormentors name,
and a low guttural voice and quote.
It's like a Zombie.
And you soap office screaming.
I mean everybody runs downstairs when
they hear this struggle going on and use
up of a screaming.
And by the time everybody gets
downstairs,
Rasputin has lurched into the snowbound
courtyard in his running away and he's
yelling,
you so offs first name,
who's also the prince.
It's Prince yourself of Felix Felix.
I'll tell this,
I'll read everything you know he's going
to tattle on the prince for trying to
kill him.
And people opened.
Fire the prince among others at
Rasputin,
as he flees Mrs a couple times,
then hits him somewhere in the back and
then they run up to the body that's on
the ground and they put a bullet through
his forehead.
Then we're told they wrap him up in a,
tie them up,
then wrap him up in a carpet than go to
a nearby
river where there's ice and throw them
through a hole on the ice and you know,
hope floats to Finland.
Of course he doesn't.
They find him in a few days.
They dragged the body out and and the
myth of this story,
and again,
it's so much better with the myth,
is that during the autopsy,
they found water in his lungs and his
body untied as though he had freed
himself and only at the end drown.
So the cyanide edema didn't work.
They shot him multiple times.
It didn't work.
They threw him in the river and it
almost didn't work.
Historians say that the shot to his
forehead almost certainly killed him.
It's right in the middle of his
forehead.
And it's possible that the cyanide was
old or that never got put in his drinks,
or who knows,
but it adds to the legend of Rasputin.
There's a warning before he dies that he
gives to the royal family.
Supposedly.
That also adds to his legend.
You know,
another one of these prophecies that are
sometimes uncannily correctly supposed
to have said to the royal couple quote,
if I die or you desert me,
you will lose your son and your crown in
six months.
Rasputin is right again from beyond the
grave.
This period in the first world war,
his timeline about the time period
Rasputin dies,
you know,
take a couple of months before he was
assassinated,
a couple of months afterwards.
That really is the first world war is
crowded our.
And you know,
that's what Theodore Roosevelt called
his combat in the Spanish American war.
He was trying to describe these large
number of events that was crammed into a
short period of time.
He said it was his crowded,
our,
the period from about November 19,
16 to April 19,
17 is the first world war was crowded.
Our huge number of events compressed in
a short period of time.
These events are all connected though to
the various themes we've examined
individually so far.
The United States and the United States
involvement in Mexico,
the submarines,
the high level diplomatic activity and
maneuvering,
and the train wreck that's about to
happen with Russia.
This all comes to a head,
as we said in January,
late January 19,
17.
Woodrow Wilson gives his peace without
victory speech.
While he's doing that,
the Germans are already behind the
scenes prepping for their February first
resumption of unrestricted warfare.
They've pulled the trigger on that
because they had given the high level
politicians in Germany the go ahead to
try some peace maneuvering.
Of course,
they were told that the peace
maneuvering doesn't when we let the
submarines go,
the submarines are slated to go February
first,
1917 now because Germany was reasonably
sure as was everyone else.
Pretty much
that if they started shooting at every
ship on the high seas,
the United States was going to get
dragged into the war because Americans
would die.
American ships would go down.
It was pretty much inevitable.
So the Germans started working on some
contingency plans in January 19,
17,
you know,
again,
right around the same time Wilson's
proposing piece for all men and all his
high minded sentiments.
The Germans are sending a telegram to
their ambassador in Mexico,
giving their ambassador in Mexico some
instructions on what to do just in case
the United States comes into the war and
starts fighting Germany.
The telegram from the German foreign
secretary,
a guy named Arthur Zimmerman to the
ambassador of Mexico,
says this quote,
we intend to begin on the first of
February,
unrestricted submarine warfare.
We shall endeavor in spite of this to
keep the United States of America
neutral.
In the event of this not succeeding,
we make Mexico a proposal of alliance on
the following basis,
make war together,
make peace together,
generous financial support and an
understanding on our part that Mexico is
to reconquer the last territory in
Texas,
New Mexico and Arizona.
The settlement in detail is left to you.
You will inform the president of the
above most secretly as soon as the
outbreak of war with the United States
of America is certain.
And add the suggestion that he should on
his own initiative,
invite Japan to immediate adherence and
at the same time mediate between Japan
and ourselves.
Please call the president attention to
the fact that the ruthless employment of
our submarines now offers the prospect
of compelling England in a few months to
make peace and quote.
So there's a note suggesting that Mexico
go to war as part of the central powers
against the United States.
If the United States gets into the war,
what's more?
They talk about getting Japan on board
too.
That was one of the United States is
great worries.
By the way.
The Japanese had scared the Americans.
There's all these theories from American
planners that maybe they could go take
the Panama Canal and come up through
Mexico mean there's all these war plan
kind of fantasies,
but the idea that Japan could be brought
in and flipped because they're on the
allied side.
The Germans are talking about flipping
the Japanese,
making them on the central powers to
having the Japanese attack the
Americans,
the Mexicans attack the Americans.
If nothing else,
that keeps the Americans busy so they're
not over there fighting Germans in
Europe.
If you're playing a board game here of
risk or something that's not a bad idea,
you know,
there's a game called diplomacy.
Not a bad move if you're playing the
game called diplomacy,
proud ms dot all kinds of variables in
real life,
not taken into account in the game of
diplomacy.
One of them is that your enemies might
be tapping into the cable that you use
to send a secret message like from
Germany to Mexico.
The British got it,
snatched it right off of the American
Atlantic cable,
which they were tapping.
I think we mentioned in an earlier
episode that British may be the,
the best espionage code breaker people
of all time.
When the war starts,
they cut the German transatlantic
cables.
Uh,
Germany can't send telegraph messages
across the Atlantic.
So they work out deals to borrow other
people's cable.
Sometimes the United States let them use
the US cable for just messages.
Woodrow Wilson thought would,
would maybe foster peace,
right?
He wants to the Germans to have an open
channel to him.
So the Germans used the American cable
to send a message to Mexico offering
some American states to them if they
come in the war by attacking the United
States.
A little ironic there.
Now the British have a problem.
They can't tell the Americans about this
cable right away because then you're
going to get all these embarrassing
questions like how'd you get the cable?
And then the British would have to say
if they were going to be truthful.
Well,
we tapped into your cable and we've been
reading your messages for the whole war.
Can't quite say that too easily.
So by hook or by Crook,
it's a great story.
Barbara Tuchman wrote a whole book on
it.
Um,
the British figure out a way to sort of
hide the source of,
you know,
how they got this cable.
They give it to the Americans.
Woodrow Wilson is shocked.
Just shocked that this would happen and
understand the context,
right?
This is the very month,
January 1917 that American military
forces are finally withdrawing from the
Poncho via expedition,
right?
This attempt to go get this terrorist us
settlers in Arizona and New Mexico and
Texas would have called you and and the
US forest kind of comes back with their
tail between their legs.
They didn't get Poncho via,
they killed a bunch of his men,
but despite,
you know,
high public praising of everything
involved General John Black Jack
pershing says it wasn't a very memorable
period in American history.
Nonetheless,
it made the Mexicans mad as hell.
And,
and the US almost went to war with
Mexico twice in two years.
In 1914 US troops occupied the city of
Vera Cruz and about 200 people died in
that little endeavor,
maybe closer to 300.
A nearly caused the war between the US
and Mexico.
Then and then in this Poncho via
expedition,
the u s crosses the border,
goes after a guy who is also the enemy
of Mexico's leader,
but it's so upset the Mexicans to have
US troops in their country for any
reason that that almost led to war.
And so just as you're getting your
troops the very month you're getting
your troops out of Mexico,
the Germans are sending them a telegram
saying,
Hey,
want to go to war against the United
States?
I'll give you three states,
will help you.
It struck a nerve for Americans.
When Woodrow Wilson released that letter
publicly,
when the public first heard
about Germany's offered in Mexico,
their reaction was one that I think
would,
would mirror the reaction of the
American public in a similar situation
today.
A large number of them thought that the
telegram was a forgery,
that British intelligence was behind it.
That this was an attempt to trick the
American government and to affect
American public opinion and make them
more angry at Germany.
More pro war.
And it's interesting to speculate how
much you know,
that sort of perception would have
stayed that way.
If the German foreign secretary,
Arthur Zimmerman hadn't done something
in early March,
19,
17 that looks inexplicably,
he admitted that the telegram had been
sent and that it was genuine twice.
The second time he,
he said he hoped the American people
would understand that this was only to
come into effect if war broke out
between Germany and the United States as
a way of saying,
you know,
you don't understand then,
right?
The American people wouldn't understand
the confirmation that the Zimmerman
telegram was indeed an official secret
proposal from the German government to
the Mexican government have set a ton of
Americans and undercut the cause of
German Americans and Irish Americans who
were hoping to keep the United States
neutral was another nail in the coffin
of neutrality and a huge German misstep.
In fact,
the whole decision to unleash the
submarines when they did was a bad
decision by Germany.
If they had only waited a little while.
Longer events would have happened that
would have made that move unnecessary,
and if that's the move that gets the
United States into the war,
than it would have made that event
unnecessary.
Winston Churchill points out that the
timing of the events that happened in
March and April 19,
17 in his mind show the hand of destiny
at work.
Here's how he frames what's about to
happen and what's about to happen.
Ladies and gentlemen,
that will screw up everything here and
you know,
set the stage for our modern world as
much as the United States getting into
this conflict will set the stage for the
modern world.
Russia has its revolution.
Churchill says this quote,
the beginning of 1917,
was marked by three stupendous events,
the German Declaration of unlimited you
boat wore the intervention of the United
States and the Russian revolution taken
together.
These events constitute the second great
climax of the war.
The order in which they were placed was
decisive.
If the Russian revolution had occurred
in January instead of in March,
or if alternatively the Germans had
waited to declare unlimited you boat war
until the summer,
there would have been no unlimited you
boat war and consequently no
intervention of the United States.
If the allies had been left to face the
collapse of Russia without being
sustained by the intervention of the
United States.
It seems certain that France could not
have survived the year and the war would
have ended in a piece by negotiation or
in other words,
a German victory had Russia lasted two
months less,
had Germany refrained for two months
more.
The whole course of events would have
been revolutionized in this sequence.
We discerned the footprints of destiny.
Either Russian endurance or German
impatience was required to secure the
entry of the United States and both were
forthcoming and quote.
As we've mentioned already,
the situation in Russia had been seeding
and simmering for quite some time.
The straw that broke the camel's back
was an almost complete breakdown of
Russia's transportation system,
which had been withering since the war
started,
and that had suffered terribly in the
winter.
That had just happened.
Russia almost couldn't handle it's
transportation needs in peace time.
After several years of war,
there were whole cities that were not
receiving enough food.
One of them was the capitol Petrograd.
Petrograd used to be called St
Petersburg,
but when the war started,
that sounded a little too German,
so they changed it to Petrograd.
This is a city that will change its name
all the time during the communist years.
It will be known as Leningrad now at St
Petersburg again.
Nonetheless,
it's the big metropolis and it doesn't
have enough food.
You take a bunch of people who were
angry,
already add the war ad no food.
It's not surprising they were marching.
They'd been doing it all throughout
1917.
His Irish historian William Mulligan
points out quote from the beginning of
1917,
there was a wave of strikes concentrated
in Petrograd.
On the seventh of March,
30,000
workers were locked out of the feudal
law of armaments,
plants in the city.
The following day,
International Women's Day,
women gathered in the viborg working
class district protest against high bred
prices.
They marched past Finland station toward
Nevsky prospect,
by which time the strikers number to
$100,000
down with the war down with the high
cost of living down with hunger bread
for the workers.
They cried as they marched through the
city.
The protesters connected their
experience of war with much broader
political claims.
Although the crux of their complaints
was the food supply crisis.
This material experience of war had
political implications including the
overthrow,
the czarist regime,
and an end,
the war.
It was possible in theory that the food
supply system could be reformed,
but the strikers knew the czarist regime
could no longer reform itself and quote
British General Sir Henry Wilson Winter
Russia during this time period and came
back and reported to his peers,
you know,
concerning how the people in Russia felt
toward the czar and Zarina and told them
quote,
it seems as certain as anything can be,
that the emperor and empress are riding
for a fall.
Everyone,
officers,
merchants,
ladies,
talk openly of the absolute necessity of
doing away with them.
They've lost their people.
There are no bulls and now their army
and I see no hope for them.
There will be terrible trouble one day
here and to quote,
there are open discussions amongst some
at the higher levels of Russian society.
That terror attack should be made
against the czar.
Someone stands up at the Duma and
important person later in this story and
says that the czar needs to be removed
by terrorist means if necessary.
Now it would be foolish to say that the
royal court did not have their
supporters.
They did,
and they had people who didn't have a
problem with,
you know,
when emperor,
but they had a problem with Nicholas the
second,
so there were all stripes in this idea
that the czar needed to go and no
consensus at all about what would take
its place or how to get from here to
there,
Russia and knew how to have protests and
to revolt about a dozen years before
this time period.
They had the famous 19,
oh,
five revolution,
which had also come after,
you know,
Russian problems in a war and that
revolution broke out.
It got so serious.
The czar supposedly wrote out his
application letter.
He didn't deliver it,
but it was ready to go.
In that particular revolution.
The crowd marched on the Winter Palace
with the czar was to align of troops who
opened fire on them,
killing hundreds of them.
It's known as bloody Sunday.
Bizarre had received intelligence
reports a few months before this event.
Saying that quote recently.
The conviction has been expressed
without exception that we are on the eve
of great events in comparison with which
19,
oh,
five was,
but a toy and the quote that was from a
police report that the czar received
months before these demonstrations in
March break out.
Now here's the thing,
you know as with many historical events,
they can be seemingly inevitable for the
longest time and still come as a
surprise when they actually show up.
The people who were out in the streets
March 7th,
March eighth,
which was international women's Day,
they didn't know that this is the
revolution.
In fact,
the people on the scene point out that
that's one of the tipping moments in
this situation when people understand,
wait a minute,
this just isn't another demonstration
like the kind we've been having.
This is the chance to topple the
government.
That's the big turning point and the
actual moment of the turning point is
one of those really interesting,
almost turning point in history moments.
Revolutionaries like Leon Trotsky,
who certainly see it that way.
Spend a lot of time talking about that
moment.
The tipping point in the revolution.
This is seven days by the way,
folks,
seven days for a 300 year old dynasty to
fall,
and it starts off with some factory
strikers on March seventh.
By the way,
this is our calendar.
These events in Russia happening on on
the old calendar in February,
so it's often called the February
revolution and it makes the dating
confusing as heck for someone like me.
Nonetheless,
March seventh by our calendar,
1917,
there is an industrial strike.
March eighth is international women's
Day.
The women go out and strike and protest
about the lack of brand and all this.
This seems to be key and so many people
talk about it.
The fact that the women are doing this,
a lot of these women are the wives of
soldiers at the front,
which gives them a huge amount of
credibility,
as you might imagine with other soldiers
and they're out on international women's
Day.
On the eighth,
on the ninth,
the women come back out,
bring more people and go to factories
and shops and businesses and grabbed the
workers out and have them join the
strike and the crowd swells to at least
twice.
What it was the day before,
by the next day,
the industry of Russia's capital is
paralyzed and to show you how out of
touch the Zarina is with all this,
she writes in her diary on March 10th
about the troubles in the capital and
she's basically in charge and the
capital quote,
this is a hooligan movement.
Young people run and shout that there is
no bread simply to create excitement
along with the workers who prevent
others from working.
If the weather was very cold,
they would probably all stay at home,
but all this will pass and become calm
if only the Duma will behave itself.
And quote the Duma is the Russian
legislature,
which I think I said earlier,
has about one percent of the power in
the system and his art has about 99
percent.
And is our arena is complaining that the
dumas misusing its one percent sort of
Russian revolutionary.
Leon Trotsky compares her pretty
convincingly to Marie Antoinette before
the French Revolution.
Let them eat cake statement there.
And she and the czar and before he died,
Rasputin liked this one.
Russian minister,
a guy named protocol pop off and so he
begins to sort of act as the Zarina's
minister in all this situation and
according to someone the scene,
it's anger at him.
That prompts a lot of this activity.
The events that are happening starting
really on March eighth and then March
9th are large enough to be a big news
story and the international media is
there.
There are magazine journalists there,
a newspaper reporters from Britain,
France,
places like that,
telling the folks back home what's going
on in the Russian capital.
One is a British newspaper man named
John Pollock and he writes about the
women protesting.
He calls them bread riots.
He writes,
and this is about March eight,
and my apologies for my Russian
pronunciation quote.
The rioting was so far confined to the
vibe Berg side,
the chief workman's quarter of
Petrograd,
but in the center of the tramway service
had already become irregular.
On the ninth,
the rioters stopped the trams across the
river terrorizing the drivers and
throwing parts of the mechanism away so
that the service groups still more
intermittent visits were paid to all the
factories and the hands were called out
in sympathetic strike against the sudden
food shortage on this day to a prefect
of police who threatened the crowd was
killed,
strong coast act squadrons,
patrol Petrograd,
and there was a collision on the Nevsky
in which the cost actually used their
whips,
but they told the crowd that they would
not shoot so long as they only asked for
bread,
alarmed at the attitude of the Cossacks.
The authorities on the 10th brought
troops of the line into the streets to
support the police,
posted machine guns on the Nevsky and
stopped traffic across it.
At many points and quote John Pawlik
then points out it sounds like a rumor,
but what?
What the Russian minister working for
this arena is supposed to have said when
his methods for dealing with this
uprising or being questioned.
Here's what Paul writes.
He says,
quote Frodo popoff approached by one who
endeavored to convince him of the
madness of his methods only answered,
do you know how splendidly machine guns
work from the roof?
End Quote,
pollock says that the first serious
bloodshed happens on March 10th when
police opened fire on a group of
protestors and killer wound 50.
The czar is now told about problems at
the capital.
Remember,
he's off kind of at the front,
not in this capital of his.
He's letting his wife sort of run the
show with this product pop off guy.
Uh,
the czar finds out about it.
They tell them things are bad.
He issues an order that basically says,
make it stop.
That order appears on lamp posts and all
over the city.
The next morning when the rioters and
protesters,
um,
muster to protests for the day,
they see this message from the head of
Petro grads.
Military garrison quote,
during the last days,
disorders have taken place in Petrograd,
followed by force and assaults on the
lives of soldiers and members of the
police.
I forbid,
every kind of assembly in the streets.
I warned the population of Petrograd
that commands have been issued and
repeated to the troops to use their arms
and not to stop short of anything in
order to assure a tranquility in the
capital end.
Quote,
John Pollock is out in the streets that
day when he writes,
quote
Sunday,
March Eleventh,
began nervously.
There were soldiers everywhere in the
streets and strong bodies held in
reserve and courtyards.
By now,
the trams had all stopped and it was
hardly possible to find a car.
No newspapers appeared.
About 3:30
PM,
the troops begin to clear the streets
around the Nevsky at the bayonet point,
and soon afterwards the police turned
their machine guns onto a crowd at the
same place as the day before,
but with more deadly effect.
A Caucasian officer who was nearby
estimating the number of dead at 300 at
the same time,
heavy firing took place further down the
Nevsky and opposite the Khazan
Cathedral.
Several score.
More people were killed.
The crowd here retaliated with pistol
shots,
another prefix and a colonel of the
police besides policemen,
the various innocent passengers by being
killed.
It was significant.
He writes that soldiers were seen among
the crowd,
firing on the police,
and a number of men in some 14 officers
are different.
Detachments were arrested for refusing
to support the police with arms on the
same afternoon,
a drunken officer of the [inaudible]
regiment named nameless,
gavage ordered his men to fire on the
crowd.
They refuse,
but less gavish forced one of the
soldiers to obey his shot,
killed a woman.
And to quote
the hurting of women,
as I said,
seems to be an important part of this
affair because it's mentioned by
everyone.
Trotsky says,
the rumor that was going around was that
a police officer struck a woman with a
club and that this was witnessed by the
cassettes who were sort of sitting by
neutrally,
uh,
they're there to kind of add some muscle
to the mix,
but the army's kind of standing by while
the hated police and the public face
off.
And Trotsky says whether or not it
really happened.
Everybody believed that a woman had been
assaulted in front of the costs x and
the Cossacks drove the police away.
Who did it.
Now,
one of the things that if you've watched
recent revolutions,
you'll notice that oftentimes some
incident will happen,
that the demonstrators and protesters
and rioters will sort of cling to some
sort of symbol generally from the event
that becomes almost like a high sign
that protesters use and that they rally
around according to Trotsky.
What it was in this revolution was a
cavalryman winking to the crowd
and that this wink became sort of a
symbol of what was going on.
Here's the way Trotsky explained it,
and remember Trotsky's or revolutionary
for him,
this is a hugely heroic tale and that's
the way he tells it and I think we're
all colored.
At least those of us who know what's
coming by what's coming.
This revolution's going to devolve into
something very terrible and a lot of us
look back on this event thinking that
that's how we should view the removal of
what came before communism.
And yet there was a period after this
revolution where Russia was on the road
to becoming something more like the
United States.
And so getting rid of a czarist regime
that these people seem to hate,
like Saddam Hussein was initially viewed
as a plus and the reporter on the scene,
for example,
for the British press,
he's thoroughly in favor of something
replacing this regime.
The United States is too,
by the way.
One of the problems the United States
has with joining the allies are being
associated with the allies is not
Britain and France who they feel very
close to in a lot of ways it's Russia to
them.
Russia is the same kind of militant
autocracy that US propaganda paints the
Germans as
the idea of the czar going away to be
replaced by some sort of constitutional
government.
Makes a lot of people in the allied camp
sit up and cheer for the protesters.
Now in the story by Trotsky of the
winking Casech,
he explains that the officers or the
cost x kind of forced them to charge
into the crowd at one point.
But as soon as the officers passed by
and scattered the crowd,
the regular costs x are very careful
moving through with their horses not to
hurt anyone.
And Trotsky writes,
quote behind them,
filling the whole width of the prospect,
Gallup,
the cossacks decisive moment,
but the horseman cautiously in a long
ribbon rode through the court or just
made by the officers.
Some of them smiled,
he quotes a protester,
Kaya Rev recalls,
and one of them gave the workers a good
wink.
This wink,
Trotsky says,
was not without meaning.
The workers were in bold and with a
friendly,
not hostile kind of assurance and
slightly infected the contacts with it.
The one who winked found imitators in
spite of renewed efforts from the
officers.
The Cossacks without openly breaking
discipline,
fail to force the crowd to disperse,
but flowed through it in streams.
This was repeated three or four times
and brought the two sides even closer
together.
Individual costs.
X began to reply to the workers
questions and even to enter into
momentary conversations with them of
discipline.
There remained but a thin,
transparent shell that threatened to
break through any second.
The officers hastened to separate their
patrol from the workers and abandoned
the idea of dispersing them lying to the
coast,
x out across the street as a barrier to
prevent the demonstrators from getting
to the center and to quote.
He then tells the story though about how
these costs x will allow themselves to
be used as a mounted barrier,
but they don't stop the protestors from
diving under the horses' bellies.
The fact that the Cossacks traditionally
these czarist crowd control mechanism
appear less than enthusiastic about
carrying out their traditional role,
convinces the government that they have
to bring in the troops.
The garrison of Petrograd is like 150,
a hundred 60,000
men,
so they've got the people and they call
them in and March 11th is the key day
because that's the day that elements of
one famous unit,
a training squadron that's called open
fire and killed those people that the
British reporter was talking about.
Now the people of Petrograd are
appealing to the troops as you heard
earlier,
mingling with them,
talking to them.
They are walking up to the line of
bayoneted troops,
you know,
in,
in ones and twos and sang brothers.
You're not really going to side with the
police and kill us.
Are you the women?
Again,
taking the lead in this whole thing are
walking right up to the line of
abandoned,
had troops and grabbing their rifles
with the band that's on them and
wrestling with them insane.
Join us.
It's very heroic.
There's a lot of that going on.
After the shootings in the street on
March 11th,
uh,
citizens were told workers go up to
members of one of these story units
and tell them that,
you know,
people in your unit opened fire
yesterday against the people of the city
and told them what happened.
And then those troops went back to their
barracks.
And on the evening of March,
11th morning of March twelfth,
they had one of those moral crisis
moments,
a key instant in any revolution.
A guy like Leon Trotsky would say.
And he describes it with almost heroic,
you know,
tones.
This,
this moment where this story unit
confronts the reality that they shot a
bunch of those poor people that had been
besieging them not to shoot the day
before and they were going to have to go
out and do it again today.
Here's what Trotsky writes,
quote,
the soldiers had no more time for
hesitation.
They were compelled to shoot yesterday
and they would be again today.
The workers will not surrender or
retreat under fire.
They're still holding their own and with
them,
their wives,
mothers,
sisters,
sweethearts.
Yes,
and this is the very hour that they had
so whispered about.
If only we could all get together.
Let me stop here at the Trotsky saying
that all these people in the city had
had thought about could desire be
overthrown.
If only we could all get together that
would happen and now these soldiers were
not taking part in that they were taking
part in crushing that.
If only we could all get together
Trotsky rights and then at that moment
of supreme agony in the unbearable fear
of the coming day,
the choking hatred of those who are
imposing upon them the executioners
role,
their ring out in the barrack room,
the first voices of open indignation and
in those voices to be forever,
nameless,
the whole army with relief and rapture
recognizes itself,
thus dawned upon the earth,
the day of destruction of the Romanov
monarchy and quote,
those soldiers shot there.
Officer ran out into the streets
cheering and joined the people of
Petrograd trying to overthrow the czar.
They encouraged other military units to
follow.
Most of which by the end of March
twelfth had done so.
The the garrison was melting away and
joining the anti czarist rioters.
They ransack the artillery depot.
Then they go to the arsenal and break
into it and take all the weapons than
they burned down the court of Justice
and a bunch of other government
buildings.
And for March twelfth on,
you have open battles in the streets
between the people in the army and the
very large police forces.
You know,
we would call them today the secret
police and all these police agencies
that have set up machine guns at
intersections.
At this point.
The big question is,
what the heck is the czar doing?
The first thing is our tries to do is
just get rid of the Duma and when the
head of this powerless,
for all intents and purposes,
Russian legislature receives the order
that the Duma is to disband.
He says no,
and most of the Duma joins him in the
street joining the revolution.
Next,
the czar gets on a train on the 13th of
March and heads back toward the capital
from the fighting front where he is in
one of his typically strange moves.
He takes a lot longer to get there than
he should have because he says he
doesn't want to disrupt any of the war
traffic heading to the front.
So his.
His train takes sort of the long way
around and it ends up getting stopped on
the way to Petrograd because the
revolution is spreading to other cities
now and at one of these train stops,
the revolutionaries are stopping the
train.
We're told that the czars advisors are
bringing him telegrams from power
brokers,
including,
for example,
um,
his cousin and others that he,
he needs to give up the crown.
And what's sort of interesting about
Nicholas is that he almost seems willing
to do it.
There's a whole line of thinking,
you know,
if you read a lot of the primary
sources,
he sometimes portrayed as this drunken
tyrant,
you know,
and,
but when you read more modern day
history,
he's a much more pitiable figure.
Churchill likes him and moved,
but Churchill would like Azhar but says
great things about in this poor,
misunderstood person.
Of course he wasn't a great man,
just a good man.
And he talks about it in like that.
But the czar sort of seems to be
relieved by the prospect of giving up
the crown.
At first there's like five minutes of
talk about giving it to his hemophiliac
son,
but this art doesn't want that.
And interestingly enough in the
abdication note to his people,
the czar specifically mentions not
wanting to be parted from,
you know,
the son that he adores.
Once again,
you get that feeling of nicholas and
Alexandra has these kinds of parents who
just adore their children.
Whether or not this is some sort of
smokescreen to cover something,
all the evidence seems to point out to a
guy who cared more about his family in
some ways than beings are.
There was a quote to the guy who will
take over the what's called the
provisional government of,
um,
the country in the near future.
His name is Alexander Kerensky,
and he met the tsar after desire had
been taken into custody.
And he said,
quote,
as I studied his face,
I seem to see behind his smile and
charming eyes,
a stiff,
proper mask of utter loneliness and
desolation.
When I began to know this living mask,
I understood why it had been so easy to
overthrow his power.
He did not wish to fight for it,
and it simply fell from his hands and
quote the things that this is our was
going to have to do to keep power.
He seemed unwilling to do.
His wife may have wanted him to.
She wrote letters telling him he needed
to be tougher and stronger.
He seemed to care more about the fact
that all his children,
while all this is going on,
have a bad case of the measles,
which was pretty serious back then and
um,
is as concerned seemingly for them as he
is of giving up,
you know,
his power all over Russia,
they to break into government
buildings and tear down paintings of the
czar
and the aftermath of this revolution.
Sounds like the aftermath of the fall of
Saddam Hussein.
Again,
when all these figures that were part of
the government that worked for the czar
are being arrested and held in custody
by people,
you know,
armed with weapons to power blocks form
in the wake of all this.
Because remember,
there is no plan.
The real revolutionaries who had been
working for this for years.
We're kind of caught off guard when it
happened.
So there's,
there's competing groups for power.
One group is the people that used to be
the almost powerless Duma.
All of a sudden they have power and
they're mostly liberals and um,
and mild socialist.
And people who want to create,
they end up writing the United States by
the way in June saying this,
they want to create a constitutional
government.
They want to use maybe the United States
as a sort of a model,
but competing with that particular
entity for power is power at a much
lower level groups that especially of
revolutionaries forming councils of
workers and soldiers together and they
formed this rough,
weird partnership with the provisional
government is it's called the former
Duma and they kind of work with each
other sometimes,
but they come to,
you know,
disagreements over other things.
But when push comes to shove,
the Soviets as they're called these,
you know,
elected groups of people from soldiers
and workers councils seems to win.
The first thing that they win is a rule
that says that anything involving the
military is under the control of the
Soviets.
And this is the key issue for the other
countries in the war in Germany wants
Russia out of the war.
They have been paying agitators for a
long time to hopefully make that happen.
Now you have this situation where the
czars gone.
What are the Russians going to do
militarily,
the British and the French field,
the same way along with the Americans.
They're not that upset that the czar is
gone,
but they're very concerned that Russia
is going to pull out of the war.
This provisional government,
there'll be known as the Koretsky
government.
At a certain point,
they tell the allies that they're going
to continue fighting.
They're committed to continue fighting
the allies start pouring money and stuff
into Russia even at a greater pace than
they were before,
but how do you continue to hold off
Germany in the central powers with your
army while you're 300 year old monarchy
is busy collapsing and all the
structures that have been hanging by a
string start falling apart.
What are the soldiers at the front going
to do?
This became the key question and it's
not answered right away.
Churchill,
as only he can solve the whole thing is
an unmitigated disaster.
Looking back on it from the late 19
twenties again,
now he can where all this is
going to go to communism in the future,
so his ideas are probably tainted.
He said,
the tragedy of Russia was,
and I'm quoting here,
that her ship went down within sight of
port,
meaning you know,
we were just going to win this war,
and then Russia doesn't get to share in
the spoils,
and he says,
I've Russia quote,
with victory in her grasp,
she fell upon the earth,
devoured alive like Herod of old by
worms but not in vain.
Her valiant deeds,
the giant mortally stricken,
had just time with her dying strength to
pass the torch eastward across the ocean
to a new titan long sunken doubt,
who now arose and began ponderously to
arm.
The Russian Empire fell on March 16th on
April sixth,
the United States entered the war and
quote,
it's been an interesting two months for
the United States since Germany decided
to unleash the submarines in the first
20 days of unleashing the submarines.
The Germans sink a hundred and 28
merchant ships,
40 neutrals among them.
Um,
there are US shipping companies in the
month of February when this all starts
that start losing a million dollars.
Nineteen 17 value money by the way,
a week.
The next month,
March 19,
17,
those numbers will double and all of a
sudden we begin to see what the first
real competent use involving at least a
minimum number of submarines is like in
world history.
The Germans had been perfecting what you
do with these new weapons systems like
submarines,
these science fiction type weapons.
What do you.
How do you use them at the beginning of
the war?
They're kind of going after war ships
and whatnot,
and then they work on short little burst
going after neutrals and merchant ships
and now by 1917 the Germans know what
they want to do with these things and
they have enough ships to make their
plan work.
Minimum number,
but enough they unleashed them to go
after everything,
which is what their strategy has told
them.
You have to do to really maximize this
weapon system and they're sinking enough
ships so that Britain is for the first
time in the war in real danger itself of
going under.
One of the advantages of being an island
nation is if you got the strongest navy,
you don't have to have the same kind of
fears that are Russia has or a France
has.
The Germans aren't going to be able to
break you directly because they can't
reach you.
This is the first time in the war that
the British face,
any serious threat of the Germans in one
way or another,
reaching them,
affecting them personally,
forcing them perhaps to knuckle under to
some sort of peace deal.
In April the month the United States
gets into the war,
the Germans sync for 123 merchant men,
almost 850,000
tons of shipping.
The British empire cannot stand those
kinds of losses.
It's submarine war that eventually
brings the United States in.
If for no other reason than it's
disrupting operations in the country.
The president is under a lot of pressure
on a day to day increasing basis because
once Germany started sinking,
all these ships,
US ships stopped leaving.
They begin to congregate and clogged up
and cause traffic jams outside the major
ports on the eastern seaboard.
And then all of the commodities and food
and perishables that were going to be
loaded onto those ships begin backing
up.
You got this terrible catalog at all the
ports on the eastern coast of material
that's rotting and degrading because the
ship's won't cross the Atlantic because
they're afraid of the submarines.
At one point,
Wilson wants to arm these ships to
change the situation.
He wants to provide insurance so that
they can,
you know,
cross.
But this is like a ticking time bomb for
Wilson.
He's got to do something.
This situation only going to get worse.
The Zimmerman telegram happens in late
February to.
I mean all these things that just
increases situation that's bad and make
it worse.
But there's no instant moment where the
line has been crossed and there never
will be
at some point by March 19,
17 at the latest.
And probably around the same time the
Russian revolution is happening,
the Wilson Administration decides that
they've had enough five US ships go down
in March 19,
17 to some in the Wilson Administration.
This is confirmation that the US has
already at war with Germany.
There doesn't have to be some big
Lusitania nine slash 11 moment to
crossover this invisible line.
It's happening every day and on April
Second Wilson gives his most famous
speech,
one of the most important speeches in
American history concerning the
situation that he sees that the United
States is at war with Germany.
And the interesting part about the
speech,
if you dissected,
it's monumental on so many levels.
He's so crafty the way it's put
together.
He never says to the Congress,
declare war on Germany,
you know,
so that will be at war with Germany.
He says,
we're at war with Germany and I invite
you to confirm that fact he had no time.
Gives Congress the impression that they
have any control over this decision at
all.
Now,
luckily for him,
they went along with him big time,
but what if they hadn't?
Part of Wilson's speech focuses on the
specific reason.
We're at this point.
He talks about the submarine warfare,
compares Germans to pirates and all
these kinds of things.
Then he takes some time out of his
speech to say that we're not at war with
the German people.
We have no quarrel with them,
it's their government we don't like and
this is a big change by the way,
in the way that much of the United
States government will craft,
you know,
the way that they frame relationships
with other countries too.
I got nothing against the people.
It's the government and Wilson's point
of view is if the people aren't running
the government like in a democracy or a
republic,
well then the people aren't responsible
for what their government's decisions
are.
They may be the victims of it and we
might have to hurt you in order to
overthrow your government,
but we're not mad at you about half this
speech is really high minded sentiments
forever known afterwards as Wilsonian
principles that talk about things like
the need to make the world safe for
democracy.
And I'll give you a taste of that in a
second but more interesting.
And again,
one of the more groundbreaking parts of
this speech is that Wilson takes on the
US tradition of non involvement in
European affairs head on.
And he basically said that was the way
it was.
Times have changed.
Here's the exact phrasing that he gives,
but it is a sea change in American
foreign policy and the way the
government of the United States
approaches the conflicts and involvement
with the rest of the world and that
course change is one we are still living
with today in the modern world in the
middle of his speech telling Congress
that award exists right now in Germany.
Wilson says,
quote,
our object now as then is to vindicate
the principles of Peace and justice in
the life of the world as against selfish
and autocratic power and to set up
amongst the really free and
self-governed peoples of the world,
such a concert of purpose into action as
well,
hence forth.
Ensure the observance of those
principles.
Neutrality is no longer feasible or
desirable,
where the peace of the world is involved
and the freedom of its peoples and the
menace to that peace and freedom lies in
the existence of autocratic governments
backed by organized force which has
controlled holy by there will not by the
will of their people.
We have seen the last of neutrality in
such circumstances were at the beginning
of an age where it will be insisted that
the same standards of conduct and have
responsibility for wrong done shall be
observed among nations and their
governments that are observed among the
individual citizens of civilized states
and quote,
having a national policy connected to
the idea of not going abroad in search
of monsters to slay just started to
sound really old fashioned,
didn't it?
But at least Wilson's got some really
good arguments to justify the historic
course change.
These are the ideas of wilsonianism and
here's how Wilson annunciates just some
of them quote,
it is a distressing and oppressive duty.
Gentlemen of the Congress,
which I have performed in thus
addressing you.
There are,
it may be many months of fiery trial and
sacrifice ahead of us.
It is a fearful thing to lead this
great,
peaceful people into war into the most
terrible disasters of all wars.
Civilization itself seeming to be in the
balance,
but the right is more precious than
piece and we shall fight for the things
which we have always carried nearest our
hearts for democracy,
for the right,
those who submit to authority to have a
voice in their own governments for the
rights and liberties of small nations
for a universal dominion of right by
such a concert of free peoples as shall
bring peace and safety to all nations
and make the world itself at last free
to such a task we can dedicate our lives
and our fortunes,
everything that we are in,
everything that we have with the pride
of those who know that the day has come
when America is privileged to spend her
blood and her might,
for the principles that gave her birth
and happiness and the peace which she
has treasured God helping her.
She can do no other and quote one
wonders what John Quincy Adams would
reply to that nonetheless.
Guys like Theodore Roosevelt,
who had been saying he was going to skin
Wilson alive if Wilson didn't go to war
like the speech a lot.
It's interesting to note by the way,
that the one American political figure
that the Europeans really respect in
this whole question is Theodore
Roosevelt,
because Theodore Roosevelt is really one
of the early what will be called Atlanta
cysts.
People who believe,
for example,
in locking arms with countries like
Great Britain and doing great things
with them.
Tiara was an interventionist before his
time and in the United States.
He's thought of as an extremist.
The Republican candidate for president
tells him to stop campaigning for him
because he's so bellicose.
It's working against the Republican
Party,
right?
You're letting Wilson and the opposition
portray us as warmongers.
That's the guy though that appeared to
be ahead of the curve when it came to
figuring out that Germany needed to be
dealt with.
Again,
from the British point of view,
there's a lot of this that you could
look at and say the various things the
Germans are being slammed for doing are
things that they were kind of forced
into doing by what their opponents were
up to.
The first world war is not the clear
cut,
good and evil separation that the Second
World War is,
and we've mentioned that before.
Nonetheless,
if you're on one side of it,
it certainly is the prime minister of
Great Britain for about a couple of
months when Wilson makes his historic
speech,
is Lloyd George in his memoirs,
Lloyd George Writing after the war can't
help but take a shot at Wilson,
not because of what he did,
but because of how long it took him
speaking about Wilson's speech.
Now,
George writes,
quote,
these principles were excellent and
excellently expressed.
The ally.
Democracies are France and the British
Commonwealth had already borne the
burden and been scorched by the heat of
a thousand days in the battle with this
natural flow to liberty,
stealing one of Wilson's lines from his
speech they rejoiced.
George does at the advent of this
powerful help from the greatest
democracy in the world at a time when
troubles were multiplying,
they perhaps might be excused for
thinking.
That issue is so clear now to President
Wilson ought to have been apparent
earlier to his eyes.
They felt grateful in their hearts to
the great American Theodore Roosevelt,
whose vision was so undimmed and who
sympathies were so sure from the outset
of this grim struggle for international
right and quote Winston Churchill
sounded almost the exact same way.
What took you so long?
Speaking of Wilson's piece,
attitudes quote he had behind his policy
or reason to explanation and massive
argument and all must respect the
motives of a statesman who seeks to
spare his country the waste and horrors
of war,
but nothing.
Churchill writes,
can reconcile what he said after March
19,
17 with a guidance he had given before.
What he did in April,
19,
17.
Could have been done in May 19,
15.
And if done then what abridgment of the
slaughter,
what sparing of the agony,
what ruined,
what catastrophes would've been
prevented in how many million homes with
an empty chair be occupied today?
How different would be the shattered
world in which victor and vanquished
alike are condemned to live and quote,
writing from the late 19 twenties and
seeing the mortally wounded and terribly
scarred continent,
which Winston Churchill remembers as
being the height of world civilization
to him.
The US taking this long to get into the
war looks like something that costs you
the world you knew
a couple of days after the president
gives his famous speech,
the Congress votes to support him and
take the nation to war.
The vote wasn't close by the way,
in the House of Representatives,
it was something like 374 or 375 to 50
and as much as a wipe out as that
sounds,
I read somewhere that that's the second
most opposition.
The congress has ever shown the
president in a war vote.
The war of 18,
12 being the most nonetheless seems
pretty clear that most of those people
voting or unsure about what voting for
going to war was going to mean the
future mayor of New York fiero Laguardia
was a congressmen when this vote was
taken.
He said that 60 percent,
he said 30 years after the war,
that 60 percent of his brethren,
we're pretty sure this wasn't going to
mean troops on the ground in Europe.
The US didn't send armies overseas to
fight,
you know,
on European soil.
They thought it was going to be like
financial aid and naval help.
Naval helped is the one thing that us
can do right away.
Military Health and an army.
That's a problem because the US really
doesn't have one.
In April,
19,
17,
the US army's ranked 17th largest in the
world.
Doesn't have any flame throwers or any
tanks or any gas masks or mortars,
no grenades.
The aircraft are these rickety strange
beasts that you the right bread,
they look like the planes,
the Wright brothers kind of put
together.
They don't look modern at all.
There's not enough artillery shells for
the guns to shoot more than a few
minutes by western front,
you know,
standards.
Historian,
justice donut key says that the US
relatively speaking had been better
prepared for the American revolution and
the war of 1812 than they were prepared
for the first world war.
I disagree with him about that,
but his point is well taken.
The United States,
if it's going to be any help to Europe,
Europe's going to have to survive while
it waits for this help to be
accumulated.
The only place that us can help right
away is with money,
which they were kind of doing already.
They're going to lower interest rates
and give better deals,
but it's a continuation of what was
already happening and the use of the
navy and the thing the navy can do right
away is held against the submarines
because as we said in April 19,
17,
the submarine sink more than 400
merchant ships.
Britain's problem isn't that it doesn't
have to stop all the sinking.
It has to stop the rate,
which is so much more than what it can
rebuild.
If it loses less ships than it can build
a month,
it's doing well.
If it loses more shifts than it can
build a month,
it's in trouble.
The height of this submarine war will be
from February 19,
17 when unrestricted warfare is declared
and the next eight months.
This is when Britain lives or dies.
Those are the stakes and Lloyd George
and Churchill and all these guys go out
of their way to talk about the almost
alarm is the word Lloyd George's is
Lloyd.
George says that there are some of the
most cautious people in his cabinet that
are starting to muse out loud about
maybe we better make peace while we
still have some ships afloat,
and he says the Germans were getting
gleeful that at times they just had
these reports coming in that made all
the pro sub marine people seem to be
perfectly correct.
They were all of a sudden going to win
the war.
Churchill said,
we went from being,
you know,
the side that had time on our side and
we could just wait this out and everyday
the Germans were losing the war a little
bit more to having the tables flipped
and now time was on the German side and
the British had to come up with
countermeasures or lose the war fast.
They not only did this,
but it was the civilian leadership that
pushed for the answer that turned out to
make the biggest difference.
This is sort of one of these early
indications that something is changing
in the war.
For years,
the military men have had an almost
unquestioned authority to choose
whatever path for fighting the war they
wanted to,
no matter what happened,
but now so many people had died and so
many disasters and so much of the same
tactic seeming to equal the same results
except more bodies stacking higher and
higher that that there was pushback now
from civilian leaders.
Lloyd George and Britain is one of these
guys who's who says openly that my job
is to protect the soldier in the field
and to the soldier in the field,
the generals,
his biggest enemy sometimes,
and you could hear all this,
talk about the stupidity of the military
leaders.
Even Churchill kind of goes out of his
way to say that the military experts all
against the solution that ended up
solving the sub problem.
It was the civilian leaders for the most
part,
that pushed the idea that won the day.
The idea was both breathtakingly simple
and incredibly complex.
The idea was convoys,
the grouping of ships into large
formations surrounding them with war
ships and escorts and sending these
large bodies of ships across at
organized times and schedules.
The military men often believed that
this was just going to group your
targets for the submarines,
make it even easier to align ships up
like in a shooting gallery,
but when it was experimented on again,
the civilian leaders pushing to
experiment with this.
The results were fantastic almost right
away.
The u boats,
that approach,
these kinds of formations often got
sunk.
The idea that it was going to be easier
to spot 50 or 60 ships on the water
rather than a single ship turned out to
not be true in the vast spaces of the
ocean.
Big Ole convoys got swallowed up to and
as Churchill said,
when these convoys made it across the
water and slipped through the blockade,
instead of having one ship make it
through the German blockade,
you had 40,
50 or 60 ships do it
by October 19,
17 of 99 convoys heading to Great
Britain with more than 1500 ships in
them.
Only 10 that were still part of the
convoy,
we're sunk 14 more that it straight and
got lost.
We're sunk.
Those are easily replaceable losses.
And by October 1917,
it was clear that the Germans were no
longer going to be able to sink more
shipping than the British could replace
what's more.
They now had us ship yards helping to
replace them.
As you might imagine,
the whole decision on Germany's part to
engage in this kind of submarine warfare
is one of the most,
if not the most criticized decision that
the German leadership ever made.
It's understandable and you know,
it kind of once again puts the lie to
this stereotype of the Germans as sort
of applauding methodical,
sort of,
um,
you know,
conservative sort of leadership style
because in both were awards,
the Germans would prove to be great,
great gamblers.
They just weren't lucky gamblers,
but they were willing many times to sort
of throw caution to the wind and try
these things.
In a sense though,
it's a defense mechanism when you are
the weaker party
mean to me,
the analogy that works best in the in
the war that,
that we have going right now is to
weight lifters competing against each
other and one of these weightlifters is
bigger and stronger than the other one,
which is obviously a huge advantage in
weightlifting,
but it isn't.
Everything on the weaker weightlifter
has to try,
you know,
to make up for it with technique and
training and will to win
and maybe taking some chances.
That's Germany strategy for the rest of
this war.
And you know,
you're seeing so many aspects of change
from the 19th century to the 20th
century that you can point to in the
story.
Because that's really the theme when you
look at this war.
You know,
in a big picture sense.
Germany has transformed in the recent
past 1916 the year before this time.
We're in now from really an old style
monarchy with legislative,
you know,
balancing out to,
to something that looks much more like a
20th century military dictatorship.
And it doesn't happen overnight and it
almost kind of happens because it needs
to.
The only way Germany has a chance in
this war is to be the technique master
and have the greater will to win.
All those things I said about the
smaller weightlifter.
Germany has to organize it society more
efficiently than the more powerful
allied countries.
If it's going to stand a chance.
And one of the things that happens is
when you get Hindenburg and Ludendorff
in there,
remember the two German commanders,
we talked about this military team,
but it's really only one guy,
the Luton Dorf guy.
He takes on more and more the powers
that in the 20th century we see over and
over again in regimes where you have one
strong man who sort of has dictatorial
control and the Germans start to try to
organize their society to make it more
efficient.
Like,
you know,
being able to tell workers where they're
going to work,
you know,
controlling people down to that level.
Because as one of the German leaders
said,
the goal is to turn Germany into one
vast munitions factory.
To do that requires a sort of single
mindedness and and a lot of power
concentrated in one person at this stage
in the war.
That person is Ludina doors.
He and Hindenburg took over in 1916 and
the first thing they did was sort of do
an audit of how the war is going and
what we're doing to fight it in the
conditions.
And the first condition you noticed when
you take over the entire war is on the
western front.
You have about two and a half million
men manning the barricades.
The other side has about 4 million men
and their numbers are increasing every
month.
How do those trends look?
You have food riots at home.
Women fighting with police officers in
the streets because they can't get the
food they need.
You have strikes in a bunch of the major
firms and in a bunch of the cities and
they get so bad sometimes the army has
to be called in to disperse the
strikers,
so the government is now going in and
sending strike leaders to the front to
get them out of the way.
I mean,
the society is under severe stress and
we already talked about the food.
I mean,
there's a quote from earns glazer that
that sums it up when he talks about this
period they're in now and he,
he says,
quote soon,
alluded ham,
thrilled us more than the fall of
Bucharest or some of parents success
elsewhere,
and to quote these people's needs have
shrunk down to the most basic human
survival levels.
Yeah,
great.
We took Bucharest,
but did you see that hand we have in the
cellar that we found?
I mean,
you know,
that's something any of us could
understand if we began to starve.
The pressure is on Germany's military
leadership to do something.
You can't very well launching offensive
on the western front when you're
outnumbered the way you are,
you're going to be lucky to survive at
all.
Nineteen 16 was terrible for the Germans
on the western front,
so you launch the submarines and that
becomes your chance to win the war
without having to do the impossible.
On the western front.
Now alluded,
Dorf is a very strange guy.
This is commander of Germany,
you know,
sort of in more every day in this story.
Hindenburg,
his partner is the charisma guy,
but he's an old man.
He really,
if he had been great at one time in his
life,
he's in his dotage now and he's,
he's the revered public face of this
government,
but lewd indoors doors,
the guy behind the scenes and we talked
about him and he's the one who way back
in 1914,
got that city in Belgium to surrender by
banging on the front doors with the hilt
of his sword,
you know,
when he easily could have been killed,
walked right up to the front door loan
guide.
I mean,
that's,
he's an interesting guy.
He's flawed in a lot of ways.
And depending on which historian you
grabbed,
your going to hear the,
the bumbling,
uh,
psychologically fragile Luton door for,
you're going to see this is great
gambler,
who was,
who was fantastic at certain things.
And remember,
all these generals are 19th century men.
They are adapting under fire at a quick
pace to all these new conditions.
And just when you think they are getting
it,
some new development comes around,
maybe you're starting to understand the
physics of land warfare a year or two
into the first world war.
If you're a general and then tanks
appear and then gas appears.
I mean,
what do you do with all this airplane?
Start having a real impact.
You don't just have to learn.
You have to be flexible to continue to
evolve as these generals and nobody's
great at it.
Luton doors,
not bad.
Ludendorff changes.
By the way,
the basic strategy of the guy who came
before him,
Fun Falcon Heights strategy was,
you know,
basically defend every inch of
territory.
Luton.
Dorf is perfectly willing to give up
territory in exchange for killing
people.
He'll pull off things like operation
Alberico right about this time period
starts in late February,
1917 where he will pull back troops that
are,
that are in unexposed loop in the line.
The line isn't straight because of
fighting here and there.
It's bulging out in some places and
there are kinks in it.
And he begins in early 1917 to pull
troops back that are,
that are way out there in no man's land
and straightened up his line.
He'll cut off like 25 miles from the
western front by doing this,
freeing up 13 or 14 divisions as
basically a German army to be used
elsewhere.
Now that's a complicated maneuver,
but his strategy in 1917 as far as he's
concerned,
is going to be defense.
So he's going to line things up and
prepare for that.
And it gives him all kinds of
advantages.
This is one area,
it will be called the Hindenburg line
that he puts together.
It's hard to imagine making the defenses
of 1916 deeper and stronger and more
impenetrable,
but that's what they do in 1917.
The hindenburg line is an example of
Luton.
Doris idea of defense in depth.
And what that means is as the German
defenses go back and they're designed to
act like a rubber band so that when
something runs into them,
it just stretches and stretches and
stretches,
and the farther it stretches,
the more resistance you find.
And then eventually just snaps back.
It's devious mean the way it's designed
and I don't need to get into all the
details.
It's the machine guns and the barbed
wire and the pillboxes and all these
things,
but they just go far back into the
distance and there's no more trenches
anywhere near the front lines because
those are too easy to pick out and
everybody just sort of sits in holes in
the ground and the sort of a random
pattern and there's no line.
In fact,
there's hardly any Germans when you
first get to it.
It's just a few Germans holding you up
and taking casualties and then as soon
as they can't keep you at bay anymore,
they retreat back to the next line and
then do the next line and every step of
the way.
The defenses are a little bit stronger
and the Germans are a little bit more
numerous.
As the British or the French who are
attacking them are getting less and less
numerous and then as they're getting
more tired.
I mean,
I thought to myself,
some of these defenses go back nine,
10 miles.
It would kill me without any resistance.
Imagine trying to do it with machine
guns and rifle fire and grenades and
artillery and I mean it just,
it's.
You just can't imagine having much left
if you even get the nine or 10 miles to
the end of the defenses and then waiting
for you.
There are German armies who are going to
counterattack anything that's left that
makes it all the way through these
defenses.
It is absolutely almost impenetrable and
devious.
If you only have two and a half,
two point $8 million men to fight four
or four and a half million men on the
other side.
This is a good way to equalize the odds.
This is a weightlifter who's figured out
a way to lift more than a bigger
opponent.
My favorite part of the Hindenburg line
defenses as a military history fan is
that they build a giant moat in front of
it.
I mean,
there's no other way to phrase it.
It's an absolutely perpendicular wall
trench that is between nine and 10 feet
deep and 12 feet across.
It's meant to stop everything tanks
especially mean fall into there and
won't be able to climb up the
perpendicular side,
but it's not an easy job for troops
either and behind this giant moat,
as you might imagine,
our machine gun positions and all kinds
of defenses and more wire and all these
sorts of things.
It is crazy to think about having to
attack something like that and what's
more when Luton Dorf has people retreat
sort of toward the Hindenburg line and
give up these positions that hundreds of
thousands of Germans had died contesting
over the last couple of years.
He has soldiers destroy everything you
know as they go,
creating a dead zone from the old
frontline to the new one,
a scorched earth policy,
something which by the way upset crown
prince rubric to was the Field Marshal
commanding some of the troops who had to
do this destruction.
He was so upset.
He almost resigned over it and
complained about,
you know,
how this would hurt Germany's
reputation.
And in that discussion,
you basically see a 19th century of
figure with 19th century standards,
crown prince rubric to member of the
Bavarian royalty and Luton Dorf a
thoroughly 20th century,
total war kind of guy.
It's a clash of cultures.
The 20th century one Ludendorff got his
way and the troops of the German army in
a very old school style began creating a
dead zone in this part of France in
front of the Hindenburg line and a dead
zone that extended in some places.
Twenty miles,
German soldier Ernst,
young or was there watching the
destruction take place.
And he compares it to a kind of lunacy.
I mean,
it's funny because if you think about
people doing this in the Second World
War,
you think about them using mostly
explosives and they were explosives used
to create this dead zone,
but Germany needed her explosives.
And so a lot of this stuff was done by
hand and younger says it had a bad
effect on the troops.
And he also blamed some of it on what he
calls the economic times we live in or
something like that.
And what he really means by that is this
total war 20th century sort of mentality
younger writes about passing through
this dead zone that was being created by
the German army.
As it moved backwards towards its main
line quote,
the villages we pass through on our way
had the look of vast lunatic asylums.
Whole companies were set to knocking or
pulling down walls or sitting on
rooftops,
uprooting the tiles.
Trees were cut down,
windows smashed wherever you looked.
Clouds of smoke and dust rose from vast
piles of debris.
We saw men dashing about wearing suits
and dresses left behind by the
inhabitants with top hats on their heads
with destructive cunning.
They found the roof trees of the houses,
fixed ropes to them,
and then with concerted shouts polled
until they all came tumbling down,
others were swinging pile driving
hammers and wind around smashing
everything that got in their way from
the flower pots on the window sills to
whole ornate conservatories as far back
as the siegfried line.
That's what the Germans called the
Hindenburg line.
Every village was reduced to rubble.
Every tree chopped down.
Every road undermined every well
poisoned.
Every basement blown up or booby
trapped,
every rail unscrewed,
every telephone wire rolled up.
Everything burnable burned in a word.
We were turning the country that are
advancing.
Opponents would occupy into a wasteland.
As I say,
he writes,
the scenes were reminiscent of a
madhouse and the effect on the men was
similar.
Half funny half repellent.
They were also,
we could see right away,
bad for the men's morale and honor here
for the first time I witnessed wanton
destruction that I was later in life to
see,
to access.
This is something that has unhealthfully
bound up with the economic thinking of
our age,
but it does more harm than good to the
destroyer and dishonors the soldier and
quote,
and it should be remembered.
The decision to award damaged country.
This,
this area that they are pulling apart
now in creating a dead zone,
was an idyllic part of France that
wasn't touched by the war.
If you weren't right on the front in the
first world war,
especially in the western front,
things were great behind it.
One of the complaints French soldiers on
leave have is you can get 20 or 30 miles
behind the front line and everything is
like there's not even a war going on,
you know,
they see men with their sweethearts
prowling around going to restaurants for
dinner in a town 30 miles from the
front,
and it's like it's another world,
so they're tearing down these beautiful
parts of France to create this dead
zone.
They're destroying everything and then
they're leaving booby traps behind
because when the Germans give up their
positions,
they're going to retreat.
As I said,
sometimes 20 miles in this one area all
the way back to the main line.
The allies are going to follow them when
they follow them,
they're going to run into these towns.
When they run into these towns,
they're going to run into and younger.
Talked about it earlier,
booby traps.
Here's what he said,
quote,
among the surprises we prepared for our
successors were some truly malicious
inventions,
very fine wires,
almost invisible.
We're stretched across the entrance of
buildings and shelters,
which set off explosive charges at the
faintest touch in some places.
Narrow ditches were dug,
a crossroads and shells hidden in them.
They were then covered over by a large
plank and had earth strewn over them,
and nail had been driven into the plank
only just above the shelf use.
The space was measured so that marching
troops could pass over the spot safely,
but the moment the first truck or field
gun rumbled up,
the board would give and the nail would
touch off the shell or there were
spiteful time bombs that were buried in
the basements of undamaged buildings.
They consisted of two sections with a
metal partition going down the middle in
one part was explosive in the other
acid.
After these devils eggs,
he calls them,
had been primed and hidden.
The acids slowly over weeks eroded the
metal partition and then set off the
bomb.
In quote British reporter Philip Gibbs
went through some of these towns right
after younger and his men had vacated
them,
and allied forces had moved in and
Gibb's talks about all those same kinds
of booby traps and then says this quote,
only a few of our men were killed or
blinded by these monkey tricks.
Are Engineers found most of them before
they were touched off,
but one went down dugouts or into ruin
houses with a sense of imminent danger
all through the devastated region.
One walked with an uncanny feeling of an
evil spirit left behind by the masses of
men whose bodies had gone away.
It exuded from scraps of old clothing.
It was in the stench of the dugouts and
in the ruins that they had made,
and to quote a booby trap,
dead zone,
Lewd endorphins,
a fully 20th
century total war commander,
and this is a big move.
This is pulling a big rabbit out of a
hat and it's,
you know,
if you're a military history fan like I
am,
it's what makes alluded door.
So interesting.
Not a lot of generals would pull this
kind of stunt and it was a game changer
in many respects.
I mean that whole dead zone for example,
proved to be a huge problem for British
and French forces to try to overcome.
They move into this cratered,
destroyed denuded area where even the
wells have been poisoned.
How do you even supply that?
The Germans on the other hand,
they've moved to sites they'd been
working on for months.
Some parts of the Hindenburg line have
had half a million workers working on it
for months and months and months and
building a new front line from scratch.
It's like building a new home.
It was now moving.
Ready.
They moved back into it and there are
railroads bringing supplies up to the
back.
What Luton Dorf did was wrong foot.
The allies he stolen night,
March.
He sees the initiative.
He changed their plans for 1917 without
knowing what their plans were.
He simply figured,
if I do this,
all the planning they've been doing for
months will be obsolete.
They're planning to have me 20 miles
closer to Paris than I am.
If you were an ally general,
how would you deal with this problem?
And if you said you don't want to deal
with this problem,
that this looks like an impenetrable
nightmare,
that just puts you in league with those
military thinkers at the time who were
known as easterners.
These people who thought attacking on
the western front was insane.
Look at the defenses.
Who would do that?
The prime minister of Britain,
Lloyd George is one of these guys.
Here's the thing though.
You can always find generals and
military commanders who no matter how
impossible the military task looks,
will be optimistic about explaining to
you how their plan will overcome it
after all,
people don't get those jobs by
explaining how they can't overcome the
enemy's defenses.
We told you earlier that the French
sack,
their military leader that they've had
since the beginning of the wars you also
shot for and they sort of,
you know,
kick him upstairs and before they do,
they have another one of those yearly
meetings where all the allies,
the Russians and the British and the
French and all the other allies,
they get together and they had this
meeting and they try to coordinate next
years,
military plans so that when the British
and the French attack on the western
front,
the Russians at the same time attack on
the east and the Italians attack in the
south and everybody's pushing in
multiple directions all at once.
Forcing the Germans to,
you know,
maybe break somewhere.
I mean,
the central powers at this point are
like an egg and as soon as you can break
into any one of their sides,
east,
west,
north,
south,
I mean you feel like the war would be
over,
but they're all holding steady,
but most commanders are looking the
western front and say,
but nothing's as steady as that.
Must we attack it?
Will the French had always believed,
yes,
you must.
And of course they were a little biased
because the Germans are on their soil
and they would like to see them pushed
off when Joseph Jaffra is asked in late
1916 at the big meeting,
what are we going to do in 1917?
What's the plan?
Jennifer tells them his plan is a
repetition of the somme.
The battle that was just wrapping up the
battle that was so horrible for British
and even for French forces,
gonna where the Germans down in,
in,
uh,
several months long battle that forces
them to throw in the last of their
resources.
French politicians were horrified by
this.
The last thing they wanted is a battle
like that because as far as they were
concerned,
how did anybody know that it wouldn't be
the French nation,
the through in all their resources,
and man,
this is part of the reason is you offer
got kicked upstairs.
The French politicians had had enough
just like British politicians.
They were starting to do the unthinkable
in terms of 19th century attitudes.
They were starting to interfere with
military decisions because they were
losing faith that the people making the
military decisions had the right
priorities.
The politicians were
worried about the casualty totals.
One of the big criticisms,
especially from the soldiers in the
field,
is that the generals weren't the guy who
gets the job as the main allied military
commander in 1917 we mentioned earlier
is a guy named Robert and evil and evil
gets this job because he's the guy out
there optimistic about victory.
Remember,
generals do not get hired,
promising to not overcome the enemy's
defenses,
so there's an ingrown bias in the whole
process,
but Robert and Israel tells the French
leadership when he takes over that you
don't have to have another battle of the
somme.
You don't have to have a grinding
months,
long battle.
You can have a lightning bolt,
sort of hammer stroke that just ends the
war in 48 hours.
Now it sounds crazy,
doesn't it?
There were a bunch of French general,
some of whom Nouvelle leapfrogged over.
Uh,
they were guys who probably deserved the
job at least three,
maybe four more than Nevada,
but Nevada was this.
He's a charmer.
I mean,
he's,
he's one of these people that can win
anyone over.
He's not winning over these jealous
generals.
He leapfrogged.
But there's a lot of politicians that
are,
are sold with Nivo and some of them
aren't.
Even French novel has this great
advantage over the other French,
you know,
military leaders,
he speaks English,
he speaks it perfectly.
He speaks it without an accent.
His mother's English.
So he's a charmer to begin with kind of
a salesman.
But people like him,
he doesn't feel slimy or sleazy.
Um,
he sort of an optimist and he goes over
to Britain and he wins over even the
arch easterner Lloyd George
that was in there and explains to the
British exactly how this plan to rupture
the enemy lines will work and it
involves creating a reserve of 27,
28 divisions that are going to be like
the spider in the web and as soon as the
Germans are held in certain places and
weakened and then this 27 divisions will
go get them and it's going to take 48
hours.
And like any good salesman offering sort
of a money back guarantee,
there's a guarantee in this deal.
And the guarantee that naval tells
everybody is if it doesn't work in 48
hours,
we'll call it off after that.
Now that's a promise to get rid of the
part of these battles that's most
troubling to people who care about dead
people.
A lot of the dead people,
unless you have just tragic first day,
it's like the battle of the Somme and
the battle of the frontiers.
A lot of the deaths happen because these
battles go on for months.
If you could end them after 48 hours,
if you had a chance to see is it working
or not working,
call it off.
It's not working.
That takes a lot of the risk out of it
and you can see why politicians would
like that plan a lot more than just
saying let's have another four or five
months long battle.
The problem is,
in hindsight,
as everyone knows,
nouvelle was working on a on an idea
that might not have been tenable.
Novell made his name at the battle of
Verdun at the very last stages of it.
When the Germans were being pushed back
in the other direction.
There's a lot of historical debate over
whether or not anything novel did was
effective,
but even if it was effective,
it was effective at a very,
very low level to all of a sudden be the
military leader in charge of not just
all of Francis forces,
but kind of Britain's forces to who he
will clash and avail will clash with
Britain's commander Douglas Haig.
They do not like each other.
The Egos of generals,
our proverbial anyway,
and these two guys will fight in them,
will create problems between Britain and
France as allies.
Nonetheless,
novellas,
the most powerful military commander on
the western front.
He's never commanded forces like this.
His first real problem happens when the
Germans pull this,
you know,
operation Albert and disappear and it
reminds me a little of the British
getting away at Gullapalli and fooling
the Turks so that the Turks didn't know
that they'd left.
Now the Germans just kind of pull back
from this giant salient and wait for the
British to find out they're gone.
And I love the way it starts by the way
it starts with,
with the British looking out over their
trenches and seeing the German trenches
being shelled and then coming to the
realization that the German trenches
that they,
that they're facing off against her
being shelled by Germans and it's a
German artillery blowing up the trenches
and destroying everything of value in it
and then destroying the trenches so the
British can't move up into them and use
them.
And then of course the probing.
It must have been Erie.
There were like single Germans left
behind to shoot a rifle off every now
and then and just keep the allied armies
from pursuing too closely,
but it was clear that the Germans were
pulling back,
you know,
miles and miles,
churchill had said like 50 miles.
Every place I read said more like 20 at
the farthest,
but nonetheless to pull back that far
means your military maps are all
different.
The place that the hammer blow in
nibbles offensive was going to fall is
the place Luton Dorf just vacated.
Okay,
so as Ludina are probably intended,
you got to change your plans,
don't you mean conditions on the ground?
That changed and evolved said,
I don't have to change my plans.
This all helps my goal and this is where
everything starts to fall apart in this
plan,
and yet at the same time you can see how
these are such huge affairs involving so
many months of preparation,
so much momentum that even if you find
out near the beginning of the of the
battle that things have changed.
There's a momentum that you can't really
even stop.
In this case,
everything starts going wrong.
For interval before the whole battle
starts,
nonetheless,
before knievel's part of the battle
starts the campaign that sort of a
diversionary campaign designed to make
the Germans move away from where the is
going to attack starts.
That's the part of this campaign that
involves the British and the dominion
forces.
It happens,
um,
next to the French position at a place
called Rs.
And at this battle for at least a few
days,
everyone gets a chance to see exactly
how you would go about striking defenses
as invincible as the Germans.
And it looks a lot like world war two.
And you know,
several historians have pointed out that
by the end of the first world war,
the armies are prodo second world war
armies.
There are certain battles though during
the war where you can say,
Aha,
there is a big step forward towards that
Second World War 20th century style of
fighting.
That's what the battle of Eros is known
for.
Now,
in the grand scheme of things,
as we said,
this is the spring offensive.
This is what the allies do every year,
right?
The weather gets good and spring we
launched an offensive,
the British and the French launch one
together,
or they launched one in tandem.
The Italians do,
as we said,
I mean they launch them everywhere.
The Russians.
This is the big spring offensive.
The British part is these sort of
diversion as we said,
and yet they're going to pull this off
initially so well.
They're going to show everyone what 20th
century combined arms warfare looks
like,
including aircraft.
The amount of coordination though that
has to come off correctly to make this
work is stunning and it can't be
maintained,
but for the short period of time they're
able to make it work.
The British show you that modern
combined arms warfare can devastate
these static defenses.
Here's the way historian Peter Harte
describes the many things that were
starting to come together that could be
unleashed at Eros and how scientific and
modern 20th
century this profession of arms is
really becoming.
He writes,
quote,
many lessons had been learned from the
Psalm,
and artillery was at the heart of the
plans and the royal artillery had come a
long way since 1915.
The thousands upon thousands of new
recruits had learned their trade well.
That gun detachments,
the layers the NCO is the officers were
all now wedded into efficient batteries
that were capable of increasingly
sophisticated and complex bombardments.
The guns themselves were now plentiful
and there were vast numbers of medium
and heavy artillery pieces joining the
masses of ordinary 18 pounder and four
and a half inch,
how it's your field,
artillery advances in technology and
science also combined to give a greater
understanding of the mechanics of a
shell in flight and the measurable
adjustments caused by different media.
A logical conditions accuracy was
improving and the advent of the
[inaudible] fuse meant that shells would
burst instantaneously on the slightest
contact,
which made clearing barbed wire and
great deal.
Simpler smoke shells were also now
routinely incorporated into the barrages
to try to mask the attacking infantry
from German defenders.
Gas shells were a key part of the
barrages and they were less visually
dramatic than the clouds of gas released
from cylinders,
but they were far easier to deploy and
much more predictable in their effects.
Progress in the linked tasks.
A photographic reconnaissance and
artillery observation allowed targets to
be identified and then destroyed by
indirect fire.
New techniques,
a flash spotting and sound ranging also
assisted in locating the exact positions
of German batteries and the amount of
coordination that has to come off
correctly to make this stuff work is
astounding and it shouldn't be
surprising that it usually doesn't.
What makes her us different is that in
some cases it did at the battle of Rs.
Take for example,
the creeping barrage,
the creeping barrage is a fantastic
military innovation and they'd been
trying to make it work before this
battle in this battle.
They got it right in this battle.
They were able for a while to create a
protective explosive force field around
British troops.
The way it worked is you would get a ton
of guns anywhere from several hundred to
more than a thousand firing giant cannon
aids in front of your advancing forces,
creating a wall of explosions in front
of them and you would have it
coordinated.
Everybody would have their watch is
synchronized and the troops would be
told,
okay,
in the first 20 minutes you were to
move,
you know,
100 yards forward and at this time the
barrage will shift another hundred yards
in front of you.
So this was all worked out so that you
know the protective barraged supposed to
keep the troops safe as the,
as they advance toward the enemy.
And the very last step of course is the
barrage will land right on the enemy and
then it will lift at the last second and
the enemy will look up and the British
forces will be right there standing in
front of them.
Having marched the whole with a giant
explosive force field,
protecting them.
As you might imagine,
coordination is critical.
You screwed this up in one of two things
happens.
The better thing is that the barrage
gets way ahead of the troops and they're
exposed to all the machine gunfire and
all the stuff that barrage was supposed
to protect them from.
That's the good part.
That's the best outcome.
The worst outcome is that the barrage
short and that giant explosive wall
that's supposed to protect you from the
enemy instead decimates you.
When it works,
it's fantastic.
At the battle of our us,
it works.
Initially,
there'll be a bunch of innovations at
this battle.
Another one,
again that has been tried before but
never quite like this,
as whole batteries have machine guns
will be used in what's called indirect
fire,
meaning they point them up to the sky so
that the bullets ended up falling.
You know?
Right.
Straight down on targets.
You could shoot over hills that way.
Not even seeing what you're shooting at
is one.
A historian explained it.
It's like hosing down an important piece
of ground and they would have thousands
of machine gun bullets falling every
second on some of these important road
crossings and whatnot.
All through this battle.
One of the important elements at the
start of the battle is that so many of
the troops that are going to initially
rush the German side,
our underground at the start of the
battle,
there's a lot of chalky ground in this
part of France and like a lot of these
battles,
there will be a ton of digging.
In fact,
four months the Germans and the British
on both sides have had sort of a
tunneling war and occasionally,
you know,
British tunnels toward the German front
run into German tunnelers going the
other way and they had these terrible
gun fights in the dark under ground.
You know,
like troglodyte fighting.
Some sources say that.
The moment the actual ground battle at a
Ross started,
some of these tunnels had gone up all
the way to the German lines,
but just a couple of feet separated them
from the German trench lines and that at
the second the battle started.
They exploded.
Charges in those,
those little walls of dirt blew down.
And the Canadians,
you know,
storm through the breaches.
It doesn't matter what exactly happened.
The Canadian storm wme Ridge now and
took it on the first day,
a ridge that untold numbers of Frenchman
had died trying to take back in 1915.
It's a huge Canadian victory and the
Germans were in terrible trouble for a
short while at the battle of ours.
And by the way,
it's not just Canadians.
They get a lot of credit and deservedly
so,
but there were Scotsman,
for example,
up on the same hill.
I'm dealing with all kinds of problems.
Okay,
and yet for the first 24 hours,
it looked like Douglas Haig,
the British commander was going to have
on his hands the long awaited,
much fantasized about in his head
breakthrough
Ludin Dorf writes in his diaries that he
was a a dangerous moment and then and
then lamented the fact that here this
brand new defense in system he'd come up
with,
with all this work and all this money
spent was apparently useless against
these new British combined arms tactics.
That was until he figured out that his
commander on the scene,
a guy named Falcon House and a 70
something year old guy,
hadn't quite figured out what he was
supposed to do with these new tactics.
They were still way too new and he had
done a bunch of things that were part of
the old tactics.
He put all his guys for the most part
way up front where they could be taken
by the artillery more than two and a
half million British shells by the way,
fired a in a shorter time than the
battle of the somme,
and then he put his reserves that are
supposed to be there to plug any holes
15 miles back too far to do anything in
for a short period of time.
It looked like the British were going to
break through at this battle and then
just like all these other battles,
it slows down.
Once the troops advanced beyond where
they're gunfire can help them,
then the guns behind them have to move
to and that takes time and everybody
gets tired and they begin to wear out
and while they're resting and
rejuvenating themselves for the next
push,
the Germans are bringing up their
reserves and the battle of Arras with
this wonderful first day in this capture
of this important vimy ridge turns into
just another one of these battles.
And by the time it's over,
more than a month later,
you have like 150,000
British casualties and like 130,000
German ones.
And by the way,
I found it interesting that the newer
histories,
numbers of the casualties,
these battles is significantly higher
than the older ones.
I have some that say that 75,000
British died at this battle.
That's a big discrepancy in the numbers.
Nonetheless,
the traditional numbers thrown out today
are well over 100,000
for both sides.
Um,
the,
the joy over vinny was short lived.
And what had happened at this battle
would happen at a bunch of other first
world war battles.
It shows the difference between how well
the first stage,
usually the first 24,
maybe 36 hours of these minute Lee
exquisitely planned encounters go the
part that's all been rehearsed and
trained for for months and months and
months goes great and you're able to
make the coordination work,
but then the next jump in wherever you
are in these battles is the part that
becomes much more improvisational,
much more ad hoc.
You can't have a plan,
you know months in advance for what you
do on the second day of the battle
because you're not really sure where
you're going to be the second day.
You may have some,
but that doesn't mean that's what you're
going to do and and as many historians
point out,
when you look at the next jumps in any
of these offensive,
they are so much more haphazard and all
that coordination falls apart that you
don't see the wonderful results that
that months of preparation gave you for
24 or 36 hours.
And yet you can't break through these
kinds of deep defenses in that short of
a period of time.
You would have to have that combined
arms activity work as well as it did for
the first 24 hours at a Ross and be able
to carry it through for a week or two.
Nevertheless,
it was a near run thing.
It's gone down in history as a,
as a,
as a heroic encounter.
Mostly for the Canadians,
the largest endeavor they participated
in yet on the western front,
and I always have to remind myself,
you know,
you look at this in an almost a field
marshal type fashion.
When you study this for military
history,
you see it the way the generals often
did these advancements on these maps.
What worked and what didn't.
You know the coordination question that
the technical side of war.
You always have to remember though,
and I always try to remind myself to the
people on the ground.
This is not so technical.
Philip Gibbs was there.
He was in the tunnels with the troops as
they came back from these encounters up
on vimeo ridge and places like that.
Gibbs gives you a real feel for what it
was like.
He writes,
quote,
there were tunnels beneath Ross through
which are men advanced to the German
lines,
and I went along them when one line of
men was going into battle and another
was coming back wounded,
some of them blind bloody vomiting with
the fumes of gas in their lungs.
Their steel hats clinking as they groped
past one another.
Involves on each side of these passages.
Men played cards on barrels to the light
of candles,
stuck in bottles or slept until their
turn to fight with gas masks for their
pillows.
He says outside the citadel,
meaning of the city.
There were long queues of wounded men
taking their turn to the surgeons who
were working in a deep crypt with a high
vaulted roof.
One day there were 3000 of them.
Silent patient,
muddy bloodstained,
blind boys or men with smashed faces,
swapped in bloody rags,
groped forward to the dark passages
leading to the vault,
led by comrades on the grass outside lay
men with leg wounds and stomach wounds.
And the quote,
Norman Collins is an officer with the
Scottish fourth seaforth highlanders,
and they're there to.
And Collins just tells these stories
that reminds you of the very strange
moral positions,
these kinds of conflicts puts you in.
Collins talks about the fact that they
were actually shown how to kill one of
their own men on the battlefield because
of the pain and suffering that they were
enduring.
And this isn't specific to this battle,
this happened on the battlefields
throughout the first world war in
basically every army you know that got
caught in these conditions.
These are human problems,
the physics of humankind on these 20th
century battlefields.
The results are predictable,
horrifying,
and pitiable collins writes,
quote,
after such intense fighting,
you always had men lying out in no man's
land,
probably with their testicles blown off
and crying in agony and laying out there
all night long in the dark,
in the rain,
most would never have survived,
but you had a choice.
They could die in agony or you could
shoot them.
You were shown how to do the thing very
cleanly.
You would take your 45 revolver and talk
to the man and kneel behind him and
whilst you were talking,
pulled the trigger,
put a bullet through the back of his
head and immediately the whole front
skull came away and they were dead
instantly.
There was no pain about it,
but I can honestly say this,
that I never had the courage because
that's what it took.
I never had the courage myself to shoot
a wounded soldier.
I carried out the operation many times
afterwards on animals.
I could kill a pet dog far better than a
vet could,
but I was never able to shoot a wounded
soldier.
I probably should have.
My friend auto,
Murray Dixon was wounded in the stomach
and the irs attack in April.
He was in great agony from what I was
told.
The kindest thing would've been to shoot
him on the battlefield.
Instead of that,
they took him back to the hospital and
he died two days later.
It's a tremendous thing to shoot a
friend even though he's in agony and I
just didn't have the courage to do it.
Most of them died overnight,
but of course they didn't.
Thank you for it.
I'm sure the quote,
there are battles coming up with the
numbers of people who were either shot
by their own men or begged to be will
skyrocket.
Nonetheless,
this battle was tough enough.
The initial stages of elation at taking
things like Vimeo Ridge became
nightmarish.
As the month went on and the casualties
piled up before long,
the British were suffering for thousand
casualties a day at a Ross and it was
getting to the morale of the troops.
Gibbs tells a story about arriving on a
scene right after a bunch of men just
behind the front had been blown up in
their bath together and the bath is
strewn with body parts and blood and he
and a soldier he knows sits down to talk
about you know how things are going,
and the soldier is clearly at the end of
his rope as far as what he's willing to
put up with.
He writes,
quote,
a few minutes before our meeting,
a shell had crashed into a bath close to
their hut where men were watching
themselves.
The explosion filled the bath with blood
and bits of flesh.
The younger officers stared at me under
the tilt forward of his steel hat and
said,
hello gibbs.
I'd played chess with him at grooms cafe
in fleet street in days before the war.
I went back to his hut and had tea with
him close to that bath,
hoping we should not get caught up with
the cake and quote.
Now,
this battle,
as I said,
is known for how wonderfully competent
the integration of all the different
elements were to make this battle so
effective.
That's not how the guy on the ground
sees it.
Though Gibbs says that his friend he's
having tea with says quote.
I had heard before,
some harsh words about our general staff
work,
but never anything so passionate,
so violent,
is from that gunner officer.
His view of the business was summed up
in the word murder.
He raged against the impossible orders
sent down from headquarters against the
brutality with which men were left in
the line week after week and against the
monstrous abominable futility of all our
so called strategy.
His nerves were in rags,
as I could see,
by the way in which his hands shook.
When he lighted one cigarette after
another,
his spirit was in a flame of revolt
against the misery of his sleeplessness,
filth and imminent peril of death and
quote.
If British reporter Philip Gibbs thinks
that that's a high level of discontent
and perhaps in the British army,
it is.
You ought to see what's going on in the
French army at about the same time
in France,
a great drama is unfolding during this
time period because right before these
offensives are scheduled to start,
the French government falls and new
political leaders take over a new
president,
a new war minister.
All these civilian leaders have changed
and these civilian leaders have a very
different attitude towards this
offensive that's about to start than the
people they succeeded.
This causes huge problems.
The first thing is,
they're not big fans of novel,
but join the club.
There are lots of people who wonder why
this guy got the top job when there were
several,
you know,
superior figures,
really August people who could have
gotten it.
Potassium follow people like that were
sitting in the wings and they gave it to
a much more junior person,
but,
but for political reasons,
I mean he fit that last government in
ways that were good for that last
government,
but now that last government was gone
and the new one that comes into power
would've rather had any one of those
other people.
What's more,
they don't like his plan,
his idea for this great thunderbolts
assault with all this artillery that's
going to end the war in 48 hours.
They're not buying it.
A lot of people are,
by the way,
a lot of people are drinking the Robert
Nouvelle Koolaid and getting into this
optimistic mood about this thunderbolt
ending the war,
but the new government's pretty sure
that that's not what's going to happen
and they've got some people who ought to
know sending the message.
Just warning them.
There are other military commanders in
France who are saying,
call this thing off.
It's going to be a disaster.
Some of them are people who are actually
subordinate to Nevada and who have jobs
to do in this coming offensive that
scaring the government.
As you might imagine,
this is all part of this growing
interference with politicians in the
affairs of generals and this is one of
those times where there sort of a face
off I'm eating is called between the new
war minister and novel in late March and
the new war minister wants to convince
devel to call this whole offensive off
and they're almost impossible thing to
do.
As we said earlier,
by the time you reach stages where
you're just finishing the last touches
ready to go.
It's taken months and months and the
training and the rehearsals and the
money spent and all this stuff,
and now the government,
the civilian leaders who don't know
anything about war,
any general would think want to call it
off.
My reputation relies on this.
I mean there's a lot of personal motives
and the war minister has some good
arguments.
He tries to tell him,
look,
everything's changed since you first
formulated this plan.
When did just be prudent to reevaluate?
I mean,
the Germans pulled back from their old
positions to these new positions on the
siegfried line and other places,
right?
There's one big change,
but not just that the war minister tries
to make the case that all of these big
events are happening right now.
These trends coming together,
everything we've talked about on this
program up to date are coming to the
fore at the same time in late March when
the war minister is talking to novel
about this,
the United States is just about to get
in the war and everyone knows it.
The Russian revolution has just
happened.
The submarines are about to enter into
the month where they sink.
Eight hundred and 40,000
tons of allied shipping.
There's a lot going on and Francis warm
minister tries to tell Nevada lit,
listen,
no one's going to hold you.
I mean,
everything's changed.
Maybe we should reevaluate.
Novel says,
no.
The government gets even more desperate
as the offensive nears and presses him
and he pulls the takeaway card.
He says to the government,
either you back me on this or I
resigned,
and everything I've read says that this
is a crisis for the French government at
this point for all sorts of internal
reasons.
It was likely to bring the government
down if they fired novell right before
his offensive was supposed to take hold
and everyone had bought into the
optimism and drank the Koolaid.
They had almost no choice in this
confrontation between politicians and
generals and the government backed down,
but it was even worse than the
government knew because the Germans knew
all about novels,
plans in detail to major incidents.
Uh,
one involving captured documents that
never should have been anywhere near the
front lines that the Germans got their
hands on in a,
in a raid,
and then an officer that they captured.
And we're able to find out more.
The Germans knew all about the French
plans and when they were going to take
place and what was going to happen.
And they had known in general for
months,
air reconnaissance had told them.
I mean,
these giant affairs are like giant
supply dumps that go on for miles and
miles and miles.
It's very difficult to keep the enemy
from finding out about it,
and in January,
the Germans had about nine divisions,
opposite novell's armies by the time
novels about to launch this attack.
The Germans have 48 and they're waiting
and it's a disaster.
Historian holds your.
Her vague writes quote,
after several delays due to foul weather
novel 16th,
April unleashed is our telleria for nine
days,
and then mounted is infantry charge in
driving rain reports from agents and
French pow,
who's had tipped the Germans off to the
coming offensive.
Given the news of the offensive and the
difficulty of the terrain,
the Germans were able to halt the main
attack before it got beyond their first
line.
Whereas novell had forecast a
penetration of seven or eight miles on
the opening day.
The French rarely advanced,
more than one or two miles.
Losses were horrendous.
Whereas novell had coldly predicted
10,000
casualties.
For the first day.
The number was 10 times greater after
the war.
The historical surface of the French
general staff placed casualties for the
first four days of the offensive at
30,000
killed,
100,000
wounded and 4,000
missing end quote.
The story of what happened at this
battle of novels is a wonderful
no demonstration of how many things can
go wrong when you're trying to
synchronize everything.
So carefully start with the weather.
Just like at a Ross,
a week before the weather was bad.
Uh,
you know,
who has snow during a spring offensive,
but that's what the French face,
sleet,
snow,
rain,
creating mud that slowed the progress of
the infantry,
which had been calculated precisely to
keep up with the explosive force field
of the creeping barrage,
which this guy in the veil had pioneered
back in for done but never on this kind
of a scale.
And in this case,
the barrage,
the force field got way ahead of the
troops exposing the troops to just
unbelievable amounts of machine gunfire.
There's one part of this front where the
French have to travel for ever.
I mean,
miles to take this,
you know,
height in the distance and and in,
in this ridge,
they've,
the Germans have cut all these little
holes into the side of it,
you know,
to,
to add to the ravines and the gorgeous
and everything that are already in it,
and they've stuffed machine guns into
every hole that you can fit into this
hillside.
They've got about 4,000
of them trained on this French infantry
trying to cross this space and at Eros
and here,
you know when you read the history
books,
they sound like relatively productive
first world war battles because the
soldiers actually take quite a bit more
ground than they did in the earlier
battles.
But that's sort of deceiving because
this is all part of the new German
strategy.
This defense in depth with the Germans
aren't supposed to fight to the depth
all up on the front lines now and not
give an inch of ground.
They're supposed to fight to a
reasonable degree and then retire to the
next line of defense.
So they're letting the enemy have more
ground.
They're just killing more of them while
they retreat.
The French actually stumble in to these,
uh,
first line areas and think that they're
winning because they're just not finding
that many Germans.
And then the Germans opened up on them
from the second line positions,
as you might imagine,
a
government that had been assured that
they'll call this thing off in 48 hours.
You know,
it was going to try to cash in on that
guarantee.
They actually gave novel and extra day
on his 48 our promise.
Here's how writer Gj Meyer describes the
situation where the politicians come to
the general and tell him to call the
whole thing off.
Now you guaranteed it wasn't going to be
another song.
You guaranteed we're going to win the
war with this thunderbolt.
And here's what my writes quote.
On April 19th,
three days after the attack starts,
the war minister intervened,
trying to get Lavelle to stop the
general who in demanding approval of his
grand plan had promised to call it off.
If a breakthrough were not achieved
within 48 hours,
refused the very next day,
he found that his chagrin however,
that he had no choice but to pause the
divisions at the front.
We're breaking down both their morale
and their supplies of ammunition
dangerously low laid on the day after
that,
April 21st a new phenomenon appeared and
quote
John Keegan among other historians has
gone to great length to point out how
there's an accordion like backup that
begins once the timetable is Intel to
strictly when the,
when the front elements of these French
forces get bogged down,
everything behind it gets traffic
jammed.
We've quoted Louis Bar toss a French.
I'm corporal in the story several times
and Bartos is at this battle,
but he never sees anything.
He gets stuck in one of these traffic
jams and as far as he knows something's
going on,
a mile or two in front of him,
but he doesn't ever get there to find
out what it is,
the soldiers who find out what it is
though,
begin to react,
as one might imagine from the horror,
and in this case,
the tip of the spear in one of these
areas are French colonial troops.
The story of what happened was relayed
to British journalists.
Philip Gibbs who writes,
quote,
talking about the French infantry here,
Gibb's talks about how the French were
lured into the lightly defended first
zone only to be attacked by the Germans.
In the second zone of defense,
he writes,
quote,
they were to be allowed an easy walk
through to their death trap.
That is what happened.
The French infantry advancing with
masses of black troops in the colonial
corps in the frontline of assault,
all exultant in inspired by a belief in
victory,
swept through the forward zone of the
German defenses,
astonished and then disconcerted by the
scarcity of Germans until an
annihilating barrage fire dropped upon
them and smash their human waves from
French officers and nurses.
I heard appalling tails of this tragedy.
The death wail of the black troops froze
the blood of the freshmen with horror.
Their own losses were immense in a
bloody shambles and quote,
the French colonial soldiers which had
been thrown into this disaster,
ran screaming back towards their own
lines,
yelling piece down with the war,
death to those who are responsible and
all of a sudden the French army began to
collapse.
Traditionally,
the novel offensive is seen as the straw
that breaks the camel's back for the
French military.
And it's ironic that it would be that
way because if it's just judged in
relation to all the other French
battles,
the novella,
fancy is not terrible.
The casualty bill is horrifying,
but pretty normal for these big battles.
And remember,
there's people being killed every day on
so called quiet fronts,
I mean the British casualties every week
to what they call wastage,
just living on the western front with
snipers and bombs and trench raids and
all that is 5,000
people a week.
So I mean even between the big battles,
it's horrible.
But in the big battles,
the numbers are astronomical by that
standard.
The novella fence is not that bad and
they did gain,
you know,
a pretty decent amount of ground level
three miles in some places.
But this was sold in a completely
different way.
The salesmen,
Robert Nevada,
sold this as the thunderbolt that wins
the war.
Everybody's got to have this last push
of optimism and and strength and
resources and gumption to end the war.
And then we can all go home and the
sufferings over and a lot of people
drank the Koolaid and the crash after
they drank the Koolaid was worse than if
they'd never had the Koolaid at all.
All that optimism boomeranged back on
Nevada who started to try to recast the
marketing just 24 hours into the
conflict.
He was no longer talking about war
winning thunderbolts.
He was talking about,
hey,
it's going very well,
modest gains in the sector in this
sector,
and no one was buying the recrafting of
the marketing strategy.
The French government now has a
wonderful little drama on its hands
where it tries to get rid of Nevada and
he won't go quietly.
They put pitocin who's very competent.
We talked about him earlier in novels,
old job,
and uh,
they have a face off and you see this
wonderful again,
changing the guard between politicians,
kind of trying to assert their authority
over the generals and this push and tug
on who's going to be the ultimate
authority.
The one thing that the politicians have
in their favor is that they're concerned
about casualties and the generals appear
to not be concerned about casualties and
the people who are rising up in French
units up and down the western front are
very concerned about casualties.
The novella offensive traditionally is
what kicks off what are called the
[inaudible] 19,
17 mutinies or the mutinies of 1917.
That's a weird term and it makes it
sound like one unit,
rebels,
and then the rebellion know transfers
like wildfire up and down the front end
and all these units are acting
simultaneously.
If that had happened,
the war would've been over for France.
I mean,
what do you do to stop a rebellion or
when it's the army that's rebelling.
If that had happened,
it would've been all over and the French
government knew it and acted
accordingly.
Instead,
you have to imagine a burning roof with
the is everywhere,
you know,
going off into the wind and landing all
over the dry grass on the lawn and you
know,
the French government is running around
stamping out fires as they catch hold as
many as six of these units a day.
We're involved in,
as I said,
what the French called acts of
collective and discipline,
which meant a whole wide range of
things.
Sometimes it meant getting drunk as an
entire unit and that was the end of
that.
We're not going anywhere.
Other Times they just refuse to go up to
the front.
One forest decided to march on Paris and
was talked out of that at the last
minute,
and a lot of this was tied to the
Russian revolution going on
simultaneously.
The French in the field saw that all of
a sudden Russian soldiers,
maybe we're going to get out of fighting
this work as they'd somehow with the
people acted together to go after the
people that were as Louis Bar Toast
explained it,
enslaving them,
Louis Bartos,
who a socialist and who would have
viewed these happenings in Petrograd in
Russia with great enthusiasm,
wrote this right around the times.
The outbreaks of collective in
discipline are happening in his army.
Quote,
at this time,
the Russian revolution broke out.
Those Slavic soldiers only yesterday and
slaved and bent double under the weight
of iron discipline unknowingly marched
off to mass,
occurs like resigned.
Slaves had thrown off their yolks,
proclaim their liberty and imposed piece
on their masters.
Their hangman.
The whole world was stupefied petrified
by this revolution,
this collapse of the immense empire of
the czars.
These events had repercussions on the
western front and throughout the French
ranks.
A wind of revolt blew across almost all
the regiments and quote,
but as I said,
it was an uneven sort of an affair.
Sometimes it involved whole units,
large numbers of troops.
Other Times it was a decision made by
single individuals alone that they just
weren't going to have their lives thrown
into a meat grinder anymore.
Historian Eric Dorm Bros tries to give
you a sense of the feeling when he
writes,
quote
already on day two of the novel
offensive.
17 soldiers have one regiment left their
post and went to the rear,
and then in May 30,000
infantry men abandoned the line.
A junior officer recorded the scene at
one train station receiving men who'd
been rotated out of the line.
Now Bros is quoting and eye witness and
the eyewitness to the troops.
Getting away from the front during this
rebellious time says,
quote,
as soon as the train enters with what
you would say a horde of savages,
all the doors open on both sides and men
flood out on the platforms,
shouts,
insults and threats flying all
direction,
death to the sugars at home,
murderers,
pigs,
that
they are long lived,
the revolution down with the war.
It's peace we want,
et cetera.
Now,
Bros picks up the narrative,
quote the troubles spread the 68 of 112
divisions in the French army in June.
Each reporting one to five mutinous
incidents,
but no killing of officers.
The rank and file demanded an end to
further attacks,
better pay and living conditions and
more furloughs and quote John Keegan and
a couple of other historians have an
interesting way of describing this.
This act of rebellion that was breaking
out almost spontaneously,
although influenced by other breakouts
all across and up and down the western
front.
He says it's like a labor strike.
Like the soldiers had just decided that
they weren't going to do certain things
anymore.
He said it wasn't defeatism.
It was defensive ism,
meaning that these soldiers were not
gonna,
let the Germans come and invade France.
They weren't going to abandon the line
and they wouldn't stop fighting,
but they weren't going to be involved in
any more of these offensives were 130,
a hundred 40,
a hundred 50,000
of them were going to become casualties
in a hopeless cause.
Let's also remember that it didn't get
to this point until the French army had
suffered in three and a half years about
as many killed as the United States has
suffered in all its wars put together.
How would the United States today,
a nation of 300 million,
France,
had about 39 or 40 deal with one point
five or one point 7 million dead in four
years.
You adjusted for population size,
that'd be more like seven,
seven and a half million,
somewhere around there.
Can you imagine?
Would you expect us to be hangover free
for the rest of the century in terms of
military affairs?
The French had some lingering damage
because of this first world war.
Anyone else would.
It's amazing.
They got back on their feet at all.
It's also sort of a wonder for the
allied cause that the Germans are
unaware of this somehow.
It's.
It's funny,
you have the novel offensive that
everybody in Germany is talking about on
the streets.
It's so well known and yet the French
Army starts falling apart and rebelling
and the Germans don't know.
If you're the French high command and
you got your army,
you know,
starting to catch fire like a bunch of
rooftop ambers that are falling on dry
grass.
What do you do to stop that?
You got to be very careful,
don't you?
If you give up too much,
it becomes like what the Russians are
dealing with where you can't even have
the troops in order to run,
where they start electing their own
little governing groups and they do what
they want.
Can't have that,
but if you crack down and get all tough
on them,
you might spread the revolution.
It's a deft and terrible tight rope for
the French government to walk.
This new military leader that takes over
for novell Patala is considered to be
sort of a soldier's general,
so that helps and he'll famously go
around to all these units speaking to
them and actually promising and
delivering some of
the reforms they want.
For example,
reforms on home leave,
food,
drink.
I mean there's a bunch of things that he
can manage to perk up and,
and take care of that help the troops,
you know,
griping on the front.
At the same time,
he has to show who's still in charge.
This is still a military.
Laws are broken.
Discipline must be maintained.
The French start a crackdown in July.
In 1917,
they will court marshal almost 24,000
soldiers for collective indiscipline
delish issue about 500 death sentences.
They will actually carry out less than
100 of them,
but there's one thing pitocin can
change.
He cannot make this army capable or
willing or trustworthy to go on another
major offensive.
This is an army that has to regroup,
be rebuilt.
Refortified in Bhutan is going to do a
historically famous job of this,
but it's going to take time and in the
meantime,
the number one thing that he gives to
his troops that they were asking for
because he's got no choice,
is that they're not going to be thrown
into murderous,
hopeless,
offensives anytime soon.
This leaves the western front in any
sort of offensive activity on it for the
rest of 1917 to the British alone,
the British commander Douglas Haig is
fine with that because he has a plan and
he's wanting to carry it out for some
time and now that the French are not in
his way,
he casts his covetous I on Oprah and the
Belgian ports,
yet again,
Douglas Haig,
the British military leader launched the
British to launch an attack on the
German defenses in Belgium at Ipa where
there's already been two battles of Epri
in this war already.
Now,
Hague's got a great army to do this with
the British army in late 1917.
Mid 1917.
Is is maybe the best army in the war at
this time.
It's taken years for the British.
You know,
traditionally a sea power to build up a
land power,
but by July,
August,
19,
17,
they've done a great job of doing just
that and it's millions strong in the
British,
had a boutique army when this war
started.
Very,
very fine and professional and
volunteers,
but,
but a boutique army.
What they have in 1917 are a bunch of
mostly conscripts,
some volunteers,
but mostly conscripts.
They don't sing on their way to and from
battle anymore.
Like in 1914 after the psalm that all
stopped.
These are a bunch of grim professionals
who operate with deadly efficiency and
have a sort of a,
a,
a morale that's hard to describe it and
they suffered a terrible ordeal the year
before at the battle of the somme.
Terrible.
Lost a lot of fantastic people,
but came back with even more artillery
pieces here in 1917.
It's a great tool in the hands of Haig
and hade wants to use it in Belgium
against the Germans.
But there are people that think that
that's a stupid idea.
And after several years of
war,
when you've watched,
you know,
the same thing happen over and over
again in all these battles,
there are people that are going to push
back and you're starting to see some of
these political leaders start to
question what the military is doing
openly to their face.
And you know,
when we mentioned this earlier,
I didn't want to insinuate that this
never happens.
I mean Abraham Lincoln for example,
famously would argue with the civil war
generals and they would resent it.
But in some countries like Germany,
politicians in Germany do not interfere
in military strategy and they'd only
just started doing that in France with
the collapse of the Novella offensive,
right?
It was the novella offensive that sort
of brought them into saying,
are you sure we want to do something
like this again in Britain?
You know,
I,
I would think as a modern person reading
the story,
and I think many of you probably thought
the same thing.
You're wondering why it took this long.
How many times can you lose hundreds of
thousands of people in what appeared to
the nonmilitary.
I to be very similar kinds of attacks.
It'd be a little strange if there
weren't more people questioning this in
Britain.
There are led by the Prime Minister
Lloyd George.
Now George,
to be fair is viewed by history very
similarly to the way woodrow Wilson is.
It's almost as though there's a good
lawyer George,
and there's an evil Lloyd George and you
know different histories will portray
him differently,
but taken at face value.
Lloyd George presents himself as the
person who defends the soldiers from the
generals.
He says during this whole lead in to
whether or not hey gets to have his
Belgian offensive quote.
The cabinet must regard themselves as
trustees for the fine fellows that
constitute our army.
They're willing to face any dangers and
they do so without complaint,
but they trusted the leaders of the
nation to see that their lives are not
needlessly thrown away and that they're
not sacrificed on mere gambles which are
resorted to merely because those who are
directing the war can think of nothing
better to do with the men under their
command.
It is therefore imperative that before
we embark upon a gigantic attack,
which must necessarily entail the loss
of scores of thousands of valuable lives
and produce that sense of discouragement
which might very well rush nations into
premature piece,
that we should feel a fair confidence
that such an attack as a reasonable
chance of succeeding Amir gamble would
be both
folly and a crime.
And to quote,
I must confess that to the modern
observer having just witnessed the
several years previous of this war,
you think to yourself when you hear
something like that,
it's about damn time,
but many modern historians wonder.
They wonder if Haig didn't have a pretty
good feel for this thing and that these
politicians,
we're barking up the wrong tree.
Maybe for their own political purposes.
Haig sure makes it look like Lloyd
George doesn't know what he's talking
about when he opens an operation
on June seventh,
19,
17.
To take this high ground that he needs
to take before he can have his IEP or
battle.
It's called Misener Ridge and the
British had since 1915.
Been tunneling under this eight miles of
ridge lines and planting explosives
underneath the incredibly deep and
complicated German defenses up there.
They were impenetrable,
so the British went underneath them and
the Germans knew they were doing some of
this because they found one of them,
but on June seventh,
19,
17 when he decides he's going to take
this high ground,
he starts off his attack by blowing up
that eight miles of ridge lines with
these munitions.
There's more than a million pounds of
explosives underneath those hills and
when they blow up all within 28 seconds
of each other,
supposedly you could hear it in London.
I've heard some people say it was heard
in Ireland.
It's thought to be the biggest manmade
explosion before nuclear weapons or
atomic weapons,
and it vaporizes 10,000
Germans.
Instantly.
The second those minds are blown up.
Thousands of British artillery pieces on
the horizon open fire on this same line
of ridges and the British,
80,000
of them who come out of their trenches
and and march toward that high ground
have a pretty darn easy time taking it
by first world war standards.
I've got to always throw that in because
to the naked eye it's still looks like a
lot of people died,
but by first world war standards,
that's a pretty darn good attack and
once again it seems to show that the
British have found the secret sauce,
the magic formula of how the tanks and
the artillery,
the aircraft,
and it all works together perfectly and
boom.
Messina Ridge taken for not that much
loss of life.
Seems like,
Hey,
he knows what he's doing,
but before he gets approval for this
battle,
it Breena.
He's pulling up the guns.
He's getting ready.
Lloyd George and company take him into a
back room and make him kind of do a
powerpoint presentation for Britain.
Civilian leaders in Hague's sort of
grits his teeth and does it and explains
why it'll be a good thing and you know
why,
why we should be doing this and why it
should be a walk over.
Did you see that wonderful battle we
just fought and took Messina Ridge.
Haig will end up getting other generals
and admirals to sort of side with him
against the political leadership.
There were always politicians who sided
with the military and thought they're
the professionals.
You leave things to them.
For guys like Churchill or Lloyd George,
who were the ones questioning military
leadership.
They were in a very tough position.
Can you imagine what risk they would
have run if they had overruled all their
military professionals and then 200,000
guys get killed in a battle,
which by the way is almost the default
result of a lot of these battles.
So you could pretty much be assured that
that would happen if it happened to the
generals.
Oh,
well it just happened again to the
generals.
But if Lloyd George overruled all their
generals and it happened because of him,
you be sure he
would have been roasted.
Um,
so predictably I'm Douglas Haig gets his
offensive.
He starts by starting a military
bombardment of the area right around
July 15th,
July 20th,
before the ground attack starts.
The British will shoot almost 4 million
shells to just show you how the
progression is going.
A year ago at the somme,
we were all saucer.
I'd and so was the rest of the world at
the time when the British shot off a
million shells before they started that
battle for this,
when they're shooting off almost 4
million.
You can see why Germany is concerned
with finding a way to turn their entire
country into a munitions factory.
As we said,
was the goal on July 30,
first 1917.
The IPA offensive starts very soon
afterwards,
so does the rain.
It will be the rain that will give this
battle.
It's unique standout character
and there are so many battles in the
first world war that sound the same,
that only a few stand out and it's
always for some particular reason.
It become associated with something
special.
You know,
in a horrific way the most casualties
are the most shells or the most this or
that.
I mean everyone knows Verdun is the
great artillery meat grinder.
Offensive.
The Somme is that horrible,
tragic situation with maybe tragic and
competence that Bruce will off offensive
in the east is known for its scope.
Passion Dale,
which will be the British name for
third.
Ipa,
is known for its mud
and mud.
Doesn't sound like too terrible a thing,
but when you think about living outdoors
and fighting mud makes a terrible
situation worse,
and I don't want to suggest that just
because this is probably the worst mud
anyone has ever fought in in the first
world war.
That mud has not been a problem for
soldiers on other fronts and another
battles.
It's been sort of the bane of the
existence for people especially in
trenches,
but nowhere is the mod like it is in
flanders.
The soldiers fighting in it described it
as having a consistency of porridge or
cheesecake.
There is no bottom to it and you sink in
it slowly as you would in quicksand.
There are a lot of people who died in
the first two battles of by drowning.
In addition,
there is a complex,
very fragile system of dikes and other
water and flood control measures that
have been implemented in that area over
the centuries to keep the water from
taking it over.
The artillery has done great damage to
that before third iep right now with
this wonderful barrage of 4 million
shells that the British have have
launched into this area.
They've destroyed whatever was left at
that system,
but it's when the rain starts that it
gets horrifying because you take an
already horrifying first world war
western front battlefield of the sort
we've described with the giant trenches
everywhere.
The vegetation
all gone except for the little twigs and
sticks that used to be giant trees.
This horrific hell more door like you
know,
landscape and you flood it.
Now we've had battles like the psalm
where there will be rain and you will
have moments of flooding,
but it isn't like this.
This battlefield will start to flood and
it will stay that way.
There will only be three dry days in the
month of August.
In fact,
they get double the normal rainfall and
this turns the area into a swamp,
a swamp of quicksand,
and very quickly with all of the,
you know,
casualties that start cropping up.
You get the same kind of situation we
talked about at the somme where the
shell holes which are everywhere filled
with water become like toxic dumps with
human body's decaying in them and the
remnants of poison gas and trash and the
results of them using these things as
latrines.
I mean it is the most sickening stuff
you can think of.
As a matter of fact,
one of the problems confronting the
British at this battle is they don't
have water for the troops.
They have water everywhere.
They have water coming out their ears,
but none to drink and these shallow
holes and the mud will form as nasty and
enemy to the soldiers fighting in this
as their know opposition and I don't
want to suggest it wasn't bad for the
Germans either.
That may be the overlooked side of
Passchendaele.
It's so horrible and this is seared into
British consciousness.
Then it's so horrible for British
troops,
which let's remember,
and not just English folks,
they're Welsh Scotch,
Irish,
Newfoundland,
Indian,
Australian,
New Zealand,
Canadian,
and I'm leaving some out there.
All their suffering,
but the Germans are suffering too.
The rain is so bad that within just a
few days,
Haig has to call a halt to operations.
The guns are sinking.
You know the horses are sinking up to
their chest.
The people are sinking.
What makes this battle particularly
horrifying is that in no other battle in
the first world war,
do you routinely see the soldiers put in
that unbelievable situation that we
quoted,
norman cousins,
that Scottish soldier,
you know as saying he was given the
tools to kill his fellow man if they
were badly wounded on the battlefield.
What if they're slowly sinking in mud?
Because that's what was happening.
When we talk about battles that scar
nations,
what do we mean by that?
Well,
in the first world war,
hundreds of thousands,
sometimes millions of men would go
through these terrible places.
Passion,
Dale's one,
you know,
Verdun was another.
The Psalm was another.
The Bruce and love offensive.
I mean these people who go through these
horrible experiences,
number in the hundreds of thousands or
millions.
Those survivors then go home,
permanently changed.
How many human beings have to go home
permanently changed for that to ripple
across their entire societies?
Passchendaele did just that,
and part of the reason why was because
what these people saw just destroyed
them.
I mean the most widely in a lampooned
poetic line is wildly lampoon because it
became so associated with this battle
and siegfried sassoon road,
I died in hell.
They called it passion Dale.
You can see pictures by the way of this
battle on the battlefield to try to keep
soldiers from getting stuck in the mud.
They laid down duck boards and so you
have and you have to imagine,
go look at pictures.
It is amazing.
You have a battlefield that looks like
the moon.
If the moon had been turned to mud and
then on the mud to try to keep people
from sinking into it as though it's
quick sand.
They put these little teeny planks in
and and they and they make them look
like paths you know for,
for where people need to go.
But what this does is it means that the
soldiers have to actually walk on those
and machine gunners can just target
them,
and these duck boards are blown up every
night by the artillery.
And every night the royal engineers come
and rebuild them for the next day under
fire.
Peter Hart,
in his wonderful book on the First World
War,
the Great War,
quotes private Norman Cliff,
a British soldier in the first grand
dear guards describing you know what was
happening,
and it happened to thousands of
soldiers,
quote the approach to the Ridge was a
desolate swamp over which brew did an
eval menacing atmosphere that seemed to
defy encroachment far more treacherous
than the visible surface defenses with
which we were familiar,
such as barbed wire,
deep devouring mud spread,
deadly traps in all directions.
We splashed and slithered and dragged
our feet from the pull of an invisible
enemy,
determined to suck us into its depths.
Every few steps someone would slide and
stumble and weighed down by rifle and
equipment rapidly sink into the
squelching mess.
Those nearest grabbed his arms,
struggled against being themselves
engulfed and if humanly possible dragged
him out.
When helpers floundered in as well and
doubled the task,
it became hopeless.
All the straining efforts failed and the
swamps swallowed.
It's screaming victims,
and we had to be ordered to Plod on
dejectedly and fight.
This relentless enemy has stubbornly.
As we did those we could see it happened
that one of those leading us was
Lieutenant Chamberlain and so
distracted.
He become at the spectacle of men
drowning in mud and the desperate
attempts to rescue them,
that suddenly he began hysterically
belaboring the shoulders of a singing
man with his swagger stick.
We were horror struck to see this most
compassionate officer,
so unstrung as to resort to brutality
and are loud.
Protests forced him to desist.
The man was rescued,
but some could not be,
and they sank.
Shrieking with fear and agony to be
ordered.
To Go ahead and leave a comrade to such
a fate was the hardest experience.
One could be asked to endure,
but the objective had to be reached and
we plunged on bitter anger against the
evil forces prevailing piled onto our
exasperations.
This was as near to hell as I ever want
to be and to quote,
and Brian Cooper's
the ironclads of Cumbrae.
He quotes a soldier at IPR saying,
quote,
one of our men was unfortunate enough to
step out of line and fell into one of
these mud holes.
We managed to loop a rope securely under
his armpits,
but it was useless.
The poor fellow now knew he was beyond
all aid and begged me to shoot him
rather than leave him to die.
A miserable death by suffocation.
I am not afraid to say therefore that I
shot this man at his own urgent request.
End Quote.
In the accounts,
it's clear that this particular mode of
dying affected the soldiers you know
worse than most of the other ones.
This is the true extra horror of
Passchendaele of 30 [inaudible]
writer Adam Hochschild in his book to
end all wars,
quotes of British major at Third Ybarra
who says,
quote,
a party of a company,
men passing up to the front line found a
man bogged to above the knees,
bogged with mud.
He means he says,
quote,
the united efforts of four of them with
rifles beneath his armpits,
made not the slightest impression,
and to dig even if shovels had been
available would be impossible for there
was no foothold.
Duty compelled them to move on up to the
line and when two days later they passed
down that way the wretched fellow was
still there,
but only his head was now visible and he
was raving mad and to quote,
and just like most of the other bad
world war one battles,
you know the people stuck out in no
man's land that you couldn't go get
drove the men in the trenches.
They're comrades.
Just almost insane with powerlessness.
Historian John Keegan quotes British
soldier Edwin Vaughn,
who was at the third IPA and who
describes how the rain takes a known
horrific situation.
The people stuck in no man's land and
the suffering that they went through and
the suffering that they then transmitted
to their powerless comrades in the
trenches and made it worse by just
adding water.
Soldier von talks about being in a shell
hole and then says,
quote
from other shell holes from the darkness
on all sides came,
the groans and whales of wounded men
faint long sobbing,
moans of agony and despairing shrieks.
It was too horribly obvious that dozens
of men with serious wounds must've
crawled for safety into new shell holes
and now the water was rising about them
and powerless to move.
They were slowly drowning.
Horrible visions came to me with those
cries of men lying,
maimed out there,
trusting that their pals would find them
and now dying terribly alone amongst the
dead and the inky darkness and we could
do nothing to help them.
Dunham was crying quietly beside me and
all the men were affected by the
prettiest cries.
And the quote,
Lieutenant Edwin Vaughn and men are
relieved a couple hours later.
And as they're walking back down the
line,
he noticed his quote,
the cries of the wounded had been much
diminished now,
and as we staggered down the road,
the reason was only two apparent for the
water was right over the tops of the
shell holes and quote.
Now,
if you want it to look at this battle
which went on for months in military
terms and you wanted to look at it
positively as some modern historians do,
you could say that it killed between 220
and 350,000
more Germans.
Nothing wrong with that.
In a war of attrition right course,
if you're the British political command,
you will.
You'll note that it killed about the
same number of British soldiers.
It gained a few miles in some places.
The Canadians heroically captured the
town of Passchendaele against all odds
and through much suffering and
persevering.
But again,
it's not quite apparent how this really
pushed the end of the war any closer.
It definitely pushed a lot of soldiers
though,
closer to a transformation that they
would eventually,
if they lived to make it home transfer
to their entire society.
British soldier,
Ronald Skirt was for ever transformed by
his experiences in flanders in 1917,
as were so many others.
It crushed the underpinnings of so much
of his worldview.
He writes about the battle quote.
I said,
the men's morale was breaking.
I suppose I should have included myself.
I had long since lost any desire to
continue as a fighting soldier.
Idealists and cowards aren't of much use
on a battlefield,
and I was a bit of both.
At 19,
I found my standards of conduct
obsolete.
My ideal shattered.
I had lost all faith in institutional
religion.
My church had authorized me to break the
sixth commandment in the name of
patriotism and quote
he continues quote.
Eventually I worked at all out.
At least for myself.
God was all right.
It was we who were wrong.
Why the hell should he care what
happened to us a lot?
We had brought this war evil into
existence,
not God.
The reason evil and ugliness were
triumphing over goodness and beauty.
Why?
Pity and compassion.
We're considered weaknesses and
ruthlessness and cruelty regarded as
noble.
The reason for all this was the
wickedness in ourselves and not the
indifference of God.
That's why the more murders you
committed,
the bigger the hero you became.
That's what made your superior officers
slap you on the back and say,
splendid old chap,
jolly good shooting when your shells had
destroyed in minutes,
the beauty which craftsman had toiled
lifetimes to create disillusion is very,
very bitter.
When you're young,
thoughtful,
imaginative,
and sensitive and quote
in the postscript to his memoirs,
writing in the third person skirts,
quote before 19,
17 ended this unbelieved.
You're insensitive.
Youth had escaped death by inches a
dozen times,
had seen his comrades die in dreadful
agony.
Had seen and heard man,
who should have been dead.
Men broken,
torn limbless,
disemboweled screaming for anyone with a
loaded rifle to end.
They're unbearable.
Sufferings and watched his friends and
others slowly choke and froth is poison.
Gas suffocated them could not believe it
possible until his own eyes.
Told him it was that half a man could
live for what seemed to him hours and by
the time he was rendered unconscious
himself had come to realize that every
friend he'd made,
every man he'd worked with had become
cannon fodder for years afterwards.
Memories of these horrors haunted his
dreams and disturbed his sleep,
yet awake.
He could never bring himself to talk to
them and when he thought of those
wounded men and the comrades he'd been
with when they were killed,
he always came to the same conclusion.
It must never happen again.
Never and to quote,
there were hundreds of thousands of
survivors like this young man,
and they went home and greatly
influenced their home societies.
I mean,
there are literary historians that will
point to the influence these people had
in the writings of the 19 twenties and
19 thirties everywhere.
War Artists,
Paul Nash,
was another one permanently affected by
Passchendaele.
He'd been to other areas and thought the
war quite nice,
and then went to passchendaele and had
his entire world turned upside down.
This is as related by David Reynolds in
his fine history,
the long shadow.
He starts off by saying that Nash
enjoyed all these other areas of the war
and then writes quote,
but when Nash returned in November to
the rain and mode of passion,
Dale,
he was transfixed by quote the most
frightful nightmare of a country more
conceived by Dante or po.
Then by nature,
with no glimmer of God's hand to be seen
anywhere.
Sunrise and sunset or blasphemies
Reynolds says he exclaimed,
quote,
they are mockeries to man and quote.
Reynolds writes that the scene he says
was gilded with the colors of hell,
yellow stinking mud shell holes filled
with green whitewater,
black dying trees and unceasing shells
that churned up the land into a
graveyard.
Quote coding nationality.
I am no longer in artists interested in
curious.
I am a messenger who will bring back
word from the men who are fighting to
those who want the war to go on forever.
Feeble,
inarticulate will be my message,
but it will have a bitter truth and may
have burned their lousy souls.
And quote
British war correspondent,
Philip Gibbs was there,
has been.
If I keep us all over that battlefield
and he had a true admiration for not
just the English troops but all the
dominion troops to and what they
accomplished,
their sort of a doomed heroism and gibbs
was just blown away by what human beings
in these gallon soldiers were able to
achieve and nothing upset him more than
to hear later that Sir Douglas Haig.
The British commander had proclaimed
reports of the battlefield at
Passchendaele as being exaggerated.
This is how a very angry gibbs
responded.
Quote Sir Douglas Haig thinks that some
of the descriptions of that six months
horror where quote end quote exaggerated
as a man who knows something of the
value of words and who saw many of those
battles scenes in flanders and went out
from her many times during those months
and then he names all the places that
he'd been and ends up by saying and
beyond to polygon wood and Passion Dale,
where his dad lay meaning the dead.
That Haig was responsible for where his
dead lay in the swamps and round the
pillboxes and were tanks that are
wallowed into the mire were shot into
scrap.
Iron by German gunfire and where our own
guns were being flung up by the
harassing fire of heavy shells.
I say now that nothing that has been
written is more than a pale image of the
abomination of those battlefields and
that no pen or brush has yet achieved
the picture of that Armageddon in which
so many of our men perished and quote,
many people began to doubt British
military leadership just because they
would think you should ever fighting
conditions that were that bad.
There's a story and some people doubted,
ever happened.
It used to be something that was
mentioned by almost everyone writing
about passion Dale.
In his book in Flanders Fields.
Leon Wolf tells the story his way and
says the following day,
Lieutenant General Sir Lancelot Cagle
paid his first visit to the fighting
zone as a staff car lurched through the
swamp land and near the battleground,
he became more and more agitated.
Finally,
he burst into tears and muttered good
God.
Did we really send men to fight in that
the man beside him who had been through
the campaign replied tone.
Leslie gets worse further on up and to
quote some say,
it would be ridiculous to think that
these military folks had not been out to
the field and seeing the conditions are
known what they were like.
I'm not going to take a position on
that.
All I will suggest is that there were a
lot of people who looked at the
conditions of passion Dale and wondered,
you know,
what was going on in the heads of
Britain's military leaders.
Passchendaele is one of the most often
cited nightmares of this war to
Britain's along with the song and just
like the psalm,
it did terrible damage to Britain's
army,
British military historian John Keegan,
who is definitely in the Anti Haig camp,
wrote quote on the Psalm.
He had sent the flower of British youth
to death or mutilation at passchendaele.
He had tipped the survivors into the
slew of despond and quote for those in
Britain's political class that wished
the generals would pay more attention to
casualties.
They would get their wish,
but not for an entire generation.
The junior officers at places like
passchendaele would be permanently
affected by that battle.
British military writer Brigadier Peter
Young wrote,
quote,
the memory of this battle affected
British leadership in the Second World
War,
causing many commanders to go to
extremes to try to avoid casualties and
quote,
this attitude will come a generation too
late for leaders like Lloyd George,
he and his allies had tried to call off
the passchendaele campaign after the
first sort of impetus was spent only to
fail once again up against the military
leadership and was heard to say blood
and mud,
bloods and mod.
They can think of nothing better,
but it should be said,
even though the British are suffering,
these kinds of casualties,
so are the Germans and their soldiers
are being as tragically affected by this
fighting as the British soldiers.
The German general Hermann von Cool
wrote in his report about the troops
fighting in flanders quote,
the sufferings,
privation,
and exertions,
which the soldiers had to bear were
indescribable.
Terrible,
was the spiritual burden on the lonely
man in a shell hole or trench and
terrible.
The strain on the nerves during the
British bombardment,
which continued day and night,
the hell of Verdun and the Somme was
exceeded by flanders,
the battle,
the whole flanders has been the greatest
martyrdom of the war,
and looking back,
it seems that what was born here was
superhuman,
but perhaps it may still prove to be too
great.
A courageous sacrifice and to quote,
well,
what general cool didn't know December
1917 was that something was taking root
that would end up leading to the German
military commanders getting their hands
on between 500,000
and a million fresh veteran rested
soldiers.
Fate is about to put the dice,
the iron dice back into the hands of
Germany's leadership.
It's well known.
They are already inveterate gamblers and
the chance to try to throw a knockout
punch in a war where both sides like
badly beat up and permanently damaged
fighters will be irresistible.
Seems like no matter what Lloyd George
does,
there's more blood and mud and the
world's future.
In 1918.
Be sure to follow us on twitter.
The address is at hardcore history.
Get more hardcore history@DanCarlin.com.
If you think the show you just heard is
worth a dollar,
Dan and Ben would love to have it.
A buck a show.
It's all we ask.
Go to Dan Carlin.com
for information on how to donate to the
show.
I'd like to apologize for a couple of
things right off the bat.
The first thing is for silly little
persnickety mistakes
you can probably tell,
especially if you wait for these
programs to be released as we make them,
that I'm a bit of a nut when it comes to
detail and yet the people around me keep
telling me that there's a certain
failure rate that should be expected.
I'm not really good at accepting that,
especially when I catch the errors
before the show gets out.
Nonetheless,
this one will go out with me saying the
word trenches to describe the kinds of
fortifications that the British Orien at
passchendaele and of course shell holes
would be a much closer term.
I think trenches to those British
soldiers would have been a luxury on
that battlefield.
Nonetheless,
those are the pedal.
The little things that slipped through
our strainer here,
even when we catch them so that these
shows come out more than once a year,
which we are just barely beating that I
think right now,
heading toward once a year if this pace
keeps up.
So I apologize for the piddly little
errors in the past.
The ones in this show,
any in the future.
Um,
we try hard but we're not perfect.
The other thing I'd like to apologize
for his,
for perhaps ignoring your favorite part
of this story,
whatever that might be.
A favorite region,
a favorite army,
a favorite people or favorite event.
Picking a topic like this is humbling
and you know,
once again shows you some of the
potential downsides with our leap before
we look topic picking policy here on the
program.
Um,
nonetheless,
I will forgive in advance from now on.
I promise I've learned my lesson,
every historian and author who talks too
much about the western front at the
expense of other areas of the first
world war because you start to realize
why that becomes important.
This is a very confusing story.
There's a lot going on.
It would be so easy to go off in the
weeds and lose everybody.
I half the time worry about losing
myself in the story.
You end up sticking to the western front
and Russia and the United States as a
sort of an anchor to keep the story,
you know,
clinging to some sort of structure.
In some ways I think it's probably the
week hosts answer to the problem.
On the other hand,
every time you introduce theater and
another people and another in a region
and more names and individuals,
you make the story more and more
confusing.
The first world war is a giant topic.
What you're getting here,
and I say this about all of our
productions,
don't I?
You're getting the Dan Carlin version of
the first world war and unfortunately
that's leaving a lot of things out,
but I tell you what,
as a friend of mine once said,
perhaps we should look at it as just
leaving a lot more potential future
hardcore history topics available for us
to handle down the road.
In the next show,
we're going to make up some of the
deficit for the things we haven't talked
about and make up for some lost time in
the Middle East.
There are many things going on that
create,
you know,
the,
the beginnings of the modern world in
that region,
including important foundational events
that lay the groundwork for the modern
recreation of the ancient state of
Israel in that region in Russia.
We get to see what an intellectual
contagion that might be a good way to
describe it,
dropped down into the middle of the very
fertile petri dish that is provisional
government,
Russia can do to a country like that in
an answer to the question will perhaps
arise as to whether or not an army can
actually function if the soldiers get to
vote on whether they want to follow
orders or not.
And finally,
we'll get to see the arrival of US
troops in large numbers on the European
continent.
For the first time ever,
if I'm lucky and get what I want,
we will get to delve a little bit into
air power and how it's three
dimensionalizing battlefields and how
that technological race is a little
like,
you know,
Steve Jobs and Bill Gates and those guys
were involved in technology back in
1969,
1917.
They might very well be in airplane
development geeks.
These pilots in these planes are,
you know,
half Technological Geek and half
Medieval Knight.
We'll talk a bit about that if I get
lucky and I can make the time.
And finally we'll talk certainly about
the difference when both sides are
exhausted on the western front,
that half a million to a million fresh
troops can make,
and I'm not talking about American
troops,
I'm talking about the German soldiers
that arrive from the eastern front to
the western front can make on tired
French and British armies before the
Americans arrive in enough numbers to
make a difference.
The last year of the war is full of
surprises.
All that and more on part six of
blueprint for Armageddon.